[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
questions
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
s
for this cozy coastal town the holiday
season isn't over
in fact the most wonderful time of the
year has really just begun
and look at the intense focus on
magnus's face what a performance it has
been
once again vikon Zay starts the new year
as the center of the chess Universe this
year as host of the 85th Tata steel
chess tournament
a magnet for the best players in the
game some recognize the Masters field of
2023 as its strongest in recent memory
of course it helps when eight-time Tata
steel chess champion Magnus Carlson is
back the world's number one looks to
further cement his legacy in this event
and the game's history
chasing Magnus will be amongst the best
in chess several have been crowned
Champion here before some have even
shocked the world in doing so
the tournament and it is yours and fun
for race winning the dramatic Armageddon
don't leave out those poised to capture
their first Tata title
although winter Tata steel chess is also
known as the place new stars come to
bloom
Magnus one here is a teenager this
year's event has its fair share of young
players on the rise each hoping to
follow in Carlson's footsteps
he's not he snuck blood and he is not
letting the Dutch refer to Tata steel as
The Wimbledon of chess for 85 years in
running this tournament continues to be
steep in Prestige and Legacy and does so
again in this welcoming Little Dutch
town by the sea
mine Brendan it's the 85th edition of
the Tata steel chess tournament and it
starts right now
[Music]
welcome everybody to the first major
over-the-board classical term of the
year The Wimbledon of Chess it is the
Tata steel Chess Masters 2023 I'm
Grandmaster Robert Hess alongside me my
good friend International Master Tanya
sachev Tanya pleasure to be working with
you on this event
Robert I'm thrilled to be here for what
is the most prestigious event of the
chess calendar and what a lineup we have
the action that's about to come up I
think this is a unique unique edition of
the Tata steel because of the amazing
mix of players that we have and I can't
wait for the action
it is the 85th edition of this
tournament let's dive into its
tremendous history it's the first year
it was 1938 it's unbelievable to say
that and while it moved to Vikings day
in 1968 Tanya it's been the home of
Champions right look at that listen
names
it's just amazing stuff I mean when you
think of the greats of Chess they've all
won this event and gone on to show their
uh metal Robert and of course we've got
Magnus who's also won the event five
times and this is the reason why this is
known as The Wimbledon of Chess just the
great tradition of Tata steel off why
can't they to host this tournament 2022
was such a dramatic year we saw amazing
chess and online speeches format and now
it's time to slow the pace down to start
the year with the classical format with
what is the biggest event of the year
it's true and we have 14 hungry
competitors in this year's Edition and
as you said a great mix of players
because as we look at these faces on
screen here we have uh several former
Champions Magnus Carlson the top left
all the way down to Jordan Von forest in
the bottom right but Tanya we also have
these Indian teenagers your compatriots
you know them very well so a lot of
hungry teenagers in the mix with some of
the more veteran players I'm so excited
to see them in action Robert is not just
them I mean this is the youngest edition
of the Tata steel Masters we've got five
players in the field who are younger
than 20 years and of course the Indian
Brigade with pragnananda with Arjun and
gokish but not just them the standout
performer from the Olympia we've got
Noddy back Abdul satirov as well as the
German Prodigy Winston gamer yeah I'm
glad you brought all their names up
because we will be discussing them
throughout the show but let's not forget
about Fabiano caruana over there right
he is a former Champion levana Ronin has
won four times but as you mentioned it's
all about Magnus Carlson and his
dominance in Vikings a he returns for
the 2023 Edition as an eight-time
Champion he won last year and well his
runner-ups one player is notable in
particular anise Geary you know he's
always in that next place second place
but Magnus Carlson has been just superb
in Vikings a and here's a fun fact
Robert that before everyone who was tied
for the first place was in fact a joint
winner but only in the recent editions
that they have the playoffs and Anish
has actually been a huge victim of that
because he's gone on to play the tie for
the first place twice once against
Magnus which he lost that finish second
and then the very famous one against
Jordan van Forrest in 2021 which he
again lost on tie breaks and lost the
championship
that was a heartbreaker I was commenting
that with sopico gurm is really Anish
giri's wife and it was a sad sight to
see as he just made that mistake nearing
that little bit of increment at the end
but uh Jordan Forest was a deserving
Champion but Magnus Carlsen the
eight-time champion he returns to
Vikings a and let's you know what the
format is because it's a bit different
than most of the round Robins you see
because this is a longer event Tanya
more grueling 13 Rounds for these 14
players and one player just one earned
their spot here by winning a tournament
and well I think you know a thing or two
about that player
who won the Tata steel challenges it
went and then qualified so he's not one
of the invited participants he qualified
earned his spot to play in the Masters
this year uh not just Arjun in fact
great players from India like Hari
Krishna with it and adiban have won the
Challenger section before making Arjun
the fourth Indian to win the challenges
last year and it's going to be really
fun to see what he does amongst the big
boys this year because we all know the
phenomenal performance that Arjun has
had in 22. he's one of those players who
suddenly broke out in the scene and
there was no stopping him
well some of the players in this field
would like to stop him but you are right
he was a breakout performer along with
the likes of noribbeck Abdul sitarov and
some of these you know teenagers that
are in the field so let's talk about the
pairings because round one is set to
begin very shortly we have
so many good matchups I don't even know
where to take us so what's the first
matchup that catches your eye Tanya I
mean look at these two absolute best
players of the world fighting each other
this is the El Clasico of Chess Magnus
Carlsen the reigning world champion in
all three formats and Rapid Blitz and
the classical is taking on Lebanon you
mentioned an interesting point earlier
Robert that Magnus has won the daughter
steal eight times Levon is the other
player who's wanted most number of times
after Magnus four championships well
there's one player who's won it five
times Robert and that is
currently not in the field but he is in
vacancy right now yes he is I saw that
photo he was with the other Indian
players So speaking of them we have a
matchup between pragyananda and Arjun
aragaisi in the very first round so I
know your loyalties are split here you
can't root for anybody in general but
what do you make of that matchup where
pragnanda has the white pieces I mean
Arjun was the breakout performer but
Prague Nanda has beaten Magnus many
times at least in the online events I
mean this is gonna be one hell of a
match between this this all Indian face
of prop taking on Arjun in the very
first round now frog has sort of
established himself amongst the elite
but that has been in the rapid format
going back to his uh 2022 season of the
Champions Chester you know he feels
right at home while this is actually the
first time for Arjun playing in the Tata
steel Masters an Invitational Elite
event Prague has also played in the 2021
Edition so I think even though Prague is
younger than Arjun Arjun at 19 and
Prague currently 17 years old Brock's
the one who's got a little more
experience in this event
wow the irony the you know the age
belies the experience but let's say you
know look at the Players because they're
on screen they're uh here they're in the
playing Hall in Vikings and I see on the
screen there that's Richard report is
the white pieces against nerdy back up
to zatarov and no dearbeck is looking
sharp right now
he's all suited up not just him I also
see Winston on our screen absolutely
ready to go and one player I'm looking
forward to seeing an action is dangler
in we just haven't watched enough of him
uh he's had difficulties playing from
China so it's kind of nice to have him
back and we saw a little Applause there
and that usually happens in Vikings when
there's a guest who comes in uh makes a
special move and the inauguration Robert
I'm so happy to see a full haul here
because this is what wike is known for
this is what this event is known for but
in 2021 because I'm 22 because of
covered reasons we didn't have uh so
many Spectators in media but today and
this year it's a full house and there we
have handshakes and we are gonna have
the first moves but what you said is
completely true we see Spectators in the
background it is a beloved event it is a
true chess Festival they call it the
Wimbledon of chess for a reason and we
have Magnus Carlsen the eight-time
champion in Vikings taking on Lavon
Ronin a four-time champion in his own
right the opening moves just getting
underway but it is true that it's great
to see everybody back in the building
all of the amateur sections and the
Challenger section the winner of which
makes their way to the Masters next year
so I love to see all the friendly faces
invite but no longer are the players
friendly Tanya it is game time it's game
time and I don't know about opening
surprises Robert but the one thing
that's already surprised me is just how
sober 11 aronians fashion choices today
that's not something we're used to we
love the bright shirts we love the big
Prince uh but the first opening surprise
here by Lavon aronian with a new style
statement
well I think he's just going to show
that it's it's both a great honor to
play against Magnus Carlsen but it's
never particularly Pleasant especially
when you have the black pieces and Lavon
has chosen you know Queen's game of
decline setup if we just go through uh
the position we can see that his Pawn is
on D5 Magnum still has his pawn and C4
so we are getting the Catalan opening
from Magnus Carlson it's something that
he worked on for his world championship
match against Yonder palmchi it
continues to play it to this day and
well the players you know they're just
getting started you can see them making
those slow moves and finally that policy
Force capture Tanya yeah and that indeed
this was the opening that we saw in
Dubai in the world championship match
between Magnus and janapamnushi and he
hasn't stopped since uh to employ the
Catalan with quite a bit of success we
see the move Queen C2 he wants to pick
up the pawn on C4 uh with the queen A6
blade so if you don't do that right now
black will go B5 and defend the pawn
that's right so Queen 64 will be met by
B5 anyway that's why Magnus plays A4 and
something we've seen from Magnus more
and more is this willingness to you know
beat down material for a little bit play
this Catalan style control the center
but after Bishop D7 it feels like it is
time for Queen takes E4 and there's just
one thing to note here Tanya there's
sometimes this trick with Bishop to B5
it's a funny little tactic it doesn't
work out here that's why the bishop
parked on C6 but if we can just show
really quickly that Bishop B5 if you
take this bishop you actually fall
victim to a problem with this Rook
hanging on C1 and this queen under
attack on C4 so just a little Blitz
trick for those of you at home and
especially if this Knight or if ever to
venture to D2 let's say just throwing a
random move Knight D2 then comes Bishop
B5 because behind the queen is a hanging
Pawn on E2 and you still have this
problem with your capture on B5 your
Rook on A1 is loose that's such a nice
tactical trick rabbit especially as you
mentioned for bullet and for Blitz you
know you go Bishop B5 pretend that it's
a mouse slip but indeed it's not uh but
of course this is classical and uh the
players are not going to fall for this
bishop on C6 is where you want to place
this bishop when you're not playing for
tricks because you have to challenge
that Bishop on G2 which is the Monstrous
Catalan Bishop if black succeeds in
trading that off happy camper exactly
the bishop 1 G2 usually the strongest
piece on the board and so that Bishop is
well placed on C6 and we know what white
wants to eventually play E4 but because
of the Bishop's placement that's very
very difficult to make work with both
the bishop and Knight staring at the
center so uh levonne aronian you know he
had a tough year in 2022 over the
chessboard had some you know happy
occasions in his personal life of course
uh he is a new father he is one of two
fathers in the field along with Anish
Geary but at least in terms of his
classical chess Tanya it was a rough
year the Olympiad in Chennai did not go
his way he had a great time uh you know
the people were so friendly and he
really enjoyed the atmosphere but his
rating took a big hit
um Love is probably one of the most
creative players of all time one of the
chess greats and it has been a
disappointing past uh past year for him
also the move the Federation move I
think there was just so much going on in
his personal life so he's here to really
prove a point Robert I think this
tournament means so much for him to
really make that come back he's 40 years
old he is the oldest player in the field
and his opponent Magnus Carlson the
eight-time winner the world champion is
32 years old actually the second oldest
player in the field
yes no that's really wild to think about
when Magnus Carlson is one of the oldest
players in the field you know time has
passed because he's been the number one
rated player since 2011. it's been a
long time when since Magnus Carlson took
that throne and Levon aronia has been at
the absolute top for many years as well
for decades and I I think most of the
Chess World would like to see him bounce
back from a rough chess year in 2022 but
he has his focus on the board he is
trying to figure out how to uh continue
this position uh but what's interesting
is after Magnus Bishop G5 sorry that was
on me I didn't uh load the move there
that this Knight can at some point be
captured on F6 right Tanya because E4 is
White's plan Don't Take Your Eyes Off of
Bishop takes F6 especially if Knight C3
is on the board allowing for E4 next
you definitely want to go for that
Center control so Bishop G5 86 doesn't
really help because you kind of provoke
white to do what you want and it's
interesting to see that Magnus already
walks up gets up takes a little takes a
little round around uh to check out some
other boards uh so feeling relaxed and
Levon goes into a bit of a think after
Bishop G5 that surprises me and I wonder
if Bishop G5 Robert is uh maybe not the
most popular move in this position
you know it could be one of those
moments where I mean it has been played
many times I've faced it myself but it's
just one of those situations wait what
does Magnus want in this game because
you know as you know of course as such a
high level player who's still very
competitive I saw you there at the
Olympiad I know uh you know you were out
there performing really well but um you
know these type of decisions right what
does Magnus want from me today what is
he going for so I think Lavon is just
going to take a little bit of time get
settled in this tournament so tell you
what he well he does that what do you
say we go to the bird's eye view and
find a new game to check out what I'm
also what I'm also going to say is
Robert you were the team the captain of
the US women team so you mentioning the
Olympiad still breaks my heart at times
because uh the memory of that still
hurts but yes we should move on and take
a look at some of the other openings
that are going on uh and do you want to
check out what's happening in the other
clash of the age here we've got the two
big youngsters now there's such great
narratives and storyline in this event
one of them is of course he's
established Elite these very top players
in the world how do they handle this a
new wave of talent this new generation
that is so hungry for success but the
other part is also to see how this new
generation plays against each other
their compatriots their colleagues but
they're also friends there's such strong
healthy competition between them so it's
going to be interesting to see who does
better than who and we've got Prague
against the origin to start that off so
let's jump over to that one
okay let's go right in the battle of the
youngsters the teenagers and just so
everybody knows you know the the memory
that Tom is just Unleashed is when I was
coaching the U.S women's team in the
final round we were playing against you
and you won that Rook end game in that
round and of course for my team I was uh
heartbroken but then you and I we uh
went uh you know out afterwards and I I
forgave you the night of so uh you know
I'm not I'm not talking about that one
drop it I'm talking about this year in
Chennai the final round that we had the
Indian women team fighting for the gold
medal and we played against the U.S
women team and we actually lost that
match and it was the only game that I
lost at the Olympiad uh I eventually had
to we had to settle for the bronze as
well as the individual bronze so still
some heartbreak moments but it's good
it's nice of you to remind me of the
earlier matchup so there has been some
India versus U.S uh rivalry going on at
the Olympic God
indeed but right now it is India versus
India on this board between the
youngsters prognananda and Arjun here so
we have a pretty classical grunfeld
setup so uh we can go back and just go
through the moves of how we got here
nothing too major nothing too special
out of the norm of the grunfeld has
occurred D5 strikes in the center now
when white plays E4 black is enticed to
take and we get the two Pawns in the
center for white versus just one for
black but what does black get in turn
it's Bishop G7 Pawn C5 just trying to
Target this long diagonal so Tanya as we
see this game develop this classical
system with Bishop C4 and 92 to my eyes
this all looks very familiar
indeed it doesn't this is such a such a
topical way to play such a popular way
to play this opening for both sides and
you mentioned a white controlling the
center but the drawback of that is that
these pawns can immediately become
targets as well I love the way that
black actually goes on and proceeds to
develop the two Bishops fan Shadows them
so that one of them can attack D4 the
other one on B7 targets the E4 Pawn so
why does gotta be careful yes you've got
a great Center but it can often become a
point of play for black white has to
decide when to push these pawns do you
go E5 you go D5 which Bishop do you
block it's a very Dynamic opening the
grunfield and I love that the two
players are fighting it out in this one
because this goes to show that this is
going to be a big game
it certainly is and oftentimes black
gives up a part or at least allows white
to take a Pawn on C5 and just a couple
moves ago that was indeed possible when
black played the move B6
um just to show everybody that D takes
E5 would win a pawn because the bishop
does protect the square but you don't
actually really get all that much for it
because when black plays Queen z7 if you
say give me this Pawn uh all of a sudden
these lines are open for blacks pieces
you have isolated pawns so you are ahead
by one Pawn but you see the evaluation
says level zeros and the players know
that so that is why white doesn't get
greedy in the early going instead after
B6 is let's continue the development the
strong central pawns are more important
than the material
yeah that's too much activity to give up
Santa you can't afford to get greedy in
modern chess it's really all about the
initiative and in those kind of
positions where white would go for the
pawn uh it would be black with all the
play and the activity black has just
made the move E6 so making sure that the
bishop on C4 is blunted and plus it's
also against the move D5 because now
that would just go on to create a
weakness you can still pick up the pawn
on C5 but I think it doesn't matter at
all Robert black doesn't need to bother
even Queen D2 as an option but even the
line that you just mentioned step away
with the queen and play for the activity
still holds strong
yes it does and this move D5 you want to
play it if you could play Pawn to C4
afterwards that way you have a protected
pass paw in the center but with the
bishop on C4 you may just lose a pawn
because the move D5 may run into Knight
A5 with Tempo and then because this
bishop 1 B7 is nicely placed the pawn
may just fall so look at this F3 from
prognanda we have very solid play I
think people are misled when they think
about young players they always tactics
and we know both these players have
vicious tactical Minds our generic
geissy I remember that Blitz game in
particular against Fabiano caruana where
he Unleashed a vision attack and
defeated him it was that the grand Swiss
the tall Memorial Blitz tournament where
Arjun performed very well so I mean we
think of these wonderful tactical
sequences but at the end of the day they
are well-rounded chess players just
because they're young doesn't mean they
can't play solid chess with a healthy
Center and for black playing with the
bishop pair staring at that White Center
makes a style
can Universal is that they are extremely
aggressive players who play Fearless
chess but very often the aggression and
the attacking style is based on a very
solid positional Foundation you'll never
see them go completely crazy and without
finishing development without keeping
everything in control to play uh you
know to just go all out in a position
and that's what we see Prague do here
he's made sure that the center is kept
intact I like to move F3 it just makes
sure that the bishop and B7 does not get
too active does not get too strong uh
Robert this is going to develop slowly
but I am predicting this one to be quite
the combative fight in the middle game
and interesting uh interesting thing
about these two players in bike is that
they're there with a bit of company
we've got Arjun who's there along with
his longtime trainer a good friend who
was also part of the national team as
the captain Grand Master srinath Narayan
and who by the way is a Catalan expert
but we'll get back to that later so he's
there along with Arjun he does accompany
him to several events he's quite a big
support while Prague is also there with
his longtime trainer RB Ramesh not just
Ramesh Frog's younger sister vaishali
who is part of the national Indian women
team one of the very big upcoming stars
of in women chess uh is playing in The
Challengers alongside Prague here
it's a really good thing to point out
because on one hand it's always great to
be surrounded by friends especially at a
chess tournament that's so long and
grueling like this one but to be
surrounded by family as well that is
very wonderful and these two players
they're friendly of course they know
each other quite well at this point and
as you mentioned a certain special guest
is in Vikings as well viswanathan Anand
photographed with those players so a lot
of company there but at the end of the
day chess is an individual game and the
result is fully on their young shoulders
so we'll leave uh origin to it after the
move F3 he has a lot to figure out how
to play Maybe Rook C8 take on D4 the
right moment you don't do it too early
and then play for the queen side but
it's clear that he is going to spend
some time at this moment so let's go to
the bird's eye view take a look at our
seven boards we can see in the top left
Magnus Carlson did take that Knight on
F6 uh levonne provoked him into doing it
with the move Pawn 87 to H6 so we have
uh you know a bishop traded for a knight
but the E4 Square that's where the fight
is going to be
um Tanya I'm looking at the second game
from the left in the bottom row Jordan
van Forrest against Wesley so both these
players have won this tournament before
but we have a queenless position there
so a typical cabinet line but without
Queen so maybe not so much tactical
flare and honestly the game in the
middle in the bottom row Richard report
against
that looks like an old school Vienna
type position but there's a black Pawn
on F5 which almost looks like you know
that shouldn't be there
yeah that one looks like a lot of fun
and just speaking about Wesley uh we
mentioned how levon's looking to have a
good performance in this one it's been a
while Wesley also mentioned that after
his win in the global Championship that
he wants to focus and improve his
classical results because he had a shaky
year so Wesley's also in tata steel to
try and really start the yo well set the
tone for the rest of the year but this
is where the action is uh the two very
creative players here in the field not a
bag against the Richard rapper Richard
with the white pieces I I have to say
Robert in modern chess I would say that
Richard is perhaps the most creative
player that I know of
this is always so exciting it is because
he plays like the most random opening
sometimes objectively dubious openings
but he makes fireworks happen and he uh
you know is a player that is just
created by Nature he loves that kind of
style but sometimes it can in fact
backfire and look at this position right
now I'm not saying that Richard's in
trouble because it's so early in the
game but I do think we have to analyze
this position just from the first few
moves because you don't see the move F4
in the style of the king's Gambit in
this case the Vienna game played at the
highest level that often and I know if
Dania was here he would be so happy
because he is a big proponent of the
Vienna game but F4 by Richard Port he's
showing no fear and it's a romantic
style of chess
and I really like that naughty bag did
not back down he didn't go into a long
thing but he's gone on to show that you
know what yes you play something random
you play something that I wasn't
expecting old school and aggressive but
I'm ready for it the thing with these
openings often is Robert if black knows
what to do and how to respond you can
get out of it without too much trouble
so let's take a look at how nordeback
went on to handle this opening surprise
by Richard yeah he did not take this
Pawn F4 which hands wiped the center it
said he fights for the center himself
with the move D5 this is the principled
way to play because now we have tension
between these Pawns in the center white
takes on E5 gives up the E4 pawn and
queen F3 is put that may look very
strange but black has the immediate
threat of Queen H4 check this is why you
don't like to move or lose your f-pawn
that's the golden pawn and queen H4
check would be a threat so that's a
queen F3 is played so if you give this
check quite simply has to move Pawn G3
to block bucket so F5 Tanya I've never
seen this group before in this opening
and already as of move five I am
watching a new position unfold for me
personally
and that is amazing because we don't see
that or hear that often Robert I mean
you're a Grandmaster you would have seen
everything under the sun and to say that
in move five black plays a move that
hasn't happened before maybe you can get
a confirmation if this is indeed a
novelty or not but definitely not a
position that we see every day or even
close to that in high level chess F5
played so you want to really reinforce
that Knight on e4 what is happening here
white has the option to go on for song
but I wouldn't do that because that just
seems like it would help uh black to
develop further
yeah taking on F6 the Knight can just
take back and this queen is misplaced
right we typically don't like moving Our
Queen out so early when this bishop
develops and the King castles the queen
is in line with the Rook this bishop can
come to G4 it's a moment with tempo as
well so that is why instead of taking on
F6 and opening up the board more he went
D3 forcing The Exchange on C3 and after
it takes back look at this D4 already we
see upon not C3 threatened if you take
on D4 thank you very much in comes the
queen which hits the rook in the corner
and the pawn on E5 a double attack
winning material on the spot so this is
not an easy moment for Richard I really
think that this position is uh
complicated in a way that you know he
needs to figure out am I going to give
up this Pawn on C3 maybe that's not the
end of the world uh but how is he going
to keep the pawn on E5 that's a bit
overextended that's the big question
that I have Tanya
I mean I love D4 has D4 been played
already
yeah it uh I'm looking at as well in the
past this position has happened 30 times
at The Master Level at least so it's not
uh brand new but it is very rare and I
wonder you know what the level of those
players are because if we're being
honest these uh 2700 plus players
sometimes they cut the ratings off where
they're like only look at games from
other Grandmasters but they have to be
looking at all games because this move
d4 it's getting sharp and I mean look at
this Knight C6 Nexus Pawn E5 is such a
Target
such a Target and if you go C4 trying to
keep things close black also has the
option to give a check on B4 which would
force you to either move the king or
intercept the check with the bishop
either ways you will lose all rights to
Castle for the rest of the game not
something that you want uh even after C
takes the voice you're pointing out
Queen D4 with a double attack on E5 and
A1 which makes me think that white has
to find a way to defend the C3 pawn and
a move like Bishop D2 just developing
trying to keep the C3 Pawn under control
hoping that you take it I go Bishop C3
defend the E5 Pawn maybe bishop D2 is
something that Richard needs to consider
here
yeah you know Bishop D2 definitely comes
to mind I'm still so worried about this
Pawn E5 but maybe I shouldn't be maybe
white can Sly Queen G3 play Knight F3
like that and maybe Tanya it's not the
end of the world if you give up the C3
Pawn because while black is getting
material it's caught costs him some time
so Queen G3 then Knight F3 play and a
sacrificial romantic style he did play
the Vienna Tanya so I feel like it's not
out of the question that he gives up
some material in the first 10 moves
I completely agree you can't play the
Vienna a Gambit and then just be like
I'm gonna play slow and defend all my
pawns you've got to go all out you say A
you say B you say we Anna you gotta go a
lot Queen G3 give up that C3 Pawn lots
of ideas here Richard having a think uh
interesting that he decided to go for
this line but in fact nordeback's the
one who's put him in a think tank right
now Richard do we have a move d4 uh do
we have a move after D4
no we don't have a move from uh Richard
here and he that's not a great sign when
you play an offbeat opening that's not
really chosen at the highest level that
often and then you're the one thinking
now he hasn't spend that much time and
we see the players at the board uh
Richard just trying to calculate what to
do but that's what he's doing right he's
calculating at least it seems that way
not relying on engine prep and memory so
that's good as a chess fan but if you're
the chess player Tanya we know that
feeling very well when we are out of our
prep and our opponent makes a pretty uh
move like D4 attacking stuff cutting off
the pawns from each other I feel like
he's might be a little bit worried
100 I mean if this was uh Blitz or rapid
you would be shaking right now but the
good thing is that this is a classical
time control you've got the time to
actually navigate and look through your
problems and I like that Richard has
slowed down he's not trying to play Mind
Games by continuing to play Fast he
acknowledges that D4 is not part of his
prep it's something that's taken him by
surprise it's a critical moment he needs
to make a commitment here does he give
up the pawn does he try to defend it but
go into a position where he would be
behind development some big questions
for Richard to answer here uh but
knowing Richard's style of play Robert I
think he isn't gonna shy away from
playing for the initiative I like your
idea of going Queen G3 maybe we can take
a look at the positions that arise uh
after a move like that you take on C3
Knight F3 continue with your development
you go Bishop E2 you go shot castle and
you play this position uh it's an option
yeah the engine at first doesn't like it
but uh maybe there's a different way to
play because I see here after DC3 the
eval Bar says it's still pretty level
and the players don't know that right we
have the benefit of looking and I'm
guessing that the move actually starting
with Bishop E2 because that threatens
Bishop H5 check it's a Tempo gaining
move and this is way too intricate like
I would never without the help of the
eval bar off the side think about moving
my Bishop first because Knight F3 seems
so logical the square was just cleared
but actually if Knight C6 I think white
is in fact going to play the move Bishop
to H5 check and you see the evaluation
go Sky High because if you play G6 thank
you very much let's sacrifice a piece
and your king is being hunted very
quickly caught in the center and it's
already it's completely winning for
white the reason why is after King D7
give me more pawns the King has to go
back and forth so at minimum white has a
draw but I think the simple answer is E6
check your King has to go up because it
goes to the side as Bishop to G5 oh uh
winning the queen and if you go up to D6
I'm sure E7 check is just winning
because you have to take and still
Bishop G5 winning that Queen
that is destruction on the board I mean
I love this idea of going Queen G3
bishopy to develop your pieces and
threaten the bishop on H5 uh Richard's
still having a long think here
I wouldn't I I have a feeling Robert
that he's actually considering where he
wants to put his Queen has he made his
choice not yet because you also do have
the option to go Queen G3 or to go that
Queen G3 looks really nice where else
are you going to put the queen
no according to this seems just the most
logical keeps the bishop stuck in place
because the pawn on G7 would be hanging
it protects E5 at the same time but this
like Bishop E2 leading the way it's not
really intuitive I would say just
because uh we tend to want to bring our
pieces as advanced as possible and the
E2 Square isn't that appealing uh by
itself but then when you think about
Bishop H5 check it starts to make some
sense but again Richard didn't prepare
this he's trying to figure out at the
board so I feel like it's really really
hard to come up with that without the
help of that eval bar off the side
screen Tanya I don't have the specific
moves we just have the bar but still
that is a huge hint for us as
commentators versus the players who are
just like I don't know I might already
be worse and the answer is he's not
worth the moment but he may be in the
next few moves but the eval bar makes it
pretty clear that D4 in fact is the
right direction for black to go for so
one gets the feeling that norderbeck had
some idea how to handle this position he
sort of blitzed out his move so far uh
not taken that much time after being
surprised with the Vienna and I like
that I like D4 big questions Robert and
I feel that white has got this idea to
go Queen G3 and continue with
development but that is very committed
because you are sacrificing upon Richard
needs to take this call uh Robert should
we go back and take a look at what is
happening on some of our other boards
let's do that indeed so Richard has lots
to figure out so do some of the other
players and as we look across the screen
here para maxulu against Vincent kymer
in the bottom right hand side of the
screen that looks like a ready type of
position you know out of the English
kind of a benoni structure colors
reverse
um where else have we not looked the
bottom left who cash against ningly Ren
that looks like a very standard position
where no pieces have been traded uh
Tanya and then the top right Fabiano
caruana with the white pieces in sort of
like a Queen's Gambit accepted type of
position I would think those colors
would be reversed in fact but it's
Fabiano who doesn't go with his standard
E4 or D4 but he actually pushed the C
Pawn early
yeah a Queen's Gambit type a position
where white still hasn't committed the
Deep Pawn but very interesting uh that
these two again we've been talking about
compatriots playing against each other
with Magnus taking on left Prague taking
on Arjun and I think this is also one
such matchup with uh Fabi with the white
pieces against Anish these are two heavy
favorites yeah uh the two two of the
world's best players fighting this
starting the Tata steel with quite a
fighting match and now this kind of a
position Robert whenever we see it it
feels like white really hasn't done much
you know you haven't really Advanced
your pieces beyond the third rank none
of your pawns are controlling important
squares wait why is white playing so
passive but actually these positions do
have a lot of poison they're slow starts
but white has got so much flexibility
you can decide to put your C1 Bishop on
B2 there are plans with B3 Bishop B2 the
diagonal is still open the one advantage
of not having pushed the Deep Pawn
meanwhile black does have activity with
moves like C5 but you still need to cast
so again these are slow positions but
just because they don't look scary it
doesn't mean that we won't have a rich
middle game I like it when White's
Bishop lands on B2 the queen goes to C2
The Rook comes to D1 The Rook comes to
C1 at some opportune moment you can
decide to go D4 lots of plans to play
for here for white
no I like the way you just describe the
position because I feel the same way I
look at him like did white even move yet
did Black get a couple free turns but
you mentioned the king is still the
center for black so that will take a
couple turns and I would also note this
Pawn on B5 sticks out so while white
doesn't have a single piece past the
third rank black has a pawn that is
extended quite far which means a timely
A4 could in fact be a problem for black
and just to put a position on the board
it's not about the evaluation right now
it's about a theme that if black were to
play B4 and this Knight had a move say
back to B1 look at the C4 square look at
the B3 Square these are squares that are
white for the taking and whether this
d-pawn goes to D3 or D4 this Pawn can go
to B3 and eventually white can take over
the C4 square and the C file as a whole
where there's a backwards Pawn that a
rook can stare at so this is a big
moment in the next couple of turns where
if white does play A4 that's fabi's
choice uh Anish will have to figure out
what to do with this B5 Paul because
playing C6 gives you an ugly Bishop
looks like a pawn back there but playing
B4 gives it the white squares so I think
Now's the Time Tanya for Fabi to play A4
very nice I actually think you're right
like A4 is a plan that you have but
maybe it's the moment already taking
advantage of Black's lack of development
uh because black has gone on to push the
a6b5 bonds creating some weakness it's a
bit give and take you've got to be
careful of those pawn moves A4
immediately directed but then Fabi has
to be okay with bringing that Knight
back to B1 uh he is taking his time he
is having a think right now does he want
to commit with A4 does he want to wait
here uh again the position looks
harmless but I would take white hair in
this opening just feels like more plans
for white hair to try and create
weaknesses in Black scam right and I
think you were illustrating this better
than anyone could that the move d4 is so
tempting because why not push your pawn
two squares take control but you refrain
from and I think that's the right
decision from a practical standpoint
because oftentimes black can play C5 and
gives black an immediate Target in the
center trades are being offered and I
really am partial to this move A4 D4 is
good B3 is good all of these are options
but I think I like the style that you
and I are coming up with with instead of
playing D4 so early we'll leave our
d-pawn in its place and play on the
queen side more so so I think that Bobby
has a big Choice my eyes are set on the
Move A4 but he is uh the former
Challenger to the World Chess
Championship for a reason he knows these
positions uh you know he's a good feel
for them but Anish did this for a reason
as well right he took on C4 he played in
the style maybe he was surprised by
Bobby's first couple moves but still he
made this choice so you have to think
that Anish Geary one of the best
prepared players in the world knows what
he he's doing as well
well you know you know Fabi really well
you guys are good friends so I wouldn't
be surprised if you and Fabi are in
sincere and Fabi goes for your idea with
A4 he is he has slowed down he is taking
a bit of a think here right now and
rightfully so because really it's the
moment where you have to decide if you
want to force black to play B4 and I
don't really see another way for black
to counter the movie for uh it's kind of
hard to defend the B5 Pawn so you've got
to commit with B4 give the C4 square and
them just hope that white takes enough
time to go d392 and create some some of
your own play as a niche again this is
going to be quite an important moment
that will decide how this game how the
middle game evolves Robert while Fabi
decides if it's the moment to go A4 or
not should we take a look at some of the
other boards we definitely should
because two big things have happened I
look at the second board from the right
in the second row here Arjun aragi has
captured a Pawn on H4 so the position is
getting spicier as the H Pawn is just
gone from Prague known as kingside and
I'm also looking at the game between
Richard report and abusotarov because
Richard actually played Bishop E2 first
so he knows the position he found that
tactical sequence and instead of taking
on C3 Nordic decides to just develop his
Knight first so just to note that
Richard he found the idea he discovered
it and for I think I mean I know we
haven't looked at all the games but
there's a missing Pawn the H file in the
game between Prague Not An Origin I'm
just curious how this is acceptable
right like he just gave him a pawn I
mean you've got to take a look at that
we will come back to the northern back
board where it where's the H Pawn I mean
this position would be absolutely normal
with the pawn on H2 but it's gone so I
think we've got to take a look at how
that happened and why did Prague just
decide to give this Pawn with H4
yeah because we left off around here
Rook C8 very good normal move getting
ready to open the C file at some point
with CD4 H4 played by proc in this
position and I'm looking and I see just
a couple of games have been played in
this line so it's a rare move and the
point is that if Queen takes H4 it looks
like a free Pawn your queen is in grave
danger Bishop G5 Queen H5 only safe
square and Knight G3 traps the queen on
the H5 Square so that's very clear right
don't take immediately your queen gets
trapped but Tanya look what happened in
the game Knight A5 Bishop goes back take
take and now Queen takes H4 because the
big difference is it Bishop G5 Queen H5
and you try your knight G3 the queen is
in fact trapped but Bishop takes D4 is a
pretty important check because your king
is in trouble
but is that over after Bishop D4 Rook F2
because your queen is eternally in
trouble no
yeah the queen is trapped here but look
at how many pieces you'll get for it
you'll take on C1 let's say a trade
you'll take on F2 check the king is back
it maybe this queen can escape even to
the H2 Square now look at the eval bar
this is insane it says it's like even
here that's shocking to me uh the queen
escapes so how in the world is this just
even like maybe it's the dark squares
around this King that are a problem
somehow but the queen survives
hmm very strange
we're lost for words here I mean queen
H4 is on the board and we might be
seeing this line because if you've given
given up the h-bond you've got to go for
this you can't just stay still as well
so what is the current live position
that we've got
just this is the position yes and by the
way Tara look at the clock Arjun still
has a ton of time and it's prognan Nanda
who has been things of progress thinking
here he may not be that intimately
familiar with the details and if that's
the case he's now down upon us to figure
it out
wow and take a look at that our
tournament Hall our venue there's so
many Spectators there to just give an
idea where that's like it's it's just
packed with people like you mentioned
it's a chess Festival there are so many
events going on and just beyond this
crowd of Spectators there is the amateur
event that's on as well so it's a crowd
it's a house full of uh chess happening
but of course all the spectators are
here to see uh these elite players in
action the Masters and The Challengers
and I think we do have a move here by
Prague
okay we see prog you know reaching he
did in fact bring his Bishop to G5
attacking the queen so he may see the
sequence of the queen going to H5 and uh
not quite getting trapped but what you
were just saying I want to Echo that uh
because I've been to Vikings a a number
of times just the atmosphere is so
wonderful it's all these people uh
mostly Dutch you know uh players and
fans who come to the location they watch
every game there's the cafe right nearby
where they have live commentary uh where
someone sits in the cafe it's a rotation
of uh Dutch players and Grandmasters who
go over the games and you can ask
questions uh to them directly so it's
just a wonderful wonderful atmosphere uh
full of love and appreciation for chess
and many strong players in those amateur
sections who will one day make their way
up to this top Master section Jordan van
Forest is a testament to that right he
grew up through uh you know that circuit
he played in many Dutch events in
hogovan in now here in Vikings and now
he's playing at the top uh tournament
for many years running
it is a great energy there Robert and it
really does motivate and Inspire the
players as well to play some inspiring
chess I've played that twice actually uh
in the C group and it was uh probably it
is my favorite chess memory I missed my
Grandmaster number half a point and it
is such a
it's such a such a great feeling to be
able to share the same Hall in the same
space as the world champions as the
future world champions and the greatest
players and they're all there together
playing here so truly a unique unique
event and I do see Bishop G5 on the
board like has gone by Queen H5 people
looking at the line with Knight G3 one
also gets the feeling that black screen
on H5 is actually stuck for a while you
mentioned the threat Bishop D4 and while
you were talking about the venue I was
just wondering Robert what if white
takes it a little slow because I've got
time on my hands what if I actually
block that Bishop on G7 a thematic idea
of E5 to do that so that there's no
pressure on D4 and now I've got a
monster stat of going Knight G3 next
targeting your queen you've got no
squares how are you going to counter
that
I love what you're saying because we
were talking about 93 traps the queen
but hangs D4 and then it's a tactical
sequence so E5 takes care of the big
problem stopping white from playing
Knight to G3 so E5 looks very strong
shutting down this bishop here on G7 I
think that black would have no choice
other than trying to play for the move
F6 and I think you could swap Brooks I'm
not sure if that's necessary but you
play this with F6 because now the bishop
is hanging and if e takes F6 Bishop
takes F6 we are freeing Our Queen along
the fifth rank it's not the end of the
story because Black's King is going to
be weaker than White's King even the
event of a bishop trade but we see the
evaluation bar it's hovering around the
middle saying it's a level position and
I believe
I yeah if I played by Prague but I think
and you know these players very well
Tanya I feel like prognan is figuring it
out a little bit at the board he has
done some preparation of course but he's
figuring out somewhat at the board where
Arjun knows this from his preparation
he's shown that I've seen interviews
with him where uh there's one with him
and Vichy where they're talking about a
position and then Arjun keeps going and
keeps going in the variation and and
then she's like did you look at this and
Arden's like yeah I did so I feel like
Arjun knows this position like
definitively and prognan is he's kind of
figuring out a little bit on his own
and it's very interesting what you
mentioned because uh the incident that
you're talking about was in fact from
the Tata steel chess India event that
happened in Kolkata in November uh in 22
and it was a match between Arjun and
nehal nehal with the black pieces and
Arjun showed this incredible 34 move
preparation and just blitzed out every
move and then nehal had to find Just One
Last accurate move but it's such a
difficult one he failed to do so Arjun
went on to win that game and it was some
insane prep I think Anish also tweeted
about it because the last move was
absolutely obnoxious and Unthinkable
just a simple F3 I remember in a
position uh Wishy was super impressed
that was a big win for Arjun which went
on to show the kind of prep that he
comes up with and Robert you were
mentioning the move F6 to attack that
Bishop on G5 against the threat of
Knight G3 it's very important to play it
like this and not eight six at first it
might seem that 86 has the same idea in
fact you don't won't even spoil you upon
structure you keep everything intact 86
hits the bishop but the problem with H6
is that white can win a Tempo with
Bishop E7 as well hit that Rook on f8
and once again the Knight jumps to G3 to
attack the queen and win material so F6
is a very important move and of course
Archen finds it
wow it's a really instructive line here
the H and F6 look interchangeable but
they in fact are not because of Bishop
E7 hitting the Rook on f8 so F6 played
by Arjun very quickly clearly to me in
his preparation he's looking away from
the board it seems like he's confident
in his game right now so let's go back
to the bird's eye view for a second a
few things have happened Tanya as I look
across the seven boards in the middle
and the bottom row Richard report played
the move C4 allowing Bishop B4 check he
will not be castling in this game he
doesn't care he's Richard Rapport he
does what he wants on the chessboard
um in the top right we'll see a familiar
site Fabiano caruana did in fact play A4
and retreated his Knight to B1 I promise
I didn't look at this position with him
but as you said baby sometimes I can
predict his move decently
um but Tanya we haven't looked at the
bottom right game between Parham and
Vincent kymer and you know you spoke
very highly of Vincent earlier in the
show I know you know you've seen a lot
of his chess and the Champions chess
store and other events but in his first
go here in the first round with the
black pieces I'm kind of a interested in
his game because these types of benoni
structures right where it's benoni's
with colors reversed with the D3 and C4
pawns but this D4 Pawn kind of sticks
out it's a complicated affair
well Winston is definitely a player that
we've been talking a lot about his
Champions chest so also while doing
commentary with Peter lecopita is his
trainer peterleko is well he's a legend
of the game he is a former World
Championship Challenger and he is the
coach on Mentor Vincent uh Vincent is
also fresh from his world rapid
Championship silver medal so he's
definitely feeling informed he's played
against the world's Elite but that has
been an online rapid form this is once
again a huge platform for him in the
classical format here at the Wimbledon
of Chess against the very best player in
a long time control so I'm expecting a
very well prepared Vincent I think
Vincent has a very Universal strategic
positional style clearly influenced by
Peter's style of play as well and the
position that we've got right now in
front of us if I was played and one
might feel that the pawn that you were
pointing at D4 isn't it hanging can't
you just pick up the pawn but the
problem is that right now the because of
tactics that's not possible after Knight
D4 you trade on D4 and then the bishop
can jump to B4 is an option you hit the
Rook on E1 you hit the Knight on D4 you
can also take on G3 and pick up the
Knight on D4 for all these various
reasons then the D4 Pawn is still
indirectly defended I think I like to
move Bishop B4 uh probably ends up
winning material here so currently A5 D4
is still defunded Black's dream someday
is to get that knight from F6 all the
way to C5 we were talking about Fabi C4
Square after A4 and having these
weaknesses in this position it's Black's
Knight that wants to go into C5 somehow
right so if you could protect this Pawn
stay with E5 and get your knight to C5
you'd be very happy and Parham is aiming
at this D4 Pawn now I wouldn't put it
past our maksulu to sacrifice an
exchange and take on D4 I'm not saying
it's the best decision but it is an
interesting one and aparam is the type
of player who loves a good fight he does
not make boring draws that is not his
style at all and you know we see we just
we see him on screen there calculating
thinking he just got invited to this
tournament right yanchist of Duda was
supposed to play Parham was his
replacement so it's not like he's
prepared for weeks and weeks for this
field no he's like all right I'm gonna
pack my bags I'm ready to go let's play
the best players in a classical format
now we know Haram from he plays in every
event on chess.com and he loves uh
competing in online Blitz and Rapid time
patrols but this is a different story
and out in the gates you mentioned Peter
letko Vince's preparation is silver
metal and the world rapid I mean it
looks like a good position for him very
healthy structure and he has more
advanced pieces particularly his Pawn on
D4 it's a thorn and white side and I
believe he is actually posing more
challenges to Parham so Tanya will
Parham take on D4 will he make another
developing move but what developing
moves even catch your eye
it's really hard to say and you know I I
think I completely agree with you about
how you describe barham's play he's the
kind of player who is so Fearless over
the board he doesn't care who he's
playing against he goes for the most uh
most combative moves that are possible
to complicate things but he's also I
think Parham that also sometimes becomes
his weakness he's the kind of player on
a good day he could beat anybody but if
he's slightly shaky then things could go
really really wrong for him and being a
last minute replacement for an event
like this where players have been
preparing for several weeks actually
planning their calendar so that they've
got time to give their best to this
tournament uh I think Parham is
definitely at a little bit of a
disadvantage but then it's an
opportunity that somebody would just
completely give anything to have in the
chest world so if you've been invited
last minute you just go out there and
give your best Barham was also there the
world rapid and Blitz uh in fact in the
last round of the blitz he played
against Magnus uh for the medal uh
played the Sicilian I remember a
fantastic game that was but Magnus just
crashed through and won the whole thing
uh one thing's for sure with Parham that
there's going to be fire on the board
which I think is the reason that you
believe that he's going to take on D4
but to be honest Robert this line with
Knight D4 trades and pick up uh and go
Bishop B4 for black it's just hard to
come up for a move for white hair for me
yeah because you know you I was gonna
say Bishop E3 right just giving up the
rook and playing a position like this
and uh as we see the eval bar off the
sides no point four point five better
for black so clear that it's good for
black from an objective standpoint but
we can see the pluses this bishop on G2
is a monster this Knight can hop into B5
at any moment the dark squares are
vulnerable on the queen side and only
white as a dark Square Bishop so I
acknowledge that black is better and
should be better but I know from also my
own experience sometimes I look at these
positions and I get these rose-colored
glasses for the side that has given up
materially I see all the pluses and
don't just say wait a second I have a
rook for just a bishop in one Pawn
that's an advantage for me so I'm
looking at the great pieces but the
material does play a huge part in this
position
very complicated but I I mean I get your
point now this is the kind of chest that
Parham also really enjoys and the bigger
question is if you don't go for this
line what is your alternative it's kind
of hard to find a good developing Square
for your Bishop on C1 black has a clear
plan this is your opportunity you don't
take it I want to go E5 I want to go
Knight D7 bring my knight to C5 and just
feel really happy about my purpose it's
going to be hard for white to get a3b4
in with the pin along the a file as well
so definitely a big moment for paramia
does he decide to get those uh two
Bishops give up the exchange give up the
material and kind of play for an
initiative I would prefer black in that
position Robert uh we'll come back and
take a look at what Parham finally
decides but I see a lot of action on our
Prague urchin board as well
yeah so much action on many of these
games uh prognanda the second from the
right and the bottom where I was taken
on F6 so we have seen that trade the
queen on H5 will be free it will be
saved so that's good news for Arjun uh
but I'm also looking at the top left at
Magnus Carlson's game but that was the
game we started with I haven't been
there in a while uh so why don't we just
tune into that one
um and see what has happened because
there was a nice Bishop on C6 for Lavon
but suddenly that Bishop is on H7 and
it's you know how did it get there why
did it run to the other side of the
board uh that's an important question so
when we left off the last move was uh
here Bishop oh actually the bishop
chased the Queen Bishop D5 the queen
went back the bishop chased it again
with Bishop E4 and only then did Levon
attack this bishop on G5 so forcing
White's hand Knights C3 is about to
happen or Knight D2 rather in this case
with Tempo at this bishop leaving the C
file open uh that was magnus's plan and
that is why the bishop ran back H7
because you can go to C6 uh but with the
bishop on C6 it's likely that E4 at some
point will be quite annoying the bishop
is shut down and maybe can be handled
eventually with D5 I'm not so sure
I really like this little Queen Dance by
white provoking that Bishop to E4 if you
just back up a couple of moves when
black was chasing the queen down the
board starting with Bishop D5 and L1
might feel wait a second why do you want
to go C2 provoke Bishop to E4 another
attack on the queen but actually it's a
really smart way to handle the position
because what you don't want is to give
black the option to jump on e4 one with
the Knight not just that after a move
like Queen C2 and Bishop E4 when White
Snake does develop to C3 or in this case
we saw to D2 it actually attacks the E4
Bishop so in a sense it's not as if
white is losing a Tempo but actually
gaining a Tempo you bring your piece out
with an attack over the bishop and as we
saw in the game driving that Bishop to
eight seven you pointed out absolutely
correctly Robert that you don't want
that Bishop on let's just play on a
couple of moves you trade the Knight
came to D2 hits the bishop why D2 I
think Magnus is really eyeing the C5
Square you want to go Knight B3 you want
to go Knight C5 and hit that pawn on B7
slowly but surely I'm starting to like
White's position a little bit especially
with the bishop shoved down on the eight
seven square nobody to really take care
of the G2 Bishop at some point black
will have to make the move C6 to try and
blunt down this diagonal but I still
like White's bind on the queen side
yes and your Magnus has put his Knight
on B3 uh the A5 Pawn always has to be
looked after but you can't combine Pawn
pushes you can't play B6 and C6 so
that's actually something that is might
be a problem for black if the A5 Pawn is
targeted uh then you might want to play
B6 but that opens up the long diagonal
and hands white the C6 square if you
play C6 well you're not gonna play B6
because then the C6 Pawn will be hanging
and so these are small little decisions
play a big part in the trajectory of the
game so Knight D7 Lavon just develops
his Knight here and I think we could
even see the move Knight E5 it's a
tactical position a rook and a queen are
on the same file The Rook almost always
wins that Showdown so Knight to E5 If
You Think You're Gonna Take on E5 and
win a pawn you're absolutely incorrect
because your queen is under attack and
now you lose a piece and if you take
with the bishop on E5 you don't lose a
piece but you do give this open file the
B7 Pawn is under attack and now C6
doesn't work because of Knight C5 so I
think black has a lot to figure out here
after the move Knight to E5 maybe it's
just the move C6 right away but even
then white has a great Bishop on G2 can
bring another Knight into C5 and I feel
like the spatial Advantage is so
pleasant for Magnus Carlson
I love the move Knight E5 that you're
pointing out really taking advantage of
the D file and The Rook on D1 just
beautifully placed anticipating the
opening of this file and I don't see a
better move than C6 to fight against the
threat on the B7 Pawn overall really
liking White's position here it's also
the kind of opening outcomes I think
that work perfectly for Magnus he just
knows how to grind down and create more
weaknesses provoke more weaknesses in
his in the opponent's Camp uh Robert
this is going to be a tough task ahead
for Lavon
it certainly will be because the space
is clearly in White's favor the bishop
on G2 is superior uh compared to the
bishop on H7 in particular the bishop
and F6 we typically love a bishop pair
the two Bishops Advantage but the bishop
106 is staring into an ultra
well-defended Pawn on D4 and that means
that uh it's not really doing the most
it can at E5 C5 typical Pawn brakes will
never work with the Rook on D1 Queen on
the C file as well so I just feel like
the plan is hard to see for black and
Magnus has several plans that he can
employ and the main one that I'm looking
at is Knight to E5 so we'll leave the
players to it Tanya I think we're gonna
take our first break of the day it's
been some really interesting chess I
know we haven't given the game between
gookash and dingley Rin are full
attention Jordan Forest and Wesley so as
well so as you know we Zoom back to the
playing Hall we'll get into those games
on the flip side of this break so stay
tuned everybody we will be right back
what's the best way to follow any chess
event from the World Chess Championship
to the candidates the speed chess
championship title Tuesday and so much
more chess.com events has all of the top
chess tournaments played both over the
board and online
analyze and review games from the
world's greatest players with live
commentary cloud analysis opening
Explorer and table bases find all the
key event information including
schedules prizes results news reports
player bios tie breaks and more
even compete by voting for your
predicted results
explorechess.com events today on web or
with our IOS and Android apps and
experience chess like never before
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
and return to the scene in Vikings a
look at how many people are there uh
Tanya I absolutely love seeing the
people playing not just spectating you
see how many people are playing there in
their rows it's all of the amateur
sections this is a chess festival and
just remind everybody of who we are I'm
Grand Master Robert Hess alongside
International Master Tanya I know I just
asked you a question and then uh changed
back to us but I love seeing that view
just like all of the participants so
many chess lovers it's great it's such a
celebration of Chess rabbit where we've
got players of all levels and ages and
from across the world come together to
play this game uh and as you mentioned
we've got the amateur section we've got
the Challenger section and of course the
Masters all happening at the same place
the same stage uh as vishyanand
mentioned in his tweet a Jan not in wike
is not a Jan at all
well I guess we have to have our gen not
invite a covering bike and it is still a
great honor and pleasure and we do have
all 14 players in the masters section uh
playing their games right now seven
boards as you can see here uh some games
a little bit more electric than others I
know we haven't looked at the game at
the bottom left between gukesh and
dingley rent finally the First Pawn is
being traded it's a bit of a slower
start there the game next to it the
bottom row second from the left Jordan
Ved Forest against Wesley so the Queens
are off the board not exactly the most
tactical oppositions but that game in
the bottom row in the middle Tanya I
mean I just can't take my eyes off of it
the one between Richard report and Notre
Beck Abdul sitarov because there's a
king on D1 there's a black king castle
Queen side a rook on the open file on B1
but lack of development for white on the
king side over there it's just it feels
like it is going to be spicy throughout
this game
adding all the fire currently is on this
game I mean what an opening we've had
and look at the creative play from
Richard not disappointing known as one
of the most creative players in the
world this is the kind of opening that
we get out of it now I see our eval bar
give its famous evaluation of 0.0 or at
least that's what it feels like that
it's even but look at the position it
looks anything with even the white King
on D1 center of the board we have been
taught since we start playing chess that
you know what you've got to get that
King to safety Go castle castle and find
your safe Nest but Richard doesn't care
about any of that the one thing that
does stand out in this position to me
that even though the king is on D1 what
we have to ask ourselves is how is black
ever getting to that King how are you
going to attack that King with this Pawn
on C4 Pawn on D3 the pawn on C2 really
just semantic and providing that Shield
meanwhile white is dreaming to get the
Knight to F4 Knight E2 Knight F4 ideas
are their Knight H3 Knight G5 ideas are
there to hit that Bishop the bishop on
F3 The Rook on B1 in a Sly way R eyeing
that pawn on B7 so you know Robert even
the White's King is the one that looks
unsafe I kind of like White's position
here
you know I couldn't tell that you like
White's position based on how you're
describing it you gave all of the
pleasant things that black has to offer
but I think that you know you make some
so many good points here that the King
on D1 is actually shielded by the fact
that there is no tension between pawns
because when a pawn captures another
Pawn I know this sounds obvious but a
file opens up what file does black need
to open up the D file that's not
happening with this Pawn on D4 and
nothing to capture Bishop takes C6 is an
immediate threat the bishop on B4 is a
bit loose so you can move the bishop
away sure but then the Rook sees through
to that B7 Pawn as you mentioned the
Knight on G1 it's undeveloped for now
but it can go to E2 and F4 but likely
via H3 to go to either G5 or F4 as well
and I don't know I just get the sense
that noribbeck doesn't have a clear plan
the one thing that Richard really needs
to look out for is Bishop takes C4 not
at the moment I don't think it's
available just yet but the point is you
said the King on D1 is safe right how do
we get to that King we need to remove
some of these Pawn so let's just say for
argument's sake I could get away with
this I would be going right after this
King on D1 ripping open the D file
trying to Checkmate I see the eval bar I
get that white is technically winning in
this specific line but that it's just
the overall point that I'm trying to
highlight here that that is how we get
to the king white lacks development so
if we can open that D file the white
king will not last very long in this
particular position it seems that white
is able to survive by putting the bishop
on the D5 square covering the D file
saving the king but Tanya you know that
nordi Beck is looking for a way to get
at that white king
I mean just looking at this line it's so
workable imagine a position like you go
Bishop C5 you first get out of this
thread of Bishop C6 and then we were
talking about developing this Knight
let's say you go Knight E2 you want to
add the F4 Square you're developing
everything it looks nice and then bam
you go Bishop C4 this could be that
moment that you're talking about you
pick up that Bishop on C4 and then D3
just exploding the position attacking
that Knight on E2 hitting that part on
C2 and let's say you go Knight F4 I take
D take C2 I come in with a check I open
the D line you go King C2 I go Knight D4
check and I would be shaking and
shivering with white hair yeah I mean
they don't have the eval bar so somehow
it's still better for white it doesn't
really look like it's our eyes but this
king is in huge trouble so it's kind of
fortunate that the king isn't just
getting checkmated but that's what
Richard has to keep an eye out for
because 92 after Bishop C5 is such a
natural move and apparently it's okay uh
for white but you know that Richard's
also looking for Bishop takes C4
sacrifices so both players are looking
at the C4 Pawn they're also looking at
the B7 pawn and the B file more broadly
and Bishop C5 there is an argument for
Rook B5 as well like continue the attack
bring the pieces up uh forward here and
I like that you highlighted it you would
love to kick this bishop out of E6 then
you have a pass Pawn that can push and
that is always dangerous so Notre back
he has a lot to work out in the moment
tiny Bishop C5 looks natural A5 is
another move but we typically don't like
pushing Pawns in front of our own King
especially when Mike can just play A3 in
response and then kick the bishop out
opening the B file so
um big moment here for Nordic not just
for this move but for the next I would
say several moves
A5 is definitely something you want to
consider but even if it was a move that
somebody would say this is the best move
in the position once you've gone long
Castle you're always afraid to do such
stuff create weaknesses around your own
King so I would be very surprised if not
a bag does decide to defend the bishop
with the move A5 even though it has its
own advantages of course the bishop on
B4 intercepts the B file makes sure that
the black snide Black Knight can jump
around with no attack on B7 but I think
Bishop C5 just feels like such a natural
move here and that's the one we're
expecting I would love to go Knight H3
then we will see how this one developed
but we've got action on on the other
boards as well we certainly do this one
is fun we'll get back to it but we have
seven games in total 14 players duking
it out in the first run here in Vic and
Zay so uh we've given most of the games
our attention why don't we start by
looking at the games in the bottom
left-hand side screen we haven't uh
looked at those in any way so let's
start with the game between gookesh and
dingley ren uh not much at least it
appears has happened from the sense that
not many pieces have been traded it
looks like a very normal position
especially compared to a report and
Abdul sitarov's game but there is one
thing of note here that we do not have a
symmetrical Pawn structure the last move
was C takes D5 and now black had a
choice so ding decides to take with the
E Pawn and Tanya does that surprise you
at all it takes with the epon rather
than with the c punt or even with the
Knight on D5
I think all these captures whether you
take it with the night Robert E or C
have their own give and take their own
pros and cons in the position uh taking
with the c Pawn you kind of make sure
that you you get out of that weakness
along the C file but then you do give
white the open hand on the C file often
white is the one to take control of it
first already ideas like group C1 Rook
C2 move the queen double up white will
be faster to control the only open file
in the position but what you've got in
return is you've gotten rid of the
weakness but this can often go very
unpleasant even ideas and plans like A4
Knight B5 at some point and white can be
very happy in these positions once you
get control of the C file on the other
hand the other option is of course yes
let's point that out with the A7 Pawn
hanging as well you can think about
taking with the Knight on D5 instead of
the C Pawn
but here white has the option to even
just consider maybe returning with the
bishop or recapturing because now you
give this free hand and this plan of
going E4 at some point let's say I go
Bishop D2 and then you always have to be
okay with that white will control the
center after rookie one and E4 so this
is something to consider and then taking
the decision as ding did taking with the
E Pawn yes you do leave the weakness on
C6 and that might look a bit strange at
first but you open the e-file for your
own activity you want to go rookie it
you want to plant your F6 Knight on e4
and try to get your own play along the
e-file I kind of understand this
decision uh by doing to take on D5 with
the e-pawn add some Far Away future one
day maybe C5 will come but you've got to
always be careful with this break
because it can create weaknesses
do you really describe this extremely
well like I'm looking at the position
and now we have an imbalance of sorts we
have a potential weakness on C6 but as
you noted in open e-files so I guess one
of the big questions I have dingly Wren
an extremely objective practical player
he doesn't really take too many risk but
I'm looking at the clock he is up 30
minutes on the clock right now is he
kind of playing for a win a double-edged
position and saying to gukesh it's only
move 11 you have many moves to make to
reach the time Patrol now you have to
prove that you can play and stabilize in
a position that doesn't look symmetrical
so I guess you know over time what do
you think about that
100 if ding has the opportunity to
complicate the position and to go for
imbalance Bond structures he's going to
go for it you know what they say catch
them when they're young and right now he
thinks it's his opportunity to create
his stances against the player like
gkeshu of course is very strong but is
making his debut here at the Tata steel
so he takes D5 is perhaps the most
complicated recaptures and as you
pointed out the clock difference that
does give an edge currently to Ding and
white needs to find a way to continue
here I am you know I think for me what
is really interesting to see is how ding
approaches this whole tournament and I
think this particular moment sort of
defines that that he wants to play
Fighting Chess thing hasn't had the
opportunity to play so many classical
games he's currently world number two in
fact the only other player apart from
Magnus Carlsen who's over 2 800. his
current rating is at two at one one he
is the world he is world number two and
who can forget his phenomenal Journey
money to the candidates and now he's
going to play in the world championship
match later this year against
and this is really a huge event for him
because potentially it could be his only
classical event before the match so
definitely looking forward to a fighting
Ding and I think taking it with the
e-pawn goes on to say that even though
he's playing with the black pieces he
wants a game against kokesh yeah and I
think that people were so caught up in
the controversy around the way that dick
had to qualify for the candidates right
he had to play 30 games in a month
pretty much and uh there are local
tournaments and he didn't need the
rating so that's why I think it wasn't
as controversial as some made it out to
be because he could have lost 20 rating
points and still made his way to
candidates but having those kind of
organized tournaments at the last minute
I get why people were upset about it but
then people forget that dingley Wren is
King Ding he is so good and he is the
number two rated player in the world
over 2 800. I mean he is phenomenal he
beat Hikaru Nakamura in that last round
of what looked like a pretty tame
position he outplayed him in that ending
with exquisite technique to earn his
spot in that world championship match so
I think you know it's good to see
dingler and back at the board and now as
we're talking about he is fighting he's
showing that he wants some kind of
position that's not completely balanced
will he strike with C5 in the future
that's a big question will he play
rookie eight Knight to E4 I'm moving the
bishop out of the way of course at some
point he does have some dark squares to
use on the queen side so I like that
it's a position where both sides have
their chances this Knight can go up to
E5 The Rook can slide to C1 it's a
moment to put pressure on C6 so many
different plans for the two players I
just like ding's time management much
better
and what you mentioned the game that you
were talking about in fact Robert that
was the last classical game that Ding
has played uh and now he comes back to
Tata steel Masters it was the final
round of the candidates in I think it
was back in July in 22 which he won
against Hikaru and I think he's been one
player who has literally taken Destiny
in his own hands he had to complete the
30-game formality to qualify for the
candidates he made that happen it wasn't
possible for him to travel to Grand Prix
no visas a difficult time but the
tournament was organized he won game
after game went on to be world number
two increase his rating qualify for the
candidates had a terrible start at the
candidates lost the first game had a
series of draws and then went on to make
a massive comeback a massive comeback
that made him finish second and as stars
would have it I mean you finished second
we've always said the candidates is all
about winning the event and qualifying
for the world championship match but in
this one finishing second method because
Magnus decided to not defend the world
championship title he is not going to
play and with that being qualified to
fight for uh being the world champion so
truly took Destiny in his own hands and
this is a massive event for him because
there are certain Dynamics at play here
as well you know Magnus is playing uh
he's not playing the world champion ding
wants to have a good tournament he's
going to play the match after this one
uh I'm expecting a very well prepared
thing here and like you mentioned he's
got a big control over the clock in this
one not just that the ideas that we were
talking about rookie 8 played so again
eyeing that e-file and why did white
make the move Knight E1 kukesh wants to
place that Knight on D3 He wants to
place that night on D3 also to block out
the bishop on A6 from putting pressure
on E2 not just that after the Knight
goes to D3 rookie one E4 is a plan that
white might consider
yes all of that is true and I think
while white is rerouting the night black
will do the same Knight f8 will probably
be next and then Knight can jump out to
E6 or G6 so both sides will show off
their uh maneuvering to figure out where
to put their pieces and because ignorant
has a lead on the clock I want to point
out the time control because
um you know it is a long time Patrol
from uh you know this point of view of
it's a hundred minutes before it moves
then 50 minutes for the next 20 uh with
a 30 second ignorant from move one and
then 15 minutes are for the rest of the
game uh so there are three type patrols
first you make it to a 40 then you make
it to move 60 and then you give it
another 15 minutes but right now with
ding uh ding ahead on the clock he's
going to use it as a weapon because only
13 moves have been played
and you know it's easy to forget how uh
this time control can be so tricky you
got so much time at hand that we often
see in these classical formats the
players come down to seconds to make
their 40th move the last few moves to
meet the time control you know the ones
from sometimes you've got five moves
left and you've got a few seconds left
and we've seen big huge blunders happen
in that time control uh Robert we were
talking about this before who can forget
that Infamous moment when Fabi just hung
an entire Rook against a niche in a he
had to make the last move of the time
control so it always gets really tricky
and what makes this tournament even more
special is that it's not just any
classical time format it is a very long
classical time format the in fact the
only other event that's got a longer
time control than this is the world
championship match
yeah that's right I think the and one
other term that comes to mind is like
the grand Swiss will have this kind of
time Patrol as well but it's saved for
very few events and well dingly Wren
right now with that lead in The Clock he
is thinking about his move will he
reroute his Knight that's the big
question uh so why don't we head back to
our bird oh I mean dingler and making
the move Knight f8 so he doesn't even
want to let me finish my sentence I saw
him grab that night bring it to f8 he is
rerouting his Knight towards uh you know
a more advanced Square whether it be G
or E6 so
um he gets up from his chair we'll all
wave a dingly red uh but we'll also wave
goodbye to this position for the moment
and your invent for us is in the
background we have not looked at his
game against Wesley so so it feels like
a good time to take a look at that one
so as we take a look at our bird's eye
view wow a big move actually just
happened in that game it's second from
the left in the bottom row Knight C4
just dropped back to E3 so Jordan is
putting the maximum amount of pressure
on that night in the center with his
Bishop on G2 staring along the diagonal
it's a pretty interesting position I
know I said Queens are off the board
Tony it's not going to be the most
tactical it's starting to get Tactical
and that's because no minor pieces have
been traded off so far and we can still
see white skin in the center and in fact
the only piece that's been traded is a
is a pair of queens and that's it so
there's still so much to play for and
watch out for that Bishop on G2 really
eyeing this diagonal black is just one
move shot imagine this position but
black had the bishop on B7 no prop lamo
but currently there is a strong pin and
Knight E3 poses immediate questions to
that Black Knight on D5 Knight takes E3
is the first move that comes to mind but
the problem with that Robert as you're
pointing out is that white picks up not
the Knight on E2 but the Knight on C6
hysterical need will go on to pick up
the Knight on E3 and that will be game
over so you don't really have the time
to pick up the Knight on E3
what's the move that comes to mind
because I'm threatening to capture uh to
capture on D5 multiple times and be
material up
yeah so if you have to retreat one of
your Knights score like E7 that opens up
the bishop on G2 which is a long-term
problem for black to get out of so the
last move Knight to E3 I would say that
there are three move candidates that
come to mind Knight C to E7 Knight D to
E7 just to make sure that these Knights
are defended you're not losing a pawn in
the center and Bishop takes E3 Bishop
takes E3 as my least favorite move of
the options I don't want to give up the
bishop pair now I know the it's an end
game there aren't really targets to
exploit but everybody prefers to have
the bishop pair in endgame rather than
be facing it so Bishop takes E3 gets rid
of the tension but it also just gives
white you know kind of a free hand to
play for an advantage of the end game so
that leaves the Knight to E7 route and
which one would I choose Tony I'm gonna
pass it back to you and let you pick
which Knight you would prefer to bring
the E7 Square I was really hoping you
wouldn't do that because that's such a
tricky question but I would definitely
not take on E3 with the bishop 100 agree
on that I don't want to give you the two
Bishops for free I don't want to play
slight a slightly worse end game where
you'll torture me forever naturally the
move that comes to my mind out of the
two night Retreats is the C Knight
Robert and the reason for that is that
the one thing I don't like after a move
like Knight D to E7 if you just back up
and show the problem with Knight D7 so I
kind of arrived at that with elimination
I don't like a night jump to E4 or to A4
hitting my Bishop on C5 and that Knight
on C6 is still a Target I'm not sure how
I can respond to that but it looks like
my troubles are not over I still don't
have time to finish my development so I
kind of
sorry I was just gonna say you're right
like Knight a force looks simple are you
just putting pressure on the the 96 and
black has to give up the bishop on E3
exactly and then the bishop on G2 still
hits the bishop and C6 so it looks a bit
tricky and speaking of the one option
that both of us were definitely not
going to play I think it's it's happened
on the board I see you on our live board
black decides to take the Knight on E3
Bishop B3 what do we know about Chess
Robert
uh we know a lot and Wesley so just
happens though a little bit more but I
mean you look at the Eva bar it is
creeping up in White's favor uh so
here's a big difference I would say that
now if your Bishop takes E3 you still
can't take back because Bishop takes C6
hits The Rook on A8 and you'll take the
Knight back on E3 with your next move
you win material so if after Knight
um D to E7 Knight A4 then we take on E3
isn't the white knight in a worse place
being on A4 so if we're giving up the
bishop pair you'd want to do it when
White's pieces are misplaced it's not an
A4 and then black can bring the bishop
out Bring The Rook to C8 and finish the
development so I feel like
um if the threat was this kind of night
move you can allow that threat and then
give up the bishop hair versus doing it
right away it might not make the biggest
difference in the sense that after
Bishop E3 maybe Wesley will just
continue his development trade pieces
and make what he hopes the draw in this
end game but I just think that was a
slight inaccuracy at that moment
I did see the ball creep up a little bit
after this decision to give up the
bishop on E3 and which does go on to
show that in fact black should have kept
uh the bishop on C5 I really like
White's chances in this end game even
after Bishop E3 black has got problems
to solve you never want to take on C3
because after Bishop E3 Knight C3 Rook
C3 you end up in huge trouble you still
have to answer the question of which
Knight to move back White's got the two
Bishops I like uh Jordan's chances in
this position but this is going to be a
long grind and the one player who no
matter what kind of an advantage you
have against him is so hard to beat is
Wesley so there's still a lot of work to
be done with Whitetail yeah Wesley he is
somebody who remains calm like the guy
doesn't just decide all of a sudden to
make an impulsive decision he is someone
who really studies the board and he
played Bishop takes E3 if I know Wesley
so and you know I've known him for a
long time I feel like he made the
decision think I'm gonna make this draw
no matter what so even if it is slightly
worse than what we were just talking
about with Knight D to e or Knight C to
E7 first I think that he feels very
confident about his chances to make a
draw because even though white gets the
bishop pair after Bishop takes E3 there
aren't clear Targets in the position
um the B6 A7 configuration just makes
the bishop on E3 look a bit uh blocked
in and where else are you going to
Target especially if this Knight goes
back to E7 so uh Jordan has responded
with Bishop takes E3 when Wesley comes
back we'll see how he continues this
position I do think he will bring one of
those Knights to E7
um I don't really like the look of
Bishop B7 giving up an isolated Pawn
Center that's how you definitely get a
disadvantage in the end game so I think
one of these Knights to E7 would be the
way to go
we'll leave vastly to
lead it which Knight he wants to fall
back on meanwhile action is on on the
other boards and if you just get our
bird's eye view up uh Robert the one
position that stands out to me is the
world champions game and in fact he has
gone for the idea uh if we see on the
top left with the Knight jumping on to
E5 you mentioned this plan taking
control of the D file and in fact C6 was
played to block the bishop maybe we can
just put that game up and in fact has
white already won a pawn here
well I'm looking at this board and the
last one was Rook A7
by Lavon which is the most mysterious
move I've seen in a while like what is
the plan find Rook A7 and if we just go
back here the previous was Queen to C3
so I think I understand now that Magnus
can't take on E5 we talked about this
earlier you lose a piece because your
queen is hit by the rook and then your
Bishop will be hit by the pawn so you
can't get away with that so what Lavon
is getting ready for is in fact what has
happened in the game Eva's Rook A7
understanding that if this queen gets
distracted away from the A5 pawn and in
this case Magnus took right away the
point being if Rook A5 Knight takes D7
your queen is doing too much overloaded
peace that three takes on D7 you lose
the Rook on A5 so that is why he did
this move order but after Knight A5
Bishop takes E5 D takes E5 a couple
things have happened Rook takes the A5
Rook D7 he'll take back with the queen
but Tanya Magnus is a pawn ahead so this
forcing sequence leaves magnets with
extra material but Lavon based on his
time management and by like this
decision here I feel like he's confident
that he can hold this and that's because
of Rook A4 that's because of Rook A4 you
don't have to take on D7 immediately and
that's what we see happen I saw Levon
reach out for that Rook on A5 what a
position this is the queen hangs but the
Rook on A1 hangs and that is why this
entire line makes sense Robert I think I
just want to back up to this moment Rook
A7 because it is such an in such a I
don't know like a beautiful way to kind
of solve your problems in the position
Rook A7 just doesn't seem like a move
that makes any sense but it's all
targeted against defending the A5 Pawn
for example if you start with Knight D7
Queen D7 as we were pointing out Knight
A5 you can suddenly go Rook it and start
attacking the A4 Pawn as well so Rook A7
has the idea to double up the pawns but
not just that now if we go to the line
that Magnus chose in the game instead
what a stunning way to play with the
black pieces I don't care what the eval
Bar says I freaking love what lavon's
done in this position after taking on E5
Bishop E5 takes on E5 Rook A5 you can't
grab the Rook just yet because of the
queen on d8 and now a hand move would be
just to take the Rook on D7 give up the
A5 Rook but then you're up on down
instead Levon says wait a minute Rook
takes A4 picks up that pawn the A1 Rook
is undefended if you take the queen on
d8 which is hanging black actually ends
up way better after Rook takes A1
picking up the Rook with the check he
will pick up the other Rook be two Rooks
for a queen with a better position and
in this Skirmish he's managed to win the
pawn back with Rook A4 I love it
right you know you can't take that Queen
you'll give him two Rooks and you're
just gonna be in big trouble when your
Bishop has lost an F1 over here so
instead we are going likely to see Rook
takes A4 and it's not the end of the
story so uh your excitement you know I
agree with that I was into that I Rook
takes A4 caught me by surprise but one
thing that Lavon has to be worried about
is let's say I just play simply Rook
takes A4 Queen D7 Rook D4 plant my Rook
on D6 try to get my queen to D4 white
despite having a double Pawn still has
control over this D file and with an
extra Pawn where and we might just see
this I'm gonna refresh the board here
um with an extra Pawn on the king side
right we have five pawns for white on
the king side compared to four for black
and black has an extra Pawn on the queen
side so black is gonna try to push that
pawn to create a passer but I feel like
it's not easy to create a pass pawn and
white may be able to launch an attack
thanks to the control the D file and
maybe these pawns can go forward at some
point
yeah I was so excited with that with all
the tactics that we saw that you tend to
forget that wait a second you don't have
to go for all these exchanges but can
actually just play slow and strategic
white has control over the D5 I see our
eval bar also does appreciate White's
position which makes it hard to play The
Devil's Advocate here but I still think
that black also has trumps here for
Levon he's going to step away with the
queen queen C7 feels like a natural move
I am attacking your Pawn on E5 you still
have double pawns and yes you have
control over the D5 but Robert has one
more open file in the position and you
know what sure you can control the D
file I want to put my Rook on it and try
and create my own chances
I think black's got game here still
okay I mean you're you know repping your
man Lavon you know you we've known Lavon
for a long time he has that flare both
in his typical wardrobe choices and in
his chest so The Rook likely coming to a
we see levona Ronin there thinking
trying to figure out where his Queen
goes but I just do think that Magnus put
his Queen on C5 maybe put a rook on D6
maybe even push his Pawn to B4 he's got
kind of got a clamp going on the queen
side and I'm just you know I see The
Rook coming to eight as long as I don't
get checkmated I feel like white can
play F4 King F2 things of that nature so
I just looking at in the position piece
by piece and I feel like white will just
end up with better peace placement and
one more important thing to show is that
black has a back rank problem because
Bishop's on H7 so if Queen C7 Queen C5
Rook eight you're trying to give me a
check down here I'll make a move like F4
giving my king the F2 score if you play
this with Queen A5 you'll lose on the
spot mid Queens because if there weren't
Rook da Checkmate let's say this polymer
on G5 black is totally fine The Rook d8
is immediately check and mate because
the King has no Escape score so I feel
like black is kind of one tempo behind
from just resolving all the problems and
if that's the case just staring at this
position for a second I mean white has
this bind going on like you don't have
B6 because C6 Falls uh you can't move
your Rook off the last rank very easily
because there's background problems and
if I get my queen to D6 and you take me
maybe I'll undouble my pawns and get a
very Advanced pass Pawn so I'm just
looking at this Tanya I get it black is
pretty solid but I still don't see the
way out and I think I've I've struggled
with most as a chess player throughout
my career I was like when I get to these
moments where I'm worse and I know I'm
going to be worse for a long time I
start to get a bit worried maybe even
more worried than I should
and especially when you're playing
against a player like Magnus you give
him this just a little bit of play just
a little bit of binding he can just
grind this down it's definitely a tricky
spot but once again I think Levon is
very resourceful he will find his play
he's gone for the move Queen C7 as we
could see on our camera so steps away
with the queen queen C5 I like your move
Queen C5 a lot it's a nice spot for the
queen uh you know you're not only
defending the D5 the E5 Pawn but it's
just so active there you want to go
Queen D6 someday you want to go B4 B5
the queen on C7 is pin I'm still
expecting rookie and not to fall for
that terrible background trick that you
just pointed out I don't believe Levon
will fall for it but he's got to be
careful he's got to waste that one tempo
moving that Bishop away from eight seven
creating an eight seven square for the
king uh tough to ask ahead of lab but
still too early to call it uh to call it
uh I don't know to call it anything for
Magnus yeah I'm with you I I think it's
kind of funny because rookie definitely
seems natural but if the Queens get
traded black wants to play G5 with the
Queens on the board like definitely does
not want to play G5 because that makes
your king unsafe so this bishop will
likely have to sit on G6 which blocks
the G7 Pawn which is you know fine with
the Queen's on but if the Queens ever
get traded then I wish I had my Pawn on
G5 so these little things that are
actually quite consequential uh because
if my Pawn's on F4 and your Bishop's on
G6 maybe I will play E4 and at some
point strike with the move F5 so I feel
like black has to be a bit careful I'm
with you though that Lavon he's so
strong he's won this tournament four
times uh you know he's beaten Magnus
many times throughout his career and now
with the black pieces and a slightly
worse position I think he's in that
ballpark of being able to hold but it
just a nagging position where Magnus is
not going to take his foot off the pedal
he's gonna make Levon work
tirelessly to make this draw if LeBron's
going to be able to
yeah agree with that it's not going to
be easy we see a quite a relax on a
chill Magnus there on the screen he's
munching on something so getting his
energy up he knows it's gonna be a long
grind and but he's got I think he's got
what he wanted with the white white
pieces and now it's just going to be
about whether Lev will be able to hold
this or not I see the move Queen C5 has
been made oh he's gone for Rook D6 has
he yeah Rook D6 and said I thought at
Queen C5 as well but that's because I
was talking it into existence or so I
hope it Rook D6 shutting the Queen off
allowing this queen to go to D4 or D2
Behind The Rook so he's just saying oh
I'm gonna sit on the position I have
much more activity than you do and I
mentioned that Levant has beaten Magnus
many times in fact he's beating him
eight times but Magnus has actually
beaten him 17. so uh quite a lot of
decisive games between these two
you've talked a lot of moves into
existence with the Magnus Robert who can
forget the most epic moment I think in
chess commentary it was the uh it was
the finals of the sea speed Chess
Championship with Magnus playing against
Hikaru and you pointed out a move Bishop
C7 which just hangs a piece in one move
and then you realized it and there was
no way that was going to happen that
Magnus on your command makes that move
that was a shocking moment so definitely
here I'm surprised he didn't go for
Queen C5 but Rook D6 also seems pretty
uh good actually
yeah it does indeed and you know Magnus
is trying to reach that 2900 rating this
would be a great start for him if he can
beat Lavon and Lavon hasn't played in
Vikings day since 2017. so um you know
he's very familiar with the scene he's
won the event four times what is what if
it's been a minute right it's been some
time since he has played invite and uh
well you know he's just getting the
first run under him and I think there's
no worst pairing in the world than black
against Magnus in your first game in a
tournament
it's definitely a tough start I mean any
game against Magnus is really tough but
the first game especially but that said
actually traditionally historically
Magnus is the one who we often see uh
struggle a little bit in the first half
of these events he always tends to start
a little slow and then goes on to wins a
lot of points so probably if you really
want your chance against him
might just be the first round where
you've got your best shot but this
position is not that Robert this is a
kind of position where I think it's
white playing for two results and the
question is does black have enough
activity down on the a file does he have
time to activate that 87 Bishop enough
to be able to do damage control and save
this game I don't see a reality where
black might have any winning chances so
to say in this one yeah and Lavon you
know he's a pretty reasonable person he
also would agree with that he's like I'm
not trying to win this I'm just trying
to hold and the question then becomes
what is White's plan we mentioned ideas
of doubling on the D file you can play
F4 sort of expanding your king side
pawns and because both kings are on the
same side don't be surprised if Magnus
starts throwing up all his pawns right
and there's no attack against the white
king so at some moment he can just push
all of his pawns forward and try to
create attack of his own so uh The Rook
is stable on D6 Rook da just to show one
very quick thing if you think you're
just going to trade Rooks and make a
draw you're very sadly mistaken because
after e takes six the queen has to sit
in front of this pawn and the material
is even but the position is not because
white is going to play E4 F4 get the
pawn to E5 this protected pass pawn and
then black is stuck passively you see
the evaluation bar is very high in
White's favor white would go out to win
this game
yeah if that pawn comes on D6 I think
that would be absolutely all hopes dead
for black there's just no way that Levon
will trade the Rooks on D6 allowing uh
that monstrous spawn to get in there uh
we will come back and see I think
lavon's made a move he's in fact gone
for what we were discussing earlier
taking control of the a file with Rook 8
still problems to be solved here uh by
black uh Robert let's come back to this
one I think it's going to be a slow
grind by Magnus and take a look at some
of the other action
okay the first thing I just want to
mention as we get to the bird's eye view
is in the second game from the left and
the bottom row your invent forest's last
move was Knight C3 back to B1
I just love that move I don't care if
it's good I love it because he's keeping
more pieces on the board and he's saying
my Bishop's Advantage will make its
presence felt with a little bit more
pieces instead of the trade so I love to
have Knight B1 it's just a cool move to
to play the board next to it in the
middle and the bottom has been our
favorite game since the start uh Richard
report and no no deerback abusotaro that
position is interesting black has played
the B6 which opens up that Bishop on F3
on the long diagonal but it also closed
down the Rook on B1 so that's cool
um Tanya any of these other Games
catching your eye in addition to the two
I just mentioned where should we go
let's take a let's get an update on the
all Indian Face-Off between Prague and
Arjun we left it at a time where Black's
Queen was almost trapped but Arjun of
course found the right way to play and
we've had quite a bit of development uh
in this game and let's take it from
where we left it
okay so we left it at that move F7 to F6
by Arjun he needed to save his Queen now
the bishop is loose of Knight G3 you
simply lose the bishop thanks to the
pawns attack so instead we saw some
trades happen and what's so interesting
about this position is I think the moves
that were played were very natural Rook
trade then a rook comes the open file
the bishop slides away and now Bishop to
E4 offering a trade of pieces white is
down a pawn remember white played H4 The
Black Queen took it oh Black's King
seems to be less safe and I believe that
Prague is sending setting up some
tactics here if Bishop takes E4 you may
think that White's gonna take back with
the pawn but we see the evaluation go up
because white will actually play Knight
G3 hitting the queen and then taking
back an E4 with the Knight so getting
this active position the Knight is in
the center this Knight is on the rim is
looking particularly dim and this King
on G8 is less safe so Tanya I like this
move Bishop E4 from prognanda
that's actually a very slight tactic
that you're pointing out and a really
important one because when we have this
position up my first thought was wait a
second what does he want after Bishop E4
and let's say you simply grab fe4 I go I
make a move like Queen H4 a simple move
with a huge thread I want to go Queen F2
next uh attack the E4 part and suddenly
I have so much counter play in the
position and your pawns are going to be
weak I'm happy with black but there's
more Knight G3 that's such a smart
Intermezzo you keep your king safe and
your Knight's the one that jumps onto E4
I love it which makes me think that
perhaps Arjun should not hurry up with
capturing on e4 uh you know the bishop
on B7 is still defended so he doesn't
need to worry about it
but then I'm thinking what's the move
here and that's not an easy question to
answer Robert what do you play with
black if not Bishop E4
I didn't want you to ask me that
question but let me think about it uh so
the queen is the problematic piece for
black and it's not just because of this
Fork that we're seeing after Bishop
takes E4 you point out the uh Bishop B7
is defended from this Knight so maybe a
move like Queen to B5 it's the only
Square I see that gets the queen back
into play I would love to put my queen
on D7 I'm also keeping an eye on this
nine two potentially and The Rook can
always slide back it may seem like white
is winning a piece after Rook CA check
and if the king comes up then Rook C7
check but the black Rook can slide back
to f8 or to F7 with the King on G7 so uh
rook f8 and if we get a trade of Rooks
then it's hard to see how white attacks
and white is down a part so if the
attack Fizzles out and black is able to
keep the king safe it's going to be
Arjun who's gonna play for a win up the
pawn so I think that both sides have to
be very careful at this moment for Arjun
it's not to make a move that gets you in
huge trouble your king under attack like
we see after 19 E3 and Knight takes E4
with a rook slamming down the C file so
he needs to avoid that and for Prague
Nanda he needs to
initiative up because the moment the
piece traded it Fizzles out he's going
to look at a pawn down end game where
black actually has an outside pass Pawn
potential
this is such a critical moment and we
see Arjun on our screen who doesn't even
seem to be looking at the board I don't
believe that he's made a move already
but we shouldn't be fooled by him not
looking at the board because I can
guarantee you Robert wherever he's
looking the board is inside his mind
he's actually thinking about the moves
right now he is calculating all these
lines that we're mentioning he's
spotting the dangers of Bishop E4 Knight
G3 deciding that whether he wants to
give this B7 Bishop he also has the
alternative to Simply sidestep the trade
with a move like Bishop A6 which also
has its advantages because you keep the
C8 Square under control it might look a
little scary to allow Rooks to get
checks you're also eyeing the E2 Knight
I like the move Bishop A6 as well apart
from Queen B5 bringing that Queen into
play so an important moment for Arjun
and uh undoubtedly wherever he's looking
right now he's definitely only thinking
about what next move to make
for sure and you know what you just said
is why he's thinking he has several
interesting options he can eliminate
Bishop takes E4 that's probably the
first one like wait Bishop E4 what if I
just take politics and he rose way way
we don't have to be uh looking just at
the simple recapture Knight G3 that
doesn't look good so he's gonna
eliminate Bishop E4 but that leaves
Bishop A6 which you uh just mentioned
and queen to B5 and they're probably
other moves as well uh but those two
moves both look interesting and it's a
very different type of game do we want
to trade Bishops do you want to keep
them on the board that's the big
question because this Knight would like
to get to the E4 Square uh ASAP and well
it's not that easy to get there if the
bishop goes to A6 because there's a
bishop on e4 in its place and this
Knight convention come to C4 the queen
can still slide across the board so I'm
liking Bishop A6 more now that you've
mentioned I think that keeping more
material on the board could be dangerous
because Black's King is in worse shape
but it also controls more squares yeah
it would be an enterprising option and
Arjun is a very enterprising player I
will not be surprised if he chooses to
keep the minor pieces and not traded he
is all of 19 years old and let's take a
look at uh some of his performances he
in fact did win the challenges with a
phenomenal score of 10 and a half and
Robert fun fact before the challenges he
actually mentioned that that is his aim
his aim is to score that and a half out
of 13. he knew that that is the score
required to win the event to qualify for
the Masters he did it he in fact won the
challenges one round to spare it was
such a convincing performance by him
last year at the Tata steel that he
garnered massive praise from the likes
of Anand from the likes of Magnus
Carlsen and it was his breakout event
this very event last year is when uh
Arjun made his mark on the Chess World
and he's here because he's earned his
spot he along with his compatriots the
Young irrigate the young talents of the
world the five youngsters playing here
currently in the Tata steel Masters
Arjun is the eldest amongst them at 19.
it's very funny to be the Elder
Statesman at just 19 but he has made his
move and he has
got enough from the board after
retreating The Rook to F7 and uh well he
brings that Rook back he wants to defend
the seventh rank he's also going to
protect his King against some checks and
The Rook on F6 wasn't really doing all
that much staring at some Pawn so if
those pawns were in danger then it would
make sense the kid to work there it said
he slides it back and he just showed
that he had another option it wasn't
just Bishop A6 it wasn't just Queen B5
Rook F7 all of those moves kept the
position dynamically balanced but Argent
is a pawn ahead so if he can withstand
the pressure he will remain that pawn up
but his King isn't the safest which may
give white the necessary checks and just
the ability to hold the position if
things start to get away from him so I
think Prague Nana he looks focused he is
going to figure out his next move and
while he does that why don't we go back
to the bird's eye view take a look at
our other games because we still have
all seven in progress so Tanya my eyes
first go to the game between Jordan Von
forest and Wesley so that's second from
the left on the bottom just because I
see the Knight went back to B1 and then
black also made this move F7 to F5 a
very committal move in the position
clearly trying to stop white from
pushing the E2 pawn and I'm also looking
at the top right of the screen Fabiano
caruana has the Knight on C4 has the
light score control but I'm looking at
the e-file bar and it looks like it's in
a niche Gary's favor so that's
interesting to note
yeah very interesting and once you look
at the Fabi board one gets the feeling
that again uh White is making such slow
progress but we shouldn't be fooled by
the bar because it's still a very solid
position and white can always go B3
Bishop B2 IDs but the one board that
really has my attention is against the
Richard rapper versus not the backboard
I mean look at that position Robert
we've got to bring that up and really
see what is happening because you see a
king on D1 long Castle the bishop on F3
I mean what on Earth is this metal game
um you're asking all the right questions
and I have none of the right answers so
I mean there's a king on D1 it looks
pretty safe as we mentioned before but
if Bishop takes D4 happens and D3 is
available then it could be in grave
danger so for now after Knight H3 B6 it
is White's move I think you know Richard
he won by Knight F4 or Knight to G5 uh
but Knight F4 might not be right here
anymore and the reason why is after
Knight F4 I think G5 might be a good
response and you're attacking the Knight
forcing the issue if you take on E6
Queen takes E6 now E5 is threatened and
this Pawn may go to F4 at some point I
know I have to watch out because my king
and queen are on the same line but F4 at
some moment could be good G4 could be
good as well and if you play Bishop D5 I
just want to show uh how this position
can go really wrong for white like if I
get this position it doesn't matter that
I give him a rook for quote unquote just
a bishop and pawn A2 is under attack E5
is under attack the black king is now
safe the white king is still on D1 F4 is
available Tanya this position could
quickly get out of hand for Richard
it's just such a rush has such a rich
Rich middle game right now that we've
got and the move B6 which was just
played you know it's such a difficult
move to make Robert because you kind of
just create so many light squared
weaknesses but it's really the only way
that nadebeck can free his knight from
C6 and while you were discussing these
ideas of Knight F4 bringing the Rook
into the game I'm trying to think what
is it that black wants after B6 and one
thing that white needs to watch out for
is that now that the black Knight's free
to jump into the game ideas like night
before come into mind and where am I
headed with that Knight let's say you go
A3 hitting that Knight it's not to A6
but suddenly I can actually dream about
even going Knight A2 here Robert I hit
your Bishop on C1 I'm targeting that C3
Square Knight C3 coming in and suddenly
blacks got so much play so white has to
watch out for these ideas and I like the
move B6 suddenly Black's the one with
coming in with all the threats
can I just say I love the Knight A2 as
an option and uh what Tanya just
demonstrated for everyone including for
me because I wasn't thinking about that
is you want to think about where your
pieces belong what their dream square is
where you know where can they go to and
the Knight on C6 right now it looks
pretty decent it's putting pressure on
E5 but a knight on C3 would be
devastating how do you get there I mean
night before it's protected by the
bishop on E7 and it simply attacks a
loose Pawn while opening up the queen to
A4 which could create other problems for
white so the issue could be forced to
some extent where white has to play A3
and as you said the Knight isn't
retreating A6 and even if the Knight got
to C5 that would look pretty good but
Knight to A2 or attacks the bishop and
tries to go to C3 because just to show
that line one more time
that even if you cover the C3 Square
let's say we get this position A3 is now
loose C4 is loose with the open D file
and the queen can go to A4 things of
this nature white doesn't really have an
attack despite this bishop on F3 looking
very promising
yeah those Bishops will be talking if
the position opens up so white needs to
be careful it all comes down to is black
going to be successful in opening up
this D line because then the King on D1
would be in huge trouble so Knight B4 is
definitely a potential plan for not a
back here Richard having a think on how
he can play against it not that easy you
pointed out the line with Knight F4 G5
sacrificing that exchange eventually on
D5 I love that idea as well uh and I
have to say that I was very hopeful for
White's position just a couple of moves
ago but now after pointing out all these
subtleties
maybe the King on D1 is going to tell
and be a weakness
yeah that's uh the big question that has
been asked ever since the king went
there very early in this game on move 11
and for uh Richard and Knight before now
to my eyes looks like a big threat how
do you deal with that threat not very
easy Bishop D2 feels very passive G5
will still be available in many
positions for black I know it looks like
a pawn sacrifice but often I can get a
rook to G8 to uh pin that piece to the
queen
King is here which means the Rooks are
not connected I feel like white just has
many issues right now I see the evil bar
saying white is okay I just don't feel
like practically speaking it's that easy
for Richard at noribbeck he just took a
drink of water I mean he should be
confident by his position
absolutely agree with that and I think
players have this little tell you know
in a stressful situation when you lean
back some players just take off their
jacket put them on the seats some take a
sip of the drink that they've got there
you know whatever it is that they uh
they enjoy get up take a walk it just
seems to show that the Dynamics and the
position are shifting the energy is
Shifting and from a complex position not
a back I think does feel happy with the
outcome of the opening I think and he
should be with the black pieces it's
everything to play for a game where all
three results are possible and currently
regardless of what the eval Bar says I
think we can all agree that we'd rather
be black hair than white so Richard
needs to bring on that creativity to
solve his problems uh let's take a look
at some of the other boards the uh let's
bring our bird's eye view Robert because
my attention was also taken up by what's
happening on the Vincent board
wow Yes actually we should look there
just for a second before we do I'm
looking at uh the game with bottom left
between Ding and gukesh was like a
bishop on C3 and a queen on F6 pieces
are flying across the board there and
left uh Magnus has induced the move H5
from LeBron that could be a long-term
Target but it seems that Levant need to
stop Magnus from doing the same so he
puts his Pawn on the light square but
I'm with you all right let's go over to
the game between Parham maxulu with the
white pieces and Vincent Cameron with
the black pieces because the Evo bar is
dipping heavily in the young German
favor here and he'll cross 2700 with the
win and it'll be a great win at that
with the black pieces but Tanya wow I
mean this just looks like such a strong
position for Vincent
and I'm trying to understand why and the
things that stand out for me in this
position that why it is giving our eval
bar loves black is because of one thing
and that is the C5 Pawn Robert it's such
a huge weakness in this position for
white and black has an immediate way of
targeting this Pawn you can go 97 you
can't hit it with Rook A5 but the lines
that we need to look at is that is does
white have the option to actually pick
up the C6 Pawn is white threatening
Knight C6 B take C6 and queen C6 because
if not black has a free hand to win the
C5 Pawn
right I mean your point yeah just you
can bring your pieces and go directly
after it I feel like I just don't want
to give up the C6 Pawn maybe it's fear
that I shouldn't have but if I am scared
I could just make the move Rook E6 it's
a very simple move to defend the Knight
and if you take then my Rook joins the
party and can attack this Pawn on C5 and
the E5 Pawn is ultra well defended by
this bishop sitting on C7 so
on one hand Black's position could look
a bit passive right the bishop is
staring into a pawn
it was a night on B4 Queen on F3 things
looking good for white but this Pawn on
C5 sticks out like a sore thumb and it
may not be long sitting on this board so
I I do really like Vincent's position I
like his clock management and now the
question is does he make this move let's
say Rook to E6 or queen to D7 just to
defend the Knight or does he go forward
with a move like Rook A5 which also
looks very interesting no I love rookie
six I mean if you've got traps on the
board you want to keep that a thread is
better than its execution why give up
the C6 Pawn C5 is a weakness forever
Rook E6 keeps everything under control
and you're threatening Knight D7 Rook A5
Queen E7 C5 is a weakness forever so you
can take it slow and I understand why
the valbar does like a Black's position
control on the center E5 D4 really
cramping up White's position black has
the space Advantage white has the
weakness in C5 you can feel a disharmony
a this coordination in white spaces Rook
B1 rookie one are not connected white
doesn't have any big targets you've got
your queen on one side the Knight on B4
on the other side the only hope that
white has is to put this Knight on D2 go
Knight C4 or go Knight E4 and try and
trade off some pieces create some
threats of Bishop it's six maybe someday
but it's so hard to imagine white
getting anything concrete in this
position meanwhile Lux plan is clear
that get the C5 Pawn Win the C5 Pawn
I like that plan and it seems like one
that Vincent can execute without much
issue look at White's lack of
development there's a bishop on C1 a
knight in front of it on D2 so when you
start pushing pawns away from other
pawns they're going to be targets so the
last few moves I mean if we just scroll
back in time we saw A5 and then A3 was
played taking away the B4 Square which
means Knight takes D4 is uh threat and
Vincent played E5
he'd simply push his Pawn to A4 that way
if you push your B Pawn then I take on
passant so B4 I will take on Busan and
ruin your Pawn structure this A3 Pawn
might be a long term Target and so and
the Knight can go to D7 to C5 like you
mentioned earlier so instead you went
Knight B4 taking advantage of the fact
that the pawn is no longer an A5 but
Vincent played simple straightforward
chess rookie eight C5 played if you take
I take your knight and then I take your
Pawn E5 thank you for all the Targets in
the board this is going to be very bad
news for black so instead simple
retreating move good knight to D2 let me
develop a Tempo so I think that Vincent
has done everything very naturally Tanya
and it's not like Parham has done
anything drastic but he's sitting here
with a lack of development with a
overextended pawn and with a much worse
position on move 18.
I agree this is big trouble for white
and uh knowing Winston's style of play
he's not going to go in for any rash
stuff he's not going to try and win the
pawn immediately I think he's going to
prefer to play it slow keep all his
trumps and a goal for well the kill to
so to say for the C5 Pawn at the right
moment let's take a look at our bird's
eye view so we can see some of the other
birds and some of the other actions on
this one we can call as black having
quite a bit of Advantage with that C5
Pawn being a massive weakness
wow I mean looking across the seven
boards here uh Magnus Carlson still
thinking after the move H5 we see the
move D5 to D4 played by dingler and that
game is really exciting so I think it's
time for us to take a short break uh but
you know there's still so many players
in the playing Hall taking part uh all
of the amateur uh tournaments
swimming The Spectators because the menu
is free to visit so you look at that
playing Hall you see a tremendous crowd
of Chess lovers and players hey I saw
someone just poke someone else on the
shoulder so I don't know what's going on
over there oh just trying to get through
excuse me please I need to get to my
board but that is the playing venue so
much action taking place we'll return to
this action in a few minutes this is the
Tata steel Masters tournament 2023 we'll
be right back
[Music]
oh yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
from the 13th to the 29th January 2023
the world famous data steel chess
tournament will be organized for the
85th time a milestone we are very proud
of in 1938 we started the whole office
chess tournaments initially it was a
tournament only for the employees of our
Steel company
but over the many years it transformed
into a world-class International
Tournament a tournament for which all
Grand Masters emerging top talents and
amateurs like to clear their agendas the
community of vacancy is very important
to us the Tata steel chess tournament is
a great opportunity for the chess fans
to visit this beautiful Village
as you can see I am in the muriano an
empty gym people were even playing
badminton a few minutes ago here and I'm
sure it will be the Beating Heart of the
international Chess World so here the
four Team Masters will play their
competition to decide who will win the
85th Tata steel chess tournament not
only the Masters group also the
challenges group and amateur events as
well as the spectators that we hope to
see back we have the absolute elite
players in the world but also five very
strong Junior players who are almost
there to compete with them for the
highest place on the world ranking list
so I'm sure this will make our next data
Shield test on an extremely interesting
to follow
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
s
for this cozy coastal town the holiday
season isn't over
in fact the most wonderful time of the
year has really just begun and look at
the intense focus on magnus's face what
a performance it has been
once again Vicon Zay starts the new year
as the center of the chess Universe this
year as host of the 85th taught to Steel
chess tournament
a magnet for the best players in the
game some recognize the Masters field of
2023 as its strongest in recent memory
of course it helps when eight-time Tata
steel chess champion Magnus Carlson is
back the world's number one looks to
further cement his legacy in this event
and the game's history
chasing Magnus will be amongst the best
in chess several have been crowned
championed here before some have even
shocked the world in doing so
have the winner of the tournament and it
is Jordan Fanfare winning the dramatic
Armageddon
don't leave out those poised to capture
their first Tata title
although winter Tata steel chess is also
known as the place new stars come to
bloom
Magnus one here is a teenager this
year's event has its fair share of young
players on the rise each hoping to
follow in Carlson's footsteps
the Dutch referred to Tata steel as The
Wimbledon of chess for 85 years and
running this tournament continues to be
steep in Prestige and Legacy and does so
again in this welcoming Little Dutch
town by the sea
mind Brendan it's the 85th edition of
the Tata steel chess tournament and it
starts right now
and we are back in the playing Hall in
Vikings a you see the many chess players
taking part in this Festival this is the
Wimbledon of Chess this is the 85th
edition of Tata steel chess and this is
Magnus Carlson taking on levonne aronian
we see Magnus fully focused trying to uh
get more squeeze this position Tanya I
mean he has a slight Advantage but you
being a levonne and ronian Backer from
the beginning you're saying that despite
what looks like an unpleasant position
now that he's rolling up his sleeves he
can handle it
what an incredible atmosphere we saw
there Robert I just love it just chess
fans players all there in why can't they
enjoying this amazing incredible
tournament it is the most prestigious
event of the Year this is what kicks off
the chess calendar this is the Wimbledon
of Chess and what an atmosphere what
energy and the chess in round one hasn't
disappointed we've seen amazing opening
ideas we've seen incredible fights in
the middle game some intense end games
right now going on Magnus Carlson you
were pointing out he definitely looks
like he's doing really well against love
but still there's a lot of work to be
done earlier on in the break we saw some
in some really cool images of Magnus and
other winners of the event he's already
won the event eight times he's been
eight times champion of I can't say the
most number of time any player has ever
won the event but we know Magnus he's
never happy he always wants more he's so
self-critical he is here we with one job
and one job only that is to win it for
the ninth time and I have to say is not
an off to a pretty good start with the
white pieces against love this is a
dream position for Magnus
well you've mentioned that he has had
slow starts in years past and he still
has managed to win the events so right
now he has a good position in edge with
the white pieces more activity a safer
King an active Rook on D6 anchored in
there by a Pawn on E5 so all is looking
good for Magnus Carlson but not always
looking bad for levonne aronian it's not
like there's a clear Target in the
position we look at Pawn chains the pawn
F7 really hard to get to the bishop
protecting it which means the pawn E6 is
safe and sound the pawn on B7 not very
easy to get to maybe with one piece with
a rook but to team up on it will not be
easy and the E5 Pawn may be a long-term
Target as well that means Heaven I kept
on it so white is better but actually
creating threats will not be simple and
that's why Magnus is you know he's made
the move King to G2 a quiet move saying
to Lavon okay now it's your turn how are
you going to continue this game if your
queen ever leaves that invites my Rook
to D7 I don't think you really want to
allow that move so I just feel like
Magnus Position will remain more active
and he is the best in the world and
winning positions just like this most
people will say handshake in a few moves
it's just to draw Magnus says no no no I
like my position I can push and press
and look at Lavon hands on his head he's
not you know worried just yet but he may
be as this game continues
I mean when you're playing Magnus your
word throughout the whole game and as
you pointed out and explained it in all
its subtleties the thing about this
position is that it may not be a big
Advantage for white but it's just so
much more unpleasant to play with black
to keep defending with black disposition
you just have to sit still and tight and
hope that it doesn't get worse but where
can it get worse is the question that we
need to ask ourselves Robert and the one
plan that does stand out for me to
create more weaknesses in Black's
position eventually would be to try once
you've doubled up on the D file at the
right time to go and break with B4 B5
you need to create weaknesses H5 is a
potential weakness later on later on but
in chess we have the rule of two
weaknesses you need one more point to
attack and that could potentially be the
B7 Pawn Magnus will take it slow he's
going to take his time to execute this
plan but I'm pretty sure we're gonna see
it happen on the board someday yes and
if he just sits on the position what you
know puts the queen on D4 he might also
play G4 just to force a trade and then
try to play H5 uh the black king doesn't
have too many Defenders over here so you
have to watch out for ideas like that so
I just really like the look of the
position I know it sounds like we're
saying Magnus is so much better he might
be winning we're not saying anything of
the sword we at the highest level of
Chess these players they often crumble
but they don't have ideas to play when
they're shuffling back and forth and
their opponent is creating a small
pressure with every single move the
karpovian path I like to call it because
when Anatoly karpov the legendary world
champion played there are some games I
looked at of his where I'm like I don't
know where his opponent went wrong it
looked like a very normal game and then
suddenly it was uncomfortable and then
the next thing you know it's losing so
uh for Magnus he employs that type of
style boa constrictor play and he's
going to do try to do that to Levon of
ronin who has won this tournament four
times and is not going to back down to
magnus's pressure beautifully explained
there that it is again just the onus on
a level on that how is he going to
continue playing this position when
white has these ideas of going G4 B4 B5
Magnus can just go on and cramp black
further and further making play more
difficult uh but that said again Black's
position is solid Magnus needs to show
that Magnus touch which he often has the
one thing in lebon's favor is the clock
he is so much ahead in clock and that
can come to his rescue at some point
when he needs it but it's still far off
from now uh Magnus still has about 40
minutes I see on our screen let's take a
look at the bird's eye view and some of
the other games that we've got going on
Robert
for sure you know move on on the clock
he doesn't really have a clear plan so
he'll need to figure that out but as we
look across these seven boards uh the
game between Fabiano and Nish Geary it
looks like they're fighting for control
of the light squares over there on the
queen side that's the top right uh in
the middle on the bottom I'm still
mesmerized by the game between Richard
report and Notre Beck Abdul sitarov the
Knight has landed on F4 this will be
interesting to see next few moves
dingley Ren and bukash we haven't seen
that game uh you know we haven't looked
at it too much but right now dingley run
with the pair of Bishops and progdananda
it's second from the right and the
bottom against our generic I see The
Rook is trying to infiltrate attack the
E6 Pawn things are vulnerable and
Vincent kymer has played your Rook A5
move and kept a big Advantage so telling
you he did not need to defend the C6
Square he plays Rook A5 right away uh he
will win that C5 Pawn if white takes on
C6 twice so I think that he's saying I
like Tanya's a plan of action here I'm
just going to activate and well be way
better developed well we should take a
look at that let's just bring that up if
we can on our full screen because Rook
A5 is such a commitment move we thought
Rook E6 keeps everything under control
Rook A5 always in the air we're gonna
love all of that but instead he goes for
it immediately and sure you can't just
allow Rook C5 right you can't just lose
a pawn but what happens after Knight C6
what if white actually grabs Knight C6
you take back on C6 I have a queen on F3
and I can just recapture on C6 again
what does Winston have in mind here
probably rookie six so he's just
changing the move order and changing the
position giving up was might have been a
long-term weakness on B7 the queen has
to go back and there's nowhere it can go
to keep in contact with the CFI Pawn so
if the queen drops back say to F3 back
where it came from Rook takes C5 thank
you so much I have active Rooks this
Rook may even come to C6 and take
advantage of the open C file if you play
Knight C4 you have to watch out for E4
removing the guard of that Knight on C4
and Black's one Pawn takes care of two
of whites I think that you know Vincent
is just saying I'm gonna trade instead
of winning a pawn but I remain much
better and Black's pieces are harmonious
White's pieces are not developed and
this bishop C1 in particular is just bad
I agree with you you know you get all
these trades on the board and after Rook
C5 it just looks like a dominating
position for black your pawns are better
your pieces are better white it's got no
activity at all uh the Knight is jumping
to D5 at some point and this is what
Vincent has gone for Parham in a bit of
a thing and in quite a bit of uh trouble
there I saw that uh one of our viewers
mentioned that they're surprised that
the way Parham has played the opening
and
I have to say that I would agree with
that with the white pieces it just feels
like Parham got into trouble really
early on without getting any game in
yeah it's just not going his way and it
could be because he just got invited to
the tournament he wasn't expecting to
play in this top section he has the time
to prepare his openings but I do think
that Parham is the type of player who he
makes some decisions that you know
others wouldn't like I don't think he
and Wesley so play in the same universe
of Chess in terms of style Right Wesley
is always very calm playing safely and
Parham says I don't mind bringing the
fight but sometimes it can backfire so I
think uh he will take on C6 he took once
likely will take twice and then we'll
lose the C5 Pawn in return and just be
worse as this game continues we'll see
if he's able to hold on but let's go
back to the bird's eye view just because
uh you know we haven't given other games
the attention that we would like to and
I think the game particular is the one
in the bottom left game between gookash
and dingley ren earlier on we were
praising dingler's time management his
lead on the clock and we thought he made
some interesting decisions to keep the
position asymmetrical vehicle it remains
just that and Tanya I have to say at
least at first glance I preferred
Black's position in the bottom left
there because it's a bishop pair and I
think that Black's pieces are very well
placed
I would agree with everything that
you're saying but my first question is
that Bishop D4 has been played on with
the C6 spawn is hanging uh I mean don't
you just lose the pawn in this position
and that's the line that I want to look
at
yeah I guess there are going to be
tactics revolving around this D3 Knight
and this F2 Pawn so that is what we need
to work out here but the Rook on E8 is
loose so I think if we go down a
variation that looks very natural Bishop
takes C6 Bishop takes D3 just trying to
remove the guard of the F2 Pawn after
say Rook takes D3 we don't have the move
that would be really strong here Queen
takes F2 check it looks almost winning
for black but the problem is The Rook on
E8 is hanging at the end of the line
because after Queen takes Bishop takes
is check the king takes back thank you
your loose Rook is now mine but so is
this Rook on E8 that would allow white
to end a piece ahead so this tactical
sequence wouldn't quite work and that
means we have to find an alternative to
Bishop takes D3 and taking on F2 so what
is that alternative that's the question
you asked maybe it's Rook C8 pinning the
bishop here now threatening D3 now
threatening C6 the F2 Pawn is loose Tony
at the very least it gets really
complicated very quickly very messy and
actually all the things that you pointed
out in Black's favor still stand I mean
the two Bishops are monstrous Precision
the bishop and D4 and the bishop and A6
they're worth way more than a pawn and
after a move like Rook C8 you also pin
the bishop on C6 so it just looks like a
lot of white spaces are extremely loose
in the position and ideas of after Rook
C8 uh Bishop E8 might look like it is
winning two Rooks but I think again the
pieces are going to tell because of the
A6 and the D4 Bishop let's see let's say
you trade twice and how do you how do
you finish white off here because it
feels like something should be hanging
in this position Queen F3 is that a move
looks like a great move hitting this
Rook hitting this Knight and you can
defend both the same time but I think
you get checkmated uh if you're Rook to
D2 after Bishop takes D3 Rook takes D3 I
take with the bishop once the King goes
here I just bring my Bishop back the
king is only one legal move and that
Queen F2 wow check and made so you're
absolutely correct that uh Rook C8 is a
legitimate pin that white can't get out
of because uh giving up the queen is the
most important defender in the position
and so uh you know we see a position
where there are threats against White's
King and just if you don't take on C6
Tanya if you make a more passive move
like say I don't know even Knight F4
it's a random move black plays C5 and I
really believe that the advantage starts
to grow for dingly red
I agree with you Robert I mean just as
Bishop on D4 targeting the F2 Pawn just
look at the Harmony in Black's pieces
everything is beautifully placed
meanwhile White's only targeted C6 which
you can't do anything about at the
moment and once black gets in C5 that
Target is gone as I make my Bishop on D4
even more solid white is going to have a
hard time here defending this your case
is uh in quite a bit of trouble and uh I
have to say that thing has played this
game really well so far you know
creating his chances taking decisions
which regardless of what the eval Bar
says are difficult for gokish to answer
you remember we were discussing that
recapture on the D5 Pawn taking it in a
way that gives both players chances so
really nicely paid games so far and I
have to say this is going to be tough
for gokish to defend
it will especially considering the time
situation still plenty of time on this
clock to reach move 40 it's move 22 at
the moment but you get the sense that
things could slip out of control if he's
not careful
um in this position already I mean the
bishop 186 very well placed if you move
this Knight to say B4 I think you're
getting a double attack on the bishop of
the pawn that allows The Rook to come
down to E2 with the F2 Pawn hanging next
so you have to be really careful here if
you are good cash because there are many
tactics in this position and I think
that dingley Wren just he's in the
driver's seat right now with the black
pieces in game one he wants to make this
tournament count you brought this point
up earlier Tanya that this may be his
final event for the world championship
match against the under palm tree we
don't know when that is we don't know
where it is we have really no details on
it maybe dingley Wren has more insights
there but regardless he wants to have a
strong showing build up that confidence
and that rating frankly as he goes on to
face you on the palm machine
we saw Magnus that briefly having a look
on this game and just looking at it and
walking off immediately gives a sense
that even just visually you see this and
you know that black is doing well here
uh you we were talking about how
important this event is for doing not
just for dang for gukesh as well and
it's so crucial in these kind of
tournaments where every game you're
gonna play against the best players in
the world to try and have a good start
because will do everything he can to
hold this game so that he's at least
able to get away with the draw he's all
of 16 making his debut here at the Tata
steel uh Masters he's had a really great
year in 2022 but the last couple of
tournaments haven't gone that well for
him and he's just 16 years old he is the
youngest player in the field so he still
has a long way to go he had a phenomenal
performance at the Olympiad won the gold
medal on board one uh but the last few
tournaments that he played he wasn't
very happy with it and Robert he was
also going to play the world rapid and
Blitz but last minute decided not to do
so so he could prepare get some rest for
Tata steel Masters so he's definitely
going to be a little disappointed if
this game doesn't go his way
and you know it's important to point
these things out because if you look at
his ear as a whole as you said he had a
tremendous increase in raiding he you
know went on everyone's radar he won a
gold medal at the Olympiad on board one
I mean he was just showing masterful
performances uh but then downstretch he
kind of stagnated a little bit now he's
16 years old you can't win every single
event you can't you know keep gaining
rating at every single tournament but
that's probably a bit frustrating when
you experience all that success and then
kind of run into a roadblock now he's in
with all the best players in the world
right now some of his fellow teenagers
who are also uh rising to the occasion
but then you have the dingley rents who
have that experience who will punish you
if you are not accurate at every single
turn so it's a big moment for good cash
I think for his entire tournament not
you know not that he's going to be
rattled by a single loss but you don't
want to start out this tournament with a
loss with the white pieces that's really
not the way to get your introduction to
vikon Zay so I think that he has a lot
to figure out right now with his Bishop
on D4 and his Bishop on A6 causing him
problems we'll leave him to it we'll go
back to the bird's eye view for now as a
gookesh you know in his Maiden Vikings a
event you know he has a lot to figure
out in the position but I mean I'm
looking at the Jordan vent Forest game
in the second from the left and the
bottom there there's like a black Bishop
on G2
and I think black's up a pawn so things
have gone
wrong for Jordan Von forest and it's
Wesley so suddenly who's up material
well let's bring that game up because
that's definitely been a turnaround and
the bishop and G2 you just need to be a
little careful that you don't end up
getting trapped there uh because even
after Bishop H3 you don't have a runoff
and you mentioned that
black has an extra pawn and indeed the
e-pawn is there I'm not really sure how
this happened should we just back up and
see how Georgian managed to lose a pawn
out of a position where we thought he's
got a double Bishop advantage and all
the trumps we were so impressed with his
play
yeah and he made the move Knight to B1
which I thought was cool you know not
caring about the evaluation but then we
see the bar let's do that one more time
it was slightly better for white and
after the move it says
not so great so it was a little too
fancy if he wanted to avoid a nitrate
maybe Knight to B5 made sense he could
have allowed a nitrate as well you know
by taking on D5 but he wanted more piece
on the board and it turns out that
Wesley quickly strikes F5 taking away
this Pawn push to E4 if you play E4 even
Knight back to F6 because there is a
problem on this diagonal and so you have
to watch out for that so instead we saw
castles Rook D7 very simple chess from
Wesley so he all he did was double his
Rooks in the open file and look at that
that's a stunner
yeah that's a move that's very easy to
miss we see that the Rooks are staring
at each other and I believe that Jordan
you might have overlooked at The Rook D7
Knight takes E2 check it looks like
you're just gonna lose a piece here uh
but the problem is after Rook D7 his
Bishop is under attack once the king
takes and if you take the bishop on B7
down goes a rook a more valuable piece
on C1 so his hand was forced to give up
this bishop on G2 and he's simply down a
pawn so he overlooked Knight of four
good tactical Vision by Wesley so
and that's the thing about Wesley right
he gets his chance he doesn't miss it he
is so good at defending and keeping
everything solid but you give him that
one small opportunity and he spots it
immediately we've seen him do that time
and time again in fast flip fast play
formats so definitely a move like Knight
F4 is so up his radar and he will uh
he'll spot it in just a jiffy and that
trick cost Jordan upon and I have to say
looking at the current position it looks
like a really healthy pawn my first
feeling was wait a second does black
need to be worried about this bishop on
G2 can it get trapped but actually it's
absolutely safe on the H3 Square you
gotta move like King F2 but I go Bishop
H3 and you can't go G4 because black
simply picks up that pawn so no worries
about the bishop the only thing is the
only chance that white has is if white
manages to trade off all the other
pieces because Robert then you could
potentially end up in an opposite color
bishop and game so even though black has
an hell the extra Pawn this is far from
over simply because of the opposite
color Bishops white also has an activity
along the C file can go on to improve
the night position ideas like Knight D2
Knight C4 come to mind trying to put
pressure uh definitely a pawn up but far
from winning
and what white would love to do is trade
these Rooks like if these Rooks came off
the board you'd feel very confident
about your chances to make a draw and if
the knights came off as well then you
know for a fact it's a draw there's no
question whatsoever because the extra
pawn it can't really push white will
have a dark Square blockade because
inherently a bishop can only control its
own colors you would not be able to
check a king off the E3 square or the E1
Square for example so that is what
Jordan needs to do let's trade Knights
let's trade Brooks that's not going to
happen anytime soon you cannot play Rook
D1 you simply lose not just would you
lose a pawn if you take on D1 take on F3
Bishop takes F3 check actually just wins
material because your king is distracted
away and then you lose not just an
exchange a full Rook once I get your
minor piece so
Tanya We're not gonna see the trades
that Jordan needs you said Knight D2
Knight C4 but that just you know allows
the game to continue so what Wesley so
has is a pawn up position that he can
play without any risk whatsoever this is
bad news for the Dutch player Jordan Von
Forest who has previously won this very
event
when I'm talking about the game
continuing I at Nike to play it and I'm
just wondering if black can actually
create chances or at least a pass Pawn
immediately with the move like E4 but
then let's just show this line it's
important to watch out because after E4
which is super tempting white can
actually take on e4 and then go King F2
and now your Bishop is stuck to defend
the E4 pawn and you might just end up
losing that extra Pawn immediately so
you've got to play slow here
right I mean the pawn E5 is healthy
where it was sitting but as Tanya's
pointing out on this line you know now
all of a sudden your Bishop is hit and
you could actually keep the bishop on H1
it's pretty funny but then the king can
even come back to G1 to force it to F3
and I think a series of Trades would be
in White's favor there uh because the
pawn F3 wouldn't probably be long for
the board so you're absolutely right the
E4 not likely to occur right now instead
let's just play this you know a bit
slowly we can just move our King up to
F7 at some point but we do have to watch
out for the line you were talking about
so maybe the king um is better away from
the action and if the knight ever moves
to C4 then you strike with E4 because
you're healthily protected so it's like
a a game of individual moves at this
point Jordan trying to keep his
composure he has lost a pawn I'm sure
he's disappointed about that and for
Wesley so you couldn't dream up a better
start to this event if the black pieces
against a very strong well-prepared
opponent and now you're up a pawn no
risk whatsoever you can play for a win
and just try to grind this game amount
it's going to be a long long one I mean
Wesley's got this extra healthy Pawn
he's gonna play this one out till the
end Jordan's got a big task ahead of him
but definitely the opposite color Bishop
gives white a lot of hope to be able to
hold this we will come back to this
Robert which other games catch your
attention because I can see a lot of
action on and the one game that again uh
I just want to jump to straight away
would be the Richard versus not a bad
game I mean that's on the center of our
screen and if you take a look uh quite
we've got a few moves from when we left
it last uh G5 happened the knights have
been traded off and White's got his rook
and Rook on B5 so it's quite an
interesting position do you want to take
a look at that
yeah let's take a look at that one first
and then we'll definitely go to the
Vincent kymer and paramuksulu game
because much has changed there and we
see the move Rook to B5 was just played
here uh liftoff trying to cover the D5
Square remember earlier some of you may
remember if you were here if you're
weren't here hi good to see you but the
point was that Bishop D5
um now the queen is in trouble and the
Knight needs it a queen's defense so
Queen takes E5 you simply lose your
knight on C6 but I'm ready to sacrifice
on D5 and then take back on D5 and you
can see I didn't just draw those now
this was sitting here from earlier that
the E5 Pawn the A2 Pawn are both in
trouble the black king is safe the white
king is in the center this would not be
a good look for Richard so instead he
brought his Rook up to B5 which protects
the pawn on E5 right now and also
threads to go Bishop to D5 which hits
the queen and makes this queen move into
a place where it defends the Knight so
Tyler I think this position is very rich
I think one mistake that can be made
right now is move Pawn to F4 you attack
the queen you cut it off from this Pawn
E5 after F4 I think white even has the
bishop G4 giving up the queen to take
your queen with check and then once your
king moves out the way somewhere you
just take this pawn and then white is up
a pawn with a new open file for The Rook
Rook B5 such an interesting move because
it really does renew the idea of going
Bishop D5 next which we really wanted
and I was thinking Robert how can black
fight it and we've been talking about
another plan for black right get your
try and you want your knight on C3 try
and get it Go night before defend this
move Bishop D5 from coming in Attack the
A2 Pawn Target Knight A2 Knight C3 and
then suddenly you're also threatening a
move like A6 and The Rook on V5 looks
like it's trapped so what is it that
white has in mind and immediately when
you ask that question the first thing
that came to my mind was that is he
planning to sacrifice an exchange after
night before because if you got Bishop
G5 for example I think I'm really happy
with picking up the 8-2 pawn
and this just gets really complicated
for why it looks like a mess with Knight
C3 coming in but I think what's more
scary in this position instead of
picking up the pawn on G5 sacrifice your
Rook that Knight is worth an exchange
and not just that you actually do end up
picking the G5 one Pawn with your Bishop
with a Tempo and maybe this is what
Richard wants he wants this position
with the two Bishops and says that he's
got enough compensation
yeah what an idea that is I mean we're
just talking about how black was going
to sacrifice in exchange in the D5
Square now it's Richard's turn to
sacrifice on B4 you get a pawn and a
bishop for your troubles and this isn't
just any Bishop this is an insanely
strong Bishop on an open diagonal it can
go to D5 at the right moment especially
if you bring this Rook to G8 thank you
very much Bishop D5 and I would love to
get my queen with that bishop and the
light scores if that happens the black
king is in a world of danger so I'm
looking at this position night before
very tempting but Rook takes before an
excellent reply it would see him so what
other move candidates do we have F4
we've eliminated it's bad because of
Bishop G4 Knight to B4 is interesting
even with this exchange sacrifice are
there any other ideas here maybe the
simple straightforward A6 just to kick
this work out is that also a viable
option
all right let's take a look A6 the first
thing that we have to check is what
happens after Bishop D5
right because the queen and the Knight
are now in trouble but I think the queen
can slide safely to the G6 Square
keeping an eye on this Knight and when
this Rook moves maybe then I might be
four ideas I was hoping you would fall
for my trick Robert of Queen E5 get
greedy with E5 and then suddenly after
trading on E5 I had a nice little check
on E6 Bishop E6 winning your knight
yeah I mean then I actually I guess
technically can go back but then you
just lose I go Rook at five and I'm
super happy with my position yeah you're
just not you see the eval bar Sky High
so that actually it's funny because
after Queen E5 it looks like Bishop
takes C6 would be the right move but as
you see it's a mistake because the queen
is unprotected under attack but we
simply swap queens and then you lose
your Rook on B5 so this would be an
error although even this looks
interesting like If This Were A Blitz
game I'd be like oh white might be able
to win with a Checkmate on Aid or
something like that but of course it's
insufficient compensation for the Lost
material so we have so many interesting
ideas in this position and we have two
of the most creative players on the
planet where only at move 17 they need
to reach move 40 to get to the next time
Patrol and it's going to remain really
complicated this one is not a position
that's going to be clear unless someone
makes a mistake and the other player
gets a huge Advantage so uh nerdy back
somebody walked right in front of the
camera because of course chess players
or an Arbiters never know where the
cameras are uh but either way nerdy Beck
he is at his table he is really focusing
on this position because I like the look
of A6 that Bishop D5 isn't so scary are
they kicking this Rook away makes a lot
of sense you're not actually weakening
your King's position by playing the move
A6 there's not an open a file or
anything like that to attack with so A6
just says get out of here a scram and
then maybe night before is an option in
the future uh and the E5 Pawn becomes a
Target
I love it after A6 we were pointing out
Bishop D5 and you immediately set the
move Queen 6 not falling for any tricks
there and then as you mentioned once The
Rook falls back Knight before comes in
with in fact a Tempo hitting the bishop
on D5 so everything would sort of fall
into place A6 looks like a nice approach
but again as we were mentioning this is
such a critical moment there are so many
tempting options uh that black has got
here lacks thinking about that not a
back needs to take his time uh and
that's what he's doing I won't be
surprised if we actually do end up
seeing move A6 it looks like such a
human way to handle this position
right because white has like this one
big idea with Bishop D5 so let's get
that Rook out of there as quickly as
possible but it's not the end of the
story if the queen is kicked over to
Duke to G6 then the E5 become Pawn
becomes a bit safer right the Queen the
night were teaming up but if the queen
has to run away then maybe uh that is
something that white would like to see
but I just the King on D1 since move 11
has been scary it remains a problem in
White's position so we'll see how this
one develops I think as nordibeck thinks
we should head back to the bird's eye
view to get looking at all of the games
because the first thing I notice is in
the top left Magnus Carlson's Rook has
landed on D7 and levonne runs King is on
H7 so things are getting a little bit
dicey for Lavon I mean his King will not
be very safe and I'm also looking at the
bottom right because Vincent kymer's
Advantage seems to be growing Tanya you
liked his position very early on and I
think he's proving you correct with his
series of moves
yeah this is Grace Great Piece activity
that he's got and those pawns on on D4
and E5 just make things so difficult uh
for white hair but that said at least
it's still equal material I still liked
those ideas where uh Winston could have
in fact won the pawn and taken it slower
but he does dominate the position even
now still has to prove the advantage
Bishop D2 on the board uh hitting that
Rook on C3 which I really don't want to
move out of there it's just such a
pretty spot and is E4 completely crazy
here Robert
well if it's crazy then visit kymer
likes crazy because he played the movie
E4 just now and the point is that the
queen is on F3 loose so if you take out
E4 with the pawn which is what you'd
want to do then you'd lose your queen if
you take with the Rook after Knight
takes E4 Bishop takes E3 the Knight can
capture back black ends up a piece of
head with a winning position so that
means that the move in the game queen of
D1 is the best move and it's interesting
because Rook takes D3 simply looks like
a free Pawn but then there's Knight C5
with a clever fork and that's not the
end of the story just because you're
giving away a rook for a knight doesn't
mean that you've made a mistake black
can actually claim first one pawn and
maybe even a second Pawn with Rook takes
A3 and now you have two pawns and very
impressive pawns I might add for uh The
Exchange so it white has an extra Rook
black has a knight and these two
impressive Pawns
really nice line and I think this could
be pretty much where we are headed
because once the upon or the queen falls
back on D1 after E4 you kind of have to
make a decision you can't back out
anymore you have to go for this line
because if you fall back with the Rook
then that kind of just takes away all
your advantage white can simply
recapture on e4 and White's probably
doing absolutely fine in this position
so definitely a big moment here
um and the Vincent all of 18 this is
also his first Tata steel Masters so a
big event and I think he would be happy
with the stock that he's got uh with the
with the black pieces in 2020 he did
play the challenges where he finished
with 7 out of 13 but Vincent has also
had a phenomenal last year which he
ended with a silver medal in Kazakhstan
at the world rapid Championship he's at
26.96 so he's definitely looking at
crossing the 2700 Mark in this event
I feel like he's one of these young
players where it's hard to call them
underrated when there's 2700 but he is a
student he is you know still in school
and I know that I've seen him at
previous tournaments where he tells me
that he's had exams right he's like oh
how are you going to celebrate your good
tournament oh well actually I have to go
take my exams after this so he is
multitasking very impressively because
he's at 2700 and uh you know he's just
finished his schooling I think so I
think going forward we'll see more and
more excellent chess from Vincent kymer
because he
left into the scene at a young age when
he won the grandkei open ahead of I
don't even remember how many Grand
Masters 50 or 100 Grand Masters and he
was just this teenager who wins the
event with a really impressive score
earning his place in the Dortmund
tournament so Vincent kymer is a name
that's been on the radar for a while and
it's one that is going to stay
especially after his silver medal in the
world's rapid Championship but the metal
is a thing of the past even though it's
a recent past he needs to make a very
important decision right now does he
drop his work back to C6 he likely will
still have a slight advantage and some
pressure against the white king or does
he say I'm going to take on D3 give up
the exchange for a couple pawns and
think that with the material imbalance
there's a good chance so it's a big
question for him right now Tanya
and it's all about the approach and your
style of play that will decide the
decision here I think if you want to uh
if you're a more if you're if you're the
kind of player who's playing more for
the initiative you would sacrifice The
Exchange and Winston decides to do it
but in a completely different way from
what we were expecting Robert he does
capture on D3 but not with the Rook with
the pawn giving up that Rook on C3 uh
and I'm not sure about this and the
reason for that is that white has the
option to actually put in Rook takes E6
as well after Rook takes E6 F takes E6
the E6 Pawn could also be a potential
weakness
but I think that param has a trick up
his sleeve here because Bishop takes C3
Pawn takes E3 this looks terrible for
white and we see the evaluation bar
sinking because look at these impressive
passports he doesn't need two pawns for
the exchange he's like one is good
enough because I'm already threatening
to fork and win material or to push upon
a D2 and then all of White's pieces are
stuck in place I think param's big idea
is actually a sacrifice Knight D4
take on C3 now we have two minor pieces
for this Rook on B1 but after Rook B3
you get rid of Black's maybe best piece
this Pawn on D3 and so perhaps the claim
is that once D3 is captured it's a rook
in one Pawn or two minor PS that's equal
in terms of material value but more
importantly there aren't that many
pieces remaining so White's King feels
safer uh if a queen star traded then
white is in no trouble whatsoever so
this might be what param is aiming for
and this would be a pretty miraculous
save for him
I mean this position could be the best
position that white has gotten all game
and we do see some trades uh we are
probably heading there after he takes D3
very possible that Vincent missed this
idea of Knight D4 that you're pointing
out I see that the Rook on E6 has been
traded as you're saying that if white
takes on C3 black is just clearly better
with this D3 and the C3 pawns C2 coming
in you don't want to fight these pawns
Knight D4 immediately played by Parham
Queen takes D4 is the only way to play
because E6 as we were mentioning is a
weakness you don't have time to make a
move like Rook A3 with Knight E6 in the
air and Robert I'm just wondering has
Vincent blown away his advantage
why the look on his face I think he
overlooked Knight takes D4 and he is not
very happy but the good news for him is
even if he's given away his Advantage
he's not really in trouble right he uh
can make a draw at any moment a half
point with the black pieces in the first
game against a strong opponent like par
Mexico is a good result but what often
happens to chess players is even if they
win the game if they let their opponent
back in it for a moment or if they
didn't play as precisely as possible
that's really what uh kind of stews on
their mind so I think that Vincent he
looks unhappy with what's transpired and
he is still in the driver's seat if
anyone's going to win this game it's him
but it doesn't look very likely anymore
and that's probably what's bothering him
it went from Clear advantage to
liquidation and likely uh a draw is
going to happen so we'll take it away
from Vincent I mean those series of
Trades that we were just talking about
will probably happen but why don't we
you know take a peek as well at the
bird's eye view and in particular we
will get to this game between five and a
car one on each gear top right that's
where we're gonna kind of look at next
we're gonna zoom in on that game but as
I look at the other games quickly
um Tanya it looks like Wesley so second
from the left from the bottom he did
play E4 and his Bishop is on H1 so he
went for that variation
is that how E4 did not
Nazis my Bishop is fine on H1 because if
you do pursue it with King to G1 he
wants to play the move E3 I think
wow yeah so you want to push that pass
on and maybe cause some problems so an
interesting choice from Wesley so but
not many pieces remaining so we'll come
back to that game as the players uh
we'll continue thinking I think we
should dive right into the game between
Fabiano caruana I'm really sorry but
that's just this crazy line that came to
my mind I don't even know if it works
but let's take a look at the Wesley on
the Wesley board okay G1
okay bringing that up right now so
if King D1 yep
and E3 so you can't take on H1 because e
takes D2 just wins for y for black uh
Fork queening all kinds of threats let's
say you go Knight C4
and I'm not sure if this works but the
point is that now if I move my Bishop
you're attacking the E3 pawn and I might
be going completely crazy but maybe E2
is possible here
aha so if King takes H1 your point is
Rook D1 wins on the spot because now the
Rooks are staring at each other and you
can't protect it if you move your Rook
you lose your bishop and then black Gets
A queen just to show that rookie one
check King Rook G1 check thank you very
much I replace my Rook with the pawn and
get a queen so so E3 and E2 so what is
White's move in response maybe it's Rook
seat oh my gosh the geometry of this
game is nuts because after Bishop F3
there's Knight E5 with a fork and if you
play Rook D1 I get a take on F3 and
protect my bishop and then white would
suddenly win
oh my God
this is amazing stuff but I saw that
after Knight E5 the game still continues
because the eval bar seemed to say that
black is fine so what's the move how am
I fighting Knight E5 maybe wait but
Bishop before this Rook takes E2 so this
is
this is crazy stuff I I think it's like
barely holding on where Black's pieces
look loose but you're just able to get
your rook and Bishop defending uh uh
defended and everything is okay but this
is not what Wesley wanted he was up a
pawn he doesn't want to give away his
pawn and then have to make a draw by
defending for a couple turns so what is
the plan after King G1 because E3 as we
were just looking at it looks like a
very forcing line he could put Bishop D5
and go for the A2 Pawn to give up E3 for
a two and still be up a pawn but I think
that's much easier for white to hold is
you know being down upon the queen side
he's gone King E2 so he decides not to
follow through with King G1 perhaps did
not like giving up the A2 pawn and
Jordan decides instead to keep his King
in the center not pursue the black
Bishop on H1 goes King E2 because black
still has problems getting this bishop
out you know you don't have the move E3
uh I do have the ideas of coming in now
with my Bishop to F2 Knight is jumping
on to C4 and Black's got some
coordination issues here so King E2 but
the eval bar doesn't approve of this
move
and I wonder why and I I guess
if you play H6 and Bishop F2 something
like this I'm wondering if black remains
better because I can drag your Rook
to a bad square and only after dragging
to a bad Square do I give up this Pawn
because if you take a bishop G4 check
and your king is actually almost
checkmated here like if you're King E1
there's Checkmate on the spot with Rook
2 D1 so I feel like that's why Wesley is
better if Jordan just makes all his
turns to win that pawn back his pieces
are an awkward squares
um well that's the beauty of Chess right
even with such few pieces there's so
many complexities in the position and
tactics hidden tactics that are there
we'll come back to this Robert and see
how uh Wesley proceeds does he manage to
actually take the point home he is upon
up but long way to go uh let's get an
overview of some of the other boards and
I see a lot of developments on the
Magnus board as well
yeah Magnus his Rook on D7 and Levon
went Rook A5 so we'll definitely tune
into that one in a second but first
let's go to the game between Fabiano
caruana and Anish Gary in the top right
and yes mittens would win this
tournament it seems like that is the
case now that Megan's is behind mittens
but at the moment I mean all gloves are
off in this game because we see a
position where Fabi has put his Knight
on B3 but look at this bishop on E2 it's
kind of the worst piece on the board so
black has this activity staring towards
this bishop and at some point black
could even decide to strike with some
pawns so Tanya I I know we liked the
move A4 when it happened uh I'll move
what move was that a long time I move
eight now that we're on move 21 it feels
like white is actually just kind of
passive here
and that's because your knight hasn't
managed to establish itself on that
beautiful Seafood square that we loved
so much after the move A4 and B4 was
provoked meanwhile black has got a very
active Bishop on A6 let's just compare
the pieces the bishop on A6 is way
better than the bishop on E2 you've got
these two Bishops uh White is still
struggling with that Queen on B1 where
is that headed the only Trump in White's
position is that the D4 Pawn hangs right
now but it's easily defendable uh right
now what Anish needs to decide is do you
want to play the move E5 and commit to
E5
I kind of don't see a problem with it I
would go E5 and defend the spawn and
play on
I think the one downside of playing E5
is you've given me an idea for my Bishop
right we're talking about how the bishop
is uh on a really passive square but as
soon as you play E5 I want to put my
Bishop on G4 just to pin your knight so
I would think we'll play Knight D2 and
Bishop G4 not the end of the world it's
not like black is losing or anything
like that but suddenly I have some
freedom for my piece and that looks very
uh good relatively speaking for white so
how else do you defend D4 I mean Bishop
F6 doesn't really look Pleasant
I feel like Knight C5 giving up D4 for
A4 is like a third option
that's a nice idea because if you get
the A4 Pawn then your queen side pawns
can be super dangerous they're already
so Advanced off the board so let's say
Knight C5 you capture on D4 black
captures on A4 and then suddenly
everything makes sense because D3 is
also still a weakness and this Knight
moves back the a Pawn's advancing I'm
kind of liking Black's position a lot
I am as well and I think that Anish
Geary should be very pleased with how
this game has gone because just quickly
show you you know back here when A4
happened and then the Knight retreated
we were talking about the light squares
would be good for white and things of
that nature the position remains
balanced and each just handled it very
well he pushed his pawns he castled his
King and at the right moment he pushes
Pawn to A5 before white could do the
same and that allowed his Bishop some
freedom on the diagonal so I really
believe that you know both players have
been jockeying for position but the way
Anish is handled it has been perfect and
he has a pretty good record in the
recent past he went Knight D4 here by
the way voluntarily to close the attack
against the C5 pawn and just hit the
queen on C2 and just to finish my
thought um Tanya he's done well against
fiber with the black pieces in recent
years he beat him last year in Vikings
they with black in the Candace
tournament in 2021 he beat him with
black in one of the final rounds so a
niche actually has proof proven quite
Mighty a tough opponent for Fabi even
with the black pieces
and this is quite the dream position
with the black pieces with Knight C5
coming in and I'm just wondering that
after Knight C5 perhaps Fabi just has to
acknowledge that his position has gone
all wrong and try and keep things
together trade-offs those Knights on C5
let's say Knight C5 I go Knight takes C5
you recapture with the bishop defending
that default pawn and maybe now it's
time to bring in my other Knight to C4
so ideas like Knight E5 threatening a
fork on D7 or the way that you're
describing it with Knight D2 but 95 just
feels a bit more active and then
eventually put that Knight on C4 and say
sure I'm not doing fine but where are
you breaking in from and maybe white
just holds them
yeah it actually is a really good
variation to show because if you take on
C4 then we just make a draw opposite
color Bishops I think it's very clear
that unless one side can control the C
file the game will just be a draw so
just to show some of that Rook C7 Knight
C4s like this Rook C8 and uh what's
gonna happen is all the Rooks are going
to be traded off and there's no weakness
in the position nothing to attack this
game would definitely head towards a
draw so uh after this Knight E5 move
that's the big question is how do we
deal with this we could try to remove
Our Queen what we really want is Bishop
B8 Queen D6 like some kind of attack uh
going for checkmate it's really hard to
make that work uh but maybe Queen C7
actually because if Knight C4 I do have
Bishop A7 and I was just talking about
it I don't know why not create a one
move threat
yeah why not I mean I was thinking wait
a second my Rook is on T1 your queen is
on C7 do I not have a great night jump
and turns out I do not have a great
night jump
yeah I'm just trying to provoke a
weakness here or there especially
because it's Queens on B1 so I can
attack on the king side White's pieces
are a little bit far from the action I
know I'm asking for a lot here it's uh
sort of just hope chest to some extent
but there are some ideas in this
position for black to go uh towards the
king side where white doesn't have many
pieces so I think that Anish remains
better but Fabiano remains pretty solid
in his position he does have some things
to work out but we'll let him do that
because we're going to want to be here
for the time pressure so uh you know we
are going to hop to a break right now uh
the players they remain in the playing
Hall there and Vikings they uh they're
fully focused all of the amateur
sections also in full swing so as the
players they do the heavy lifting the
hard work Tony and I are gonna stretch
our legs get a glass of water and be
right back for more from the Tata steel
chess tournament 2023.
dude it's impossible to not hear you
just breathing super loudly okay fine I
will hold my breath for three minutes
all right let's go okay let's go right
now let's just clock up right here
almost there and you did it
what can you do for three minutes my
wife says not a lot but I can plank keep
that big butt down dude nice
two one you did it wow I feel better oh
yeah oh you were timing me yeah you were
in there for 30. oh man let's play some
chess and get some dinner let's do it
time lines yeah okay you bring a clock
oh I left my clock at home dude you
idiot I told you to bring it let's just
go get somebody okay
oh
download the new chess.com clock app so
you can time yourself playing chess or
whatever other dumb stuff you and your
friends do
one of the all the top players right now
world number two for a very very long
period of time currently dipped a little
below what is making us come back in
Vikings a 40 year old a player
tremendous achievements and uh he'll be
happy to be back so I can say he's won
the tournament before he'll try to do it
again Richard Rapport has no name he's
been to vacancy before one of the more
creative players has recently also
gained a lot in the rankings he is
always known for his very unusual style
playing very unusual and interesting
opening ideas and a very creative player
but also really really strong and very
high rated at the moment so looking
forward to see the short report back
invitancy Wesley saw is a known name top
there from the United States it's been
to I can say many times one of the
fixtures of the top chess just had a
great result in the chase.com Global
Championship which was a massive event
and he is definitely looking forward to
another by Kansas Edition
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
and we return to the action in Vikings a
this is the 85th edition of the Tata
steel chess tournament it is held in
Vikings the Netherlands and right now
the action has been in full swing for a
while and it's heating up and I think
the game in particular that has most
people's attention surprise surprise is
that of the game between Magnus Carlson
the reigning world champion in all
disciplines uh well I guess fish are
random he did not win a car Nakamura has
that title but in classical rapid and
Blitz but he's taking on Lavon aronia we
have that board in the top left and
something has just happened the E5 Pawn
Tanya is gone and Magnus doesn't look
too pleased about what's happening he's
looking like he's ready to pounce but I
think he's more so a little bit annoyed
about what just happened because he
dropped the pawn the center and I feel
like lavon's getting away with it
yeah and I'm just wondering how that
even happened I mean we thought that
Magnus has full control of this game and
he's gonna be the one who will be
pushing but remember Robert we did
mention that Levon also has his trumps
in the position the a file uh the
control with the queen coming on to B6 I
love this move by the way if I left
because the queen on B6 does not only
hit the B2 Pawn but it takes away this
really important Square the White Queen
has on D4 where magnus's Queen would
have really centralized itself from D4
or C5 so Queen B6 a multi-purpose move
and black can now start looking at Rook
lifts Rook A5 hitting that pawn on E5
and suddenly the two the double pawns uh
looks like a big weakness how do you
defend this you can't go Queen D6
because the queen on D2 in fact is
overburdened you've got to also defend
the B2 pawn and suddenly uh Magnus finds
himself in a spot where it's so hard to
defend the pawns let's say you go back
Queen C3 instead in that position and
then Rook jumps away to B5 and you end
up losing the B2 Pawn
yeah your problems left and right here
uh weak pawns that are being attacked
and if we just return to what happened
in the game B4 was played so Magnus
voluntarily gave up the pawn and on
Queen D6 this Rook is almost trapped it
can't go to D5 because the bishop is
here but Lavon cools a cucumber plays
Queen to B5 now there are several things
to note the only defender of this Rook
is this queen so Rook takes B7 does
distract the queen but this is not at
all what Magnus would want because now
we're liquidating we're getting into
position with queen and Bishop and Five
Pawns each and after Queen takes B4
Bishop takes H5 even a queen E4 check
immediately forcing the Queens off the
board and even if just Bishop takes a
king Jade black is not worse is just an
equal position so that's would be good
news for Lavon and I think what was
looked at was Rook d8 queen f8 queen h8
would be Checkmate but there's a big
problem here that black person with
Bishop E4 and this King will actually be
safe on the G6 square and Tanya black
would be up a pawn in the starting
position before would be weak E2 would
be weak and you see the evil bar
creeping in Black's favor and the move
queen of Fate was just played by Madness
so he's changed the move order so Rook
date could happen next and if the bishop
moves F7 would fall so very interesting
moment right now that's really smart
because you keep an eye out on F7 and
take a look at how Levon respond so he
has to fight against the mating idea of
Rook d8 he sacrifices what Rook takes E2
the point is that now if you go Rook d8
black has the option the opportunity to
move that Bishop from G6 Bishop to E4
comes in you vacate the G6 Square for
the king queen h8 is just a check well
actually it's not yeah it's just a check
because King G6 and guess what the queen
on B5 playing a brilliant role of
defending the H5 Pawn otherwise that
would have been checked made after Queen
H5 Queen G5 but it's not possible
anymore rookie 2 is a stunning move by
Lev and the point is that if you take
Bishop E2 Queen E2 and black can never
be worse than that position
no not at all Bishop E2 Queen takes E2
you have checks on e4 it might just need
a Checkmate if you think that you're
checkmating black no black checkmates
you because no matter where the King
goes I just keep giving it checks until
my queen gets the G2 with Checkmate here
this would even be even worse or even
faster I should say queen H1 is made so
yeah this is an easy finish for black so
instead we saw Bishop E4 takes in Queen
takes F7 we should point out once more
the queen does defend the pawn on H5 so
Queen takes H5 would be Checkmate if not
for the queen on B5 and that's what the
best players do multi-purpose moves that
Queen B5 move it attacked the pawn on B4
and protect the rook in E5 but defended
the pawn on H5 and all of these
sequences and now rookie one would
threatened with threaten a Checkmate I
think there's going to be a draw so King
G6 Queen E8 queen h8 queen E8 and so on
this is how the game is going to end in
the next few turns Queen V5 was an
absolute star move I mean it's such a
multi-purpose uh Queen there not only
playing a Defender but also an attacker
you were pointing out the move rookie
one and I love it because it kind of
forces magnus's hand in the position not
giving white time to make a move like
Rook F7 or Rook G8 attacking the G7 Pawn
you go rookie one Queen F1 Black's the
one who's threatening all the checks and
it looks like Magnus will have to give a
Perpetual will have to repeat and this
one should be ending about now we see
him reaching out for the queen he's
seeing if there's anything that he can
do because of course Magnus felt like he
had an advantage but indeed he does go
for what you recommended Magnus he plays
Queen Jade Levon calmly moves the king
up the board King to G6 just not enough
pieces so why you've made Magnus Gibson
nugget and a Levon can simply fall back
to eight seven one more time because H5
is defended by that Queen on B5 he could
also go King it six either ways white
will give a check and this game will end
in draw in just a couple of moves now
it's a heroic defensive effort from
LeBron he made it look so easy I know
the eval bar never got away from him but
these are the types of games that Magnus
Carlsen wins all the time right he just
presses and squeezes and eventually you
just relent because it's hard to defend
for 30 moves but that's what's going to
annoy Magnus the most not the results of
the game but the fact that the game
didn't last longer that he didn't make
Levon suffer lavon's not suffering we're
about to reach move 40 it's going to be
a draw but the black pieces in game one
levona Ronin will make that draw and
with it his tournament is off to a great
start he is a four-time champion in
Vikings a Magnus Carlsen an eight-time
Champion but this is the perfect start
for Lavon and not the start that Magnus
wanted
and that's it handshakes uh the first
result of the first round Magnus Carlsen
ends with a draw against Levon
definitely levon's the one who's more
pleased with this outcome we see the two
players still on the board analyzing
some variation Levon felt the pressure
in the game but Robert I'm very proud of
the fact that I did point out that Lev
will find a way I believed in him I
believed in his resources and he managed
to make it look pretty simple
yeah no he really did because when Lev
takes over I mean you just gotta trust
him and he was able to stabilize his
position was worse and they're talking
the players do that analyze at the board
they just want to hear each other's
thoughts and they have tremendous amount
of respect for one another are these two
players They're laughing right there's
like okay I drew with the white pieces
against somebody I wanted to be but
that's not such a big deal and I I think
there is so much mutual respect between
these two players they have squared off
many times we showed that graphic
earlier and the players they remain
analyzing at the board here as the
Arbiter rips up the signed score sheets
these two players I mean they gave it
their all in game one but for Magnus it
didn't lead to a victory and for Levon
it led to the perfect result a draw with
black against the best player on the
planet so with a sigh of relief Lebron
leave his chair he's gonna have to get
ready for game two tomorrow
um and I saw Magnus there picking up the
Jeep on probably pointing out to those
plans that you were mentioning with G4
breaking open the H5 pawn and definitely
he felt that he had the pressure the
upper hand in this game but Levon a
really nice defensive idea and I have to
say it all starts from that move with
Rook A7 bringing on that uh Rook into
the game and all along the A5 was the
defense the a file was the defensive
resource for black a really nicely held
game there by Lev again a decent start
for both players but Lev is definitely
more relieved with this result you've
still got action on on our other boards
we certainly do so one draw in the books
and what is happening in the bottom left
between gookash and dingly red I see a
Pawn on G5 and suddenly a white Pawn on
G4 and then dig them plays F5 where his
Pawn's not even protected so he's giving
it up two different ways let's Dive
Right into that position I know in the
bottom right just quickly uh it is that
two minor pieces against a rook and pawn
scenario that we talked about so we'll
keep an eye there and we will take a
look at all of our games because the
report game is also looks interesting in
the center but let's go to the game
between gookesh and dingley ren because
the last move that we just saw was F7 to
F5 that pawn is not defended you can
take with the g-pawn you can take with
the queen but no matter what recaptures
here it looks like dingly Ren has
tactics available to him to go after
this black excuse me this white king
with the dark Square Bishop
and I think we have to take a look at
what are these tactics Robert because
it's not so clear at first what black
wants I think after G takes F5 it's
probably slightly easier to understand
what black wants and I'm just wondering
if it's G4 it definitely is G4 you're
cutting off the Bishop from the Knight
which means Bishop takes G4 as necessary
but what was that Bishop doing a very
important task covering the white king
Bishop B7 Queen C6 that looks like a
very quick Checkmate that's going to be
very difficult for white to deal with
especially because the F2 Pawn is pinned
that looks we just came over I actually
had another idea when I mentioned G4 I
was wondering if black would perhaps
have the time after Bishop takes G4 also
the option to go Queen G5 I pin your
bishop and the point is if you go H3 I
want to bring in my other Rook to E2 now
that your Bishop is pinned uh maybe this
works maybe it doesn't but it looks
really strong
yeah I'm surprised it's not minus eight
but it's minus 1.7 it appears on the
about bar there so still an advantage
for black you're just kind of spoiled
for Choice many uh good options and
dingler and has a lead on the clock this
is the territory that guest does not
want to find himself in so we eliminate
G takes F5 based on the very forcing
variation just to show Once More the
Knight needs a Defender the bishop is
under attack which means Bishop takes G4
is force and whether it's Bishop B7
Queen G5 something of that nature is
going to be a big problem for white to
deal with so instead I think it's likely
if it capture average queen takes F5 but
then we see several options Rook of Fate
comes to mind Bishop C8 with Tempo
against the queen and the pawn behind it
um I'm not fully seeing it if I'm honest
um Tanya like Rook f8 the queen can
escape to E4 I feel like the game
continues but obviously black has a lot
of activity
if you have to take the F5 Pawn it's
pretty clear that you have to take it
with the queen and I am actually not
even sure if you have an alternative to
Queen F5 uh because it's just simply so
difficult to keep the position as is
with f takes G4 in the air uh I'm anyway
threatening to blow open your King's
side so you've got to take a decision
and after Queen F5 the big question is
what you were mentioning Robert is Rook
f8 which is so tempting is that the way
that black wants to proceed after Rook
f8 Queen E4 yeah you're right it's hard
to kind of see a finishing uh a finish
there
yeah because the queen and Bishop defend
each other for now
um it doesn't look great I'll be honest
about that but if this Knight can get
back to G3 and F5 then we close down the
f file and we really have some good
chances to survive this game if you're
thinking about it from gookesh's
perspective so uh after F5 Queen takes
to five looks very logical another idea
that I'm just keeping in the back of my
mind and I think this is a very
important for people who uh you know
they fall victim to an attack and they
feel like they can never defend
themselves Rook takes D4 at the right
moment might be necessary because the
bishop on D4 is such a powerful piece
staring at f2 and hurting the white king
that Rook takes D4 it needs to be put
and stored in your back pocket for the
right moment and now that I say that
there could be a time and a place and it
could be after Rook f8 maybe there's
Rook takes D4 it's not completely out of
the question because if you take on F5
and I take on d8 all of a sudden I have
Lasker compensation of Rook Knight and
pond for the queen and the black king
isn't completely safe either so I feel
like this kind of scenario could present
itself
wow that is an amazing resource that
you're pointing out Robert I love the
idea of Rook D4 and especially in this
line Queen F5 which makes me think that
maybe Rook Cafe might not be the best
way to play after Queen F5 but the
moment you point out Rook D4 one also
thinks that maybe white can consider
doing it immediately in this position
just go Rook takes D4 Rook D4 and then
also take on F5 you still have so much
compensation with the bishop jumping
into F5 a bishop jumping into D5 my
knight F6 coming in with a fork on the
king and the Rook let's just show that
on the board let's say Rook D4 Rook D4
yeah
yeah
that's what I was trying to figure out
really quickly but either way your point
still stands take on F5 and if you're
saying Bishop D5 Knight F6 is a big
threat with a fork on the king and the
rook and if it's Rook slides to f8 this
sort of looks like a transposition the
problem is that I'm gonna get Queen E5
like this is just checking mate you have
to give up all your pieces the stop
Checkmate so that's not really what you
want you see the Eva bar goes Sky High
so
um that is not advisable and if that's
the case and black really needs to
figure this out because Bishop D5 is a
threat Knight F6 is a threat the E5
Square for my queen at some point will
be nice going against the dark squares
as well so I mean Rook takes D4 maybe in
the moment Pawn 64 is good just keeping
both of my Rooks on the last rank seems
to be at least a bit safer and after the
queen takes on F5 there is Maybe
I don't know what move D3 is possible
it's so difficult in these positions
because I do see the eval bar it loves
Black's position but the thing is from a
human perspective and practically on the
board when you don't know what the
evaluation is it just looks like a
complete mess like a game that you're
playing for three results
it does I mean I have to trust dingley
Wren because he volunteered this sort of
tactical sequence with F5 let's just go
back a half turn Knight G3 was just
played but before F5 I was going to say
that that's not forced at all there's so
many different moves that black can play
Queen G6 uh maybe King h8 just to stay
off these forking squares things like
that but he goes F5 and Knight G3 was
gookesh's choice in response and he
wants to get his Knight to F5 so I see
the Merit in this decision as well
it's a really interesting way to handle
the problems in the situation to reroute
your knight to F5 because once it lands
there you can see it creating trouble
for black as well now the first thing is
that what happens after black captures
on G4 because that just seems like such
a natural response you want to make
white skin more vulnerable open up the
position I would hate to go Bishop G4
here allowing the move Bishop B7 and the
queen C6 ideas that you were pointing
out it just looks like a complete
disaster if black is able to set up a
battery along the 8 H1 diagonal that's
game over for white which brings us to
the point that you were mentioning that
does white have the Intermezzo here
don't recapture on G4 but first jump in
with your knight on F5 hitting that
Queen on H6
mm-hmm and the queen has places to go
like Queen F6 uh but this still looks so
scary if this bishop gets the B7 I feel
like you know you're just in huge
trouble maybe also just a simple Bishop
C8 because so many pieces are hanging
your knight your Bishop the F2 Pawn all
right I'm not buying it I know Gucci is
an amazing player but with the clock
situation with the position I'm just so
worried that in a position like this I
mean how is he going to continue to
defend his King when all of Black's
pieces are about to join the action
we're going to find out Robert because F
takes G4 is on the board and now of
course dukesh has to think what he needs
to do I will be shocked if he goes for
Bishop G4 you don't want to give up
control of this diagonal you can't
afford to sacrifice the G4 Pawn but not
let go of this diagonal for example
after Knight F5 let's say you move out
with your queen to F6 hitting that
Knight as you were pointing out I would
rather put my Bishop on e4 than take on
G4 and allow you to go for Bishop B7
because after Bishop B7 I am getting
checkmated for sure
yeah that's a good point because you
know the bishop on B7 open diagonal but
Bishop on e4 protects the Knight and
takes away Bishop B7 at the same time
that's a really clever move I think you
know so many people myself included
would immediately just take back that
seems like the good choice but Bishop E4
does hold the position for now because
the attack hasn't stopped black is up a
pawn so even if the attack doesn't lead
a Checkmate and I just put my king on h8
you need to prove that you're gonna
survive down material when all is said
and done and I'm getting word that
gukesh is down around actually five
minutes there have been some issues uh
with the relay throughout the round of
you know some problems from the live
playing venue but he is down to around
five minutes at the moment so we'll keep
an eye on that that is bad news for
somebody who's King is wide open this
position is a nightmare if you've got
five minutes and what move are we on uh
Robert what move number are we on
we are moved 27 Blacklist 27th moves
Ponte G4
so that's still another 13 moves to be
made up with the white pieces and that
is no easy task in an already difficult
position five minutes on the clock is
what we are being updated with uh and
right now a big question to gukesh does
he does he keep the material balanced
take on G4 while he's made his decision
he does jump in with the Knight and uh
I'm expecting the move that you were
suggesting Queen F6 makes a lot of sense
uh perhaps yeah I think that's the
nicest move because if you go Queen G6
then Bishop E4 is even more attractive
targeting the queen uh so Queen F6 is
is the move that you want to make with
the black pieces and then big questions
to gkesh because you can't fall back
with the bishop to G2 rookie 2 comes in
and that is absolute disaster so not
only do you have to control the A8 H1
diagonal as white you have to keep the
F5 Knight defended and you have to stop
rookie too
wow so many things that need to be taken
care of and the time trouble does not
help but ding he's spending a bit of
time he wants to be precise so let's
take this moment to go to the bird's eye
view because a lot is happening
throughout our boards we can see in the
center Center board on the bottom there
it is report and Abdul sitarab and
things have gone from questionable to
just outright bad for the new Romanian
player the Hungarian player by birth now
plays for Romania but look at this
position Tanya I mean we have an end
game all of a sudden where it's Rook
bishop and six pawns per side and some
people may look at that end game and see
a past Pawn on E6 but what abusatara
sees and what I'm agreeing with is
that's not a past Pawn that's a Target
this King will quickly walk up the board
along with the Rook to go after it if
white spends time to defend it there's
going to be problems with Rook F1 and
maybe this Pawn H3 as well so I just
feel like Black's pawns are much
healthier uh Tanya and the last one
player is Bishop B2 I think C5 is very
straightforward reply and this Pawn E6 I
feel like is not going to be long for
the sport
and that's the problem and why to
position the concept
s can't keep both pawns defended if you
lose the H3 Pawn black will have two
connected passes on the king side that
would be a disaster you lose the E6 Pawn
that's a healthy Pawn H3 would still be
a weakness C5 is just such a good move
here even though you've got the dark
Squad bishop and you put your Bishop
behind those pawns but you've simply
blocked out all of White's Bishop's
activity uh you just defend the D4 Pawn
cut out the activity slowly bring in
your king to D6 your Rook to F6 as you
were pointing out and it's impossible
for white to keep the pawns together so
everything looks like it's worked out
for Naughty back he needs to show good
technique but it looks like it's not
going to be very hard for him it doesn't
look like very difficult technique in
this position
no and I'm taken back to that game
between dingley Ren with the black
pieces against Richard report and the
candidates where dingling won a very
nice ending so you know report now in
worse shape here these end games are not
similar but the point is that you know
you get a crazy game that ends up in an
end game that is bad for reporting
that's just not something you want to
deal with and I think the only chance
kind of you have here is after C5 you
need to try to break with C3 because
it's not even a bishop right now if it's
behind this Pawn chain it's just not
active and you need to play C3 and try
to get your Bishop out in the open
towards Black's pawns but the aftermath
is simple like what if I just take here
which does free this bishop frees the
scope of the bishop but I just feel like
this Pawn is the biggest problem and
this Pawn is also a Target so I do have
to watch out I admit for Bishop G7 but I
don't know I'm not super scared of it
because even if I allow it now that I
think about it your Bishop gets trapped
Rook G8 takes Rook G6 thank you very
much you Bishop's trap so it's not
actually a threat
but you're you're absolutely right
Robert that white needs to play C3 in
this position whatever chances are there
if you open up the bishop that's your
best shot and the C3 is what we're
expecting but currently nordeback's the
one who's still having a think after
Bishop B2 and I'm just wondering what is
the alternative that he's thinking about
the other move that comes to mind is
Rook to F4 not committing that pawn to
C4 and you still defend the pawn on D4
right in this Rook can actually go to H4
and then you can try to play G4 so you
may think Rook F4 is met by Bishop C1
but Rook to H4 looks very strong not to
mentioned Rook F1 check actually just
wins on the spot so Rook F4 looks
extremely promising now that it's been
mentioned and I'm behind it
um Rook F4 looks excellent I guess white
desperately needs to get active somehow
but a rook trade doesn't look like it
solves the issue especially because this
Rook can always come around and win this
Pawn not Tanya this looks really really
bad for reporting he doesn't have much
time left he's probably a bit dejected
and look at noteier back on the other
side of things he is staring at this
position he knows that a win is just
within his reach so he does not want to
let this avenge slip yeah that is some
intense focused step by nodded back with
his twirling of the rope that we saw
earlier I think that's very classic and
typical of him I remember that from the
Olympiad in Chennai as well a classic
not a back pull was just completely
focused and twirling a piece around his
fingers he knows that he's very close to
taking a big point back that would be a
dream start to the Tata steel masters
with the white pieces for the 18 year
old uh Prodigy from Uzbekistan who had
his breakout moment at the Olympiad what
a performance that was in fact he's got
his compatriot cindero who is currently
playing in vikanze in the challenges I
think Cinderella was the second board or
maybe the third board uh chat can
correct me at the Olympiad currently not
back at 18 a rating of 27-13 he's
looking at getting those points and it
looks like he's going to have well the
best possible start here with this end
game and such incredible player not just
where this is headed but the way he
handled the opening the way he took care
of the difficulties that white posed in
the Vienna it's been a fantastic game by
notabeck it really has and he is a
former which is fun to say when you're
so young a former anything but he's a
former World rapid Champion so he has
some of the biggest accomplishments to
his name you know an Olympiad gold medal
for team Uzbekistan a world rapid
championship and he is just getting
started and it looks like with the black
pieces he's really good winning chances
uh we'll see if he's able to take this
one home but since he's thinking let's
go back to the bird's eye view we still
have six games going on in this very
first round at the 85th edition of vikon
Zay Tata steel tournament So speaking of
so Wesley so is now up a pawn still but
in an end game so I feel like his
winning chances have actually decreased
because the Rooks are off the board
that's the second game from the left in
the bottom row uh that game will go on
for a long time so let's table it for
now in the top right Anish Geary whoa we
definitely have to go to that game
because all of a sudden Denise Geary
looks like he's down a piece he's
sacrificed a knight for a couple past
pawns over here so I think we have to
tune right into that one as it is a
material imbalance let's go back in time
to see how we got there because Tonya we
talked about this moment Knight C5 that
was the move that was played a capture
happened on D4 with the F3 Knight Queen
went to A2 saying hey if your knight
backs up give me your A5 Pawn thank you
very much and Knight takes B2 was played
by Gary giving up a piece he has a pawn
for that piece and then Bishop F6
there's a pin on this Knight the thread
is A4 to remove the guard and we see a
swap of Rooks by Fabiano here and Anish
has not responded he's not captured back
yet but what is the plan for black after
Rook takes C8 let's say I should say
what's the plan for white there's this
nasty looking pin with A4 being the big
threat not just A4 I mean you can fight
against A4 with a move like Rook A1 but
then how are you replying to Rook d8 you
mentioned the nasty looking fan I
continue to put pressure on it and it
looks like things could get a lot worse
for white uh I mean that's quite a quite
a Sacrifice by Anish and uh you know for
all the haters who say that he takes the
safety first approach and he would never
go for any sacrifices I mean this is a
niche and uh he is he's just such a
strong player but very often because of
his results we tend to forget about how
combative of a player he can be
yes I mean he has finished second place
in his variant five times and some will
say oh well he's never won it but
finishing second place five different
times that shows that he feels right at
home in the Netherlands his home country
and he performs Super well in this event
at five minute carwana with his fresh
haircut right now you know we see that
we're not New Year's year used to seeing
him with lots of hair on his head he
clearly got a haircut right before this
trying uh to you know get ready for this
event but I I think that you know he's
gonna have to have his head in his hands
if he's not careful because a niche is
putting all this pressure on him so I I
do think we need to analyze this moment
as a niche is considering do I take on
state with the bishop or with the Rook I
think it's actually quite clear you
should take with the Rook on see it uh
for several reasons so if we can uh
analyze the position a little bit
Bishop C8 Rook A1 Rook d8 the same idea
that you were mentioning putting
pressure on this Knight I think that
white just simply sidesteps it because
if you take on D4 here and white just
takes back and you take with either the
queen or The Rook I'm going to get your
A5 pawn and once I get your A5 Pawn
especially with your Bishop placed on C8
I feel like that white can't be worse
and we see uh based on the eval bar here
the white is definitely not worse I mean
you're just simply let's say we take
this way if you trade Queens you're just
worse because rookie threatens to pin
and win a piece Rook B5 behind this pawn
and we actually have the healthier Pawn
structure with the white king quickly
jetting towards the E3 Square so Anish
does have to be careful there it was a
definitely adventurous and cool
sacrifice and as we see he did just take
back uh with the Rook on C8 so it makes
the right choice but this A5 Pawn maybe
that will be won by Fabiano and is just
a a balance is restored
this entire line that you just pointed
out makes a lot of sense to take on C8
with the Rook because at least the
bishop on A6 is a lot more active than
on C8 and you're still putting pressure
on D3 so let's say after Rook takes C8
you jump back Rook A1 and let's try and
play through the same idea because I
don't see how you're going to fight uh
to defend your piece you have to give up
your piece but in the process you have
to make sure that you win the A5 pawn
and now suddenly I don't think Queen A2
is something to really worry about
because you pick up the D4 Knight and
that Bishop on A6 will eventually uh put
a lot of pressure on D3 let's say queen
D4 and after Queen A5 can I pick up
Bishop D3 immediately or is Rook D1
something I need to watch out for
I guess Rook D1 uh just happens to work
out here it looks very close especially
with this past Pawn but the PIN seems to
win material and that's an issue uh for
uh black so
I guess after Queen A5 maybe you
well Bishop B7 doesn't look appealing
that looks not good at all Rook B1 and
you lose the pawn so maybe there's
Rook Z6 and a rook B1 okay this is
getting like really clever that you
defend your outside pass Pawn in this
manner and all your pieces protect each
other the bishop 182 is worse uh so it's
really touch and go at this point Tony
like you have to be so precise it just
works out for a niche
but Rook D6 Rook B6 is so difficult to
understand and to make on the board
Robert I mean you know you to know that
all you have to do is keep the B4 Pawn
alive your Bishop on A6 is better than
your opponent's Bishop on E2 and you
keep all your trumps Rook C8 I don't has
do we have a move after Rook see it he
has recaptured with the rook and now
this is the live position so black with
big threats of A4 and Rook d8 Fabi
definitely in big trouble do we have an
update on the clock
uh being told that fabi's clock is
around oops sorry I'm flipping the board
I'm trying to refresh it around uh six
minutes and Anish is about uh 15. so the
clock is uh wrong There's issues with
the internet coming from the site in
Vikings a hopefully that gets rectified
but let's go back to the bird's eye view
for now uh we will keep an eye on these
players so um we will look at all the
remaining games because one game has
just concluded it was Vincent Connor
with the draw against
it maybe a little bit disappointed
because the game is going so well for
him uh but the result itself Tonya
that's a very good showing with black in
round one against a very strong opponent
and he was the one who was dominating
the entire game I mean he's the one who
created his chances with the black
pieces in the benoni setup so really
Drew on his own terms and you're
absolutely right that's a good result in
round one and parham's the one who's
relieved with that result after being in
pressure but we've got a lot of clock
action and board action on so where
should we jump to Robert which is the
position because I see that there's been
a lot of developments in the gkesh game
as well
yes there happened I mean so many
developments across the uh boards here
so we see in the top rights what we're
looking at the game between Anish and
Fabi are still going on there in the
prognanda game against Arjun it looks
like many pieces have been traded the
evil bar still hovering towards the
center uh in the middle in the bottom
row there it looks like the end game
remains great for abusot he's excellent
winning chances and then right next to
that on the left side there Wesley so
against Jordan red Forest it's a pawn up
for Wesley he's gonna try to win that
game will go on for a long time so
should we I mean has ding Loren not
moved it seems a bit surprising but he
was ahead on the clock so maybe ding is
just trying to figure out how to be as
accurate as possible
he's trying to figure out what is the
best Square for the queen and this is
the position that we were looking at so
white has just gone Knight F5 hitting
the queen on 86 and of course there are
some tempting options on the board right
now you want to go Queen F6 you also
have the option to go Queen E6 might be
considering Queen H3 as well Robert
wow Queen H3 I mean why not protect
Bishop G2 maybe yeah I guess that's uh I
fell for that
you know I was gonna be here to uh
support you but you pointed out Queen X3
Bishop G2 uh that Queen not really going
anywhere but there actually might be
some funny tactics here is Bishop D3
available
wow what is that move my queen is
hanging and now my Bishop's hanging as
well what is Bishop D3 you've got to
break that down for us Robert well if
you take the queen on H3 I take the
queen on C2 you take my Bishop I take
your Bishop that seems like a fair trade
but black was up a pound to start so
that's good news if you take the bishop
which looks free here then I could take
on D3 and the point is that once the
queen takes back Bishop takes F2 is
check the Rook opens up the discovery
against the queen and much like Parham
maksudlu against Vincent kymer we get
its material imbalance of two minor
pieces versus a rook in this case black
has two pawns uh and a rook for the
minor pieces but it's enough for white
to feel confident to be able to survive
this game it's a very wild sequence I
just don't think that Ding is going to
bring his Queen up to H3 even though it
looks fun I think Queen F6 feels very
very logical and the other move besides
as many Queen E6 to stop your Bishop E4
I like Queen F6 it just makes so much
more sense it's such a human move to
make you don't want to put your queen in
front of the Rook you always want to
threaten Rook to eat too why would you
not threaten that why put Queen E6 uh
Queen H3 you would just reject after
seeing Bishop G2 why even go into the
calculation I'm expecting ding to
eventually play the move Queen F6 and
then a very tough ball in gokish court
where what does he do with the bishop on
F3 it was hard enough for us to find an
answer to that but currently ding in a
very long thing
yeah he's trying to be perfect but
sometimes perfect is the enemy of the
good because you get yourself in time
trouble your advantage in the clock
starts slipping away and with gukesh
down to you know five plus minutes
that's not a lot of time when the King
on G1 is so exposed and maybe there's a
knockout maybe ding is saying all right
I'm gonna find this series of moves that
just ends all hope so it doesn't matter
if I have 25 minutes or if I have five
minutes remaining I'm gonna win this
game but I just feel like people get
nervous and we saw that from dingley run
Independence against Timor of a job of
around move 40 he let a huge Advantage
slip and then it was immediately a draw
so ding he needs to keep his composure
his momentum he's rocking in his chair a
little bit as we see on screen but he is
in the driver's seat he has great
chances to win game one with black and
what a victory that would be over the
rising star in gukesh but he needs to
make a move the more time that he's
taking the more one feels that is he
really uh feeling the position and you
know you kind of end up making a mistake
if you think too long I'm forgetting the
name but a great player once said that
you know a longer than a 10 minute think
and you're already on the wrong path so
he needs to kind of really take a call
here put the pressure on gakesh kukesh
is using the time to also find his
resources so he gets that additional
time I know Robert when I'm playing and
I'm under pressure and I'm trying to
find resources the more my opponent
thinks the more confident I get because
I do feel that one he's probably not for
he or she is not finding the right path
and uh two it gives me more time to
calculate my own variations so yeah
Queen F6 uh thing needs to make a move
is it gonna make Queen F6 or queen E6
whichever he decides but he needs to
play fast
and it's not every day that chess
players have such a large audience
watching them from the scene I mean in
Chennai the Olympiad there were many
fans coming to The Venue every single
day trying to take in the action and
right now you can see the crowd behind
the players there are many people there
watching these top players these super
Grand Masters duke it out and also the
Challenger section that we can see on
camera as well but that must add to the
experience and maybe in a way that
gukesh in particular because he's so
young isn't used to right he's had some
experience I know he played that match
in India against
um Arjun right that sort of death match
that chess space India uh puts on I was
at the one between a niche and did it
that was a really wild experience with a
thousand people watching right there but
I mean we could see it on screen there
are many people so many eyeballs on you
you need to tune that all out and Tanya
I mean for gukesh he's doing a good job
because well it's not his move and now
he's just sitting in there calculating
for dingley Ren I feel like the more he
thinks sometimes it's the worst gets
there's some irony in that
I can tell you one thing is very used to
this attention and being a crowd
favorite and having hundreds of people
around him sometimes as you mentioned
there were a thousand people at the
depth match and at the Olympia as well
we saw the chess craze in India uh
constantly surrounded by fans and by
press as well gukesh might just be 17
years old but he's also extremely mature
in handling that that is not a factor
that affects him right now it is all
focus on the board for him thing uh I
don't know how much of it he's such an
experienced player he's and he finally
does make the move as you were talking
about it that time is so crucial right
now he immediately plays Queen F6 and
this is what I was saying that the more
time that Ding takes kukesh has the
potential and the uh the opportunity to
think about his response he immediately
responded and I what I saw from our
board I think he's made the move Bishop
E4 yeah he's gone for Bishop E4 so
keeping in control of the a8h1 diagonal
this is the move that we were discussing
Robert keeping everything together you
stop Rook from coming into E2 you
prevent black spaceship from taking this
monstrous diagonal and just keep
everything under control it's still bad
for white but ding has burnt a lot of
clock in the last move
yeah no things spit a lot of time there
uh we're just trying to you know get
updates as they come in there is an
issue
um coming from the venue in terms of the
relay so we're just trying to keep
everything as accurate as possible the
clocks you see on screen are not correct
ding now has just under 10 minutes go
cash down to four minutes and 55 seconds
so we're going to keep an eye on things
as they unfold but Richard report is
also down to about two minutes in his
game so let's pull up the bird's eye
view because we were taking a look at
that one earlier uh report trying to
hold on in an ending and with just a
couple minutes on his clock he is decide
who is trying to defend it looks like he
is likely in the center of our screen
here on the bottom he's likely to just
lose that pawn on E6 in the near future
and it doesn't mean game over but it
means that it's going to be a tough hold
for him down a pawn in this end game
that said I have to say with White's
Bishop active it just looks like white
is also still holding on or at least
trying to your idea Bishop b2c3 happened
to activate that bishop and I think that
was the right way to go black still
hasn't won a pawn but of course with the
weakness on E6 H3 if anyone is trying
this end game it is going to be white
black you can think about just trading
on E5 get that King on E7 block it the
E6 pawn and simply pick up either H3 or
E6 uh it looks like it's going to be a
tough task for Richard to defend this
Rook on end game
I think the one thing he might hope for
is some kind of Bishop B8 and go out for
these pawns but it feels artificial it
doesn't really seem like it's going to
work out for him and for a good start
right now King E7 seems very logical
just putting your king in front of this
pawn and I'm not seeing it because
Bishop B I think actually fails
tactically speaking to Rook A1 I'm going
for this Pawn with check if you take on
A7 you actually just lose your Bishop on
the spot and if you defend the pawn with
Kingdom B3 not only is Rook B1 check
very interesting and looking good at
Rook C1 the C3 with check and I feel
like the white king might even get
checkmated at some point so uh it's just
really bad news for report in this
position uh Rook B1 check good Rook C1
also good with two minutes on your clock
you're just grasping at straws here
very tough position so as we are
mentioning rookie do played and now King
E7 or even Bishop E5 are two options
that both look very pleasant for black
eventually white will have to play some
Man game being a pawn down should not be
easy to defend but still uh not a back
has to continue to show some decent
technique to convert this uh
what else catches your attention Robert
well it's mainly reports clocks I just
want to remind everybody that they need
to get to move 40 to get extra time they
start with 100 minutes for the first 40
moves then they'll get 50 minutes at
starting move 40 for the next 20. once
they reach move 60 they get another 15
minutes so they'll get a lot of time
after that so Richard report right now
relying on the increment until he
reaches move 40 it's only move 31 at the
moment and report as we're getting an
update he is actually a minute and 40
seconds so the clock's uh slightly
inaccurate at the moment like I said
it's being worked on but he is down
under two minutes he has a lot to figure
out here but noribbeck is trying to be
accurate he doesn't want to rush and
lose his advantage and he does want to
use the clock as a weapon he did just
play King to E7 so that looks like a
good choice by him just trying to get
the pawn and I'm just curious how is
report going to respond he doesn't have
much time here time now these are the
moments where uh players end up freaking
out and making a mistake but King takes
E6 is actually looking like a threat
because there's no useful Discovery for
this bishop on E5 so you need to figure
it out and you don't have much time to
do it if you're richer
you can't take on F6 and trade the
Bishops because Rook F6 loses the E6
spawn uh what Richard is I think
counting on is the line that you showed
trying to create some counter play with
Bishop B8 and then the big question will
be has not a back spotted this idea of
Rook A1 and going for the A2 Pawn
because if not then white has got
counter play why does got the play that
you were looking for on the queen side
as well
right and I think for uh no Rebecca what
he wants is that one-two punch so he
played King E7 and he wants to
anticipate all of Richard's replies so
when he makes his move then nobody picks
a very quick response so we see that a
report has moved and he has decided to
push his Pawn up to D4 and I think he
wants you know he really wants to make
that next move to put his opponent back
on the clock but D4 was a very good
choice it shuts the bishop off the
daggle if this bishop were ever to move
from E5 and also now it's threatening D5
and then black needs to be careful so
King takes E6 might in fact be forced
this is the moment because once you
allow D5 you're never recapturing that
pawn you don't have time to take on E5
anymore after rookie 5d5 comes in
everything is under control so King E6
and the big question is that what
happens after a jump with the bishop
let's say King E6 Bishop B8 I give you a
discovered check I want to pick up the
A7 pawn and then we see the drawback of
playing the move d4 is that the bishop
on F6 actually after white picks up the
A7 Pawn will go on to win the D4 Pawn
it's a great point so King F5 let's get
our King active if you take on A7 thank
you for your D4 punt which defends B6 as
well and no this is just completely
winning H5 G4 and the pawn goes up the
board so this is a big problem for
report and King 66 the good news for
abusa tarab it's process of elimination
you don't want to see D5 on the board
and if that's the case and you have to
take this Pawn E6 and maybe there's
Bishop F6 King F6 and D5 and reports
saying your king is cut off so unlike
the previous pass Pawn I had where King
block hated it and then won it your king
is not going to help out so this might
be a desperate attempt to survive but I
think it might work out and so we're
also getting worried that there is a
result in the books uh Anish giri and
five minute carwana's game as concluded
and their game has uh been a draw I
believe oh wow I was just hoping Robert
you wouldn't say that
we were just talking about uh Anish
finding This brilliant idea about
sacrificing a piece and playing all
combative and then it just ends in five
minutes in a draw
yeah well looks like a ponds were traded
and the equality remained on the board
so a a good hold in the end from carwana
but you see these players they're very
good friends and they know each other
very well and they're talking about some
of the complexities that the game
offered them I mean there were chances
for both sides it appeared I think Anish
was maybe the side who had better
chances and he's probably thinking well
could I have played for more was there
an opportunity for me and Bobby's
probably like nah I always had this
under control
very possible but still very fascinating
play with the black pieces there by
Anish sacrificing a piece but Fabi kept
his defenses up and this one ended in a
draw but we've gotten more action on as
well Robert across boards uh let's take
a look at the games that are still going
on
okay so we still have four games going
in the bottom row it looks like the game
between Arjun and pragananda program of
the white pieces uh what's the material
count it's the second from the right
there three pawns for black four for
white so I think P's are getting traded
off and we will likely have peace a
Richard report in the center down the
bottom he did strike with D5 he's trying
to rush that pass Pawn up the board and
saying you may have a pawn Advantage
quantity but I have the best Pawn on the
board so there's my quality and then
next to that we have van forest with the
white pieces against Wesley so it's
still that end game up a pawn for black
but opposite colored Bishops and then
gookesh and dingley ren where did B4
come from right where did that move just
suddenly appear from I think Gucci is
trying to undermine the defense of the
bishop on D4 and activated his pieces
but it's not looking great for him so
maybe let's dive in to that one what do
you say Tanya definitely I think that's
the one that looks most exciting right
now and uh where we left it all of that
happened Bishop E4 H5 uh was played to
defend the G4 Pawn just make everything
safe and then B4 suddenly on the board
so you can't really take on B4 because
the D4 Bishop's weak and then King f8
can someone explain to me the move king
of faith
um I think he wants to avoid any kind of
queen B3 or any checks so he brings King
to a dark square and then A3 I feel like
gukesh playing in time travel he makes
his A3 move but I mean protecting this
Pawn that feels somewhat irrelevant
considering the attack that black is
trying to get over here on the king side
now Knight takes D4 at some moment will
be possible but I think that opens the
board up in a way that's favorable for
black so if Knight takes D4 isn't scary
maybe H4 which threatens G3 and just
trying to open this board up for the
attack
H4 G3 is looking super scary for black
here and gokish in time trouble makes
the move A3 but he does have good
control over his nerves so I think uh
you know a small move like A3 just wants
to keep everything defended on the queen
side and he wants ding to take a
decision here for example after H4 I
think he's forced to take on D4 because
I don't know how to fight the G3 threat
after H4 Knight takes D4 what do you
recapture with you go C takes D4
I think you could take with the pawn
looks very good but you can all stick
with the rook and after Rook takes D4 I
think Queen takes D4 as possible and the
one thing black needs to be scared about
is this king I don't think white has
enough Firepower to go after it and if
this bishop ever moves you got to watch
out for the E file as well G3 remains a
threat I'm just looking at this and
white has some chances to you know get
after that exposed black king but also
White's King is really in some serious
danger H4 is on the board we're getting
an update that gukesh he's really down
to his last minute uh so it's no fun for
him while dingley run has a slight lead
on the clock and has an extra Pawn on
the board and he blitzed out the move
rookie one as soon as H4 was played down
to seconds on the clock like you're
mentioning so it doesn't take on D4 just
defends the E4 Bishop so that after G3
you can actually pick up that pawn with
the H Pawn let's say G3 H takes G3 H
takes G3 Knight G3 is still possible
keeping everything under control
right the Knight is doing a very
important defensive task so Rook E1
played but if ah rookie 4 rookie 4 is
possible Queen takes at five wait a
second there's Bishop D3 ideas oh this
is a blunder I was trying to win the
Knight on F5 but after Rook takes E4 no
matter how you capture there's gonna be
a bishop D3 and that's going to be
lights out I think
that is an incredible spot Robert what
tactics here rookie for so let's just
show that Queen E4 Bishop D3 you're
threatening the Knight and if Queen
takes D3 it runs into Bishop F2 you win
the queen you win the house the king is
still unsafe the Knight on F5 is spin
that is game over and if you take rookie
4 you still want to go in with your idea
of Bishop D3 will ding find rookie for
I think it's the big question I think he
will definitely find this because uh
once you spot it it's not so difficult I
was just looking at this D3 Square some
pressure down the f file the Knight
being a bit loose on F5
so rookie for
working for Bishop D3 is easy Queen E4
Bishop D3 is like Queen E7 check but
once I take your knight has to take and
then G3 happens and this is devastating
this pin is just winning your knight is
stranded too far away uh this is just
game over
This Is The Moment of Truth everything
that Ding has worked for in this game
with his Bishops with this piece play it
comes down to this rookie one we see our
eval bar it has dipped straight down to
rookie one I think your on point is a
massive blunder by gokish and rookie 4
just wraps things up for ding the good
news for ding is that he's got enough
time to figure out the tactics
yeah and it is a huge help I must say
like people will always like well how
did you know the commentators see it but
the players are thinking when you see
the eval bar just shoot down you know
that there's something there it's always
a big help so the Evo bar is at -5 and
all that changed was the Rooks line E1
that helps you process that information
I mean G3 does look very strong there
are other ideas that look good and
promising for black but Rook takes E4 is
a tactic in the air and Bishop D3 to
follow we are getting word there's a
draw between pragananda and Arjun erag I
see that result seemed quite likely for
a while it's unfortunate we didn't get
to look more into that game after the
opening but it was just a very steady
game by the two Indian teenagers and
friends but I mean right their their
friend fellow teenager from India gukesh
he is having a tough first round of Rook
takes E4 is played dingly Ren will take
this game and be our first winner in the
opening round yeah that's four draws so
far in the first round for fighting
draws rookie one this is the big moment
this could be our first decisive uh game
of the day ding still having a thing so
he's still not spotted the move rookie
for or he's probably just thinking about
how the line goes uh with rookie for
Queenie for those that Queen trade that
you were talking about because he needs
to spot the move g3 at the end of that
line and we see Parham there having a
think about this position Parham
survived his game against Vincent out of
a difficult opening ended in a draw so
he's just hanging around taking a look
uh kukesh I don't think he's gonna get
as lucky as Parham
no he will not I think and there it is
that is you know the sign of an
exceptional player he saw it I'm sure
relatively quickly he doubled he tripled
quadruple check because he knows that if
it works it's game over but if it
doesn't work it might backfire you may
even lose the game but in comes this
bishop to D3 The Rook on d8 it's a
tactical shot this king is on f8 which
means there are no sudden checks against
it and that just means that
unfortunately for gukesh he is going to
lose material he's going to lose this
game and the bishop on D4 was kind of
the heroic piece uh for a long time in
this one so e takes D5 way back in the
opening Tanya we praised it as Fighting
Chess it became a very complex battle
but I think dingley Ren you know he
showed his might here in round one
and then after rookie four gokish down
to seconds needs to take a decision he
picks it up a panic decision but the
clock is not his biggest problem the
position is busted now and ding has
calculated it uh till the very end Queen
E4 immediately blitzes out the move
Bishop D3 the lines that Robert you
showed us the bishop on D3 is not on pre
because of the discovered attack after
Bishop F2 comes in with a check wins the
queen wins the game the only move that
white has got here is Queen E7 uh if you
move the queen away black simply picks
up the Knight so you've got to come in
with a check on E7 and the finishing the
last final touch which is what ding saw
all the way through after Queen E7 would
be the trade and then to go G3
well he chose Queen E6 instead and
uhukash down to his last minute he needs
to reach move 40 that was his 34th move
but Queen E6 What's Happening Here I
think that black can safely trade on E6
take this Knight on F5 and then play G3
it's all very straightforward from this
point on and you can see on gukesh's
face I mean it's disappointment uh at
the Olympiad uh there were some moments
where some of these young players you
know from India while they were
performing so well there was also some
heartbreak right in that game between
good cash and Abdus atarov so uh you
know it's unfortunate that he's had some
tough moments down the stretch of the
last year but when you're playing
dingley Ren you cannot afford to make
any inaccuracies dingley Ren takes the
99.5 if the Rook takes a Pawn on B6 you
know have fun with that pawn Here Comes
G3 the pin is real the pawn F2 is going
to be one and then you're just gonna get
a queen
I couldn't agree more with David saying
that Ding is nasty he has been nasty in
this entire game I think he's just
dominated with the black pieces Robert
uh those two Bishops are brilliantly
played game showing the power of a
bishop pair really not caring about
pawns just going for the initiative uh
and we see ding there reaching out for
his water bottle he knows that it's this
is all over for black uh sorry for white
after G3 no defense at all in the
position uh and you mentioned about
kukesh definitely a difficult a tough
start in a tournament where you've got
no easy rounds
not a single one the lowest rate of play
in the field is Jordan Von Forest who
has won this event before and next
lowest I believe is a prognanda it goes
without saying that he is a superstar
and he's beaten Magnus Carlson many
times in the online tournaments and then
you have Vincent kymer who is you know
just below 2700 and he was second place
in the world rapid Championship the list
goes on and on and only starting from
the lowest rated by classical ELO so we
see G3 has played we'll see a swap on G3
you can't take again that is a pin that
is illegal and after G takes up two you
have a pass Pawn you're going to likely
win a full Rook for that pass Pawn so a
great start by dingley Ren that comment
you read Tanya where dingler and is
nasty he's like the nicest person on the
planet when it comes to his chest you
just don't want to mess with dig
that is so true you know if you meet
ding he's the most soft-spoken super
humble he's missed a nice guy of Chess
but over the board he is an absolute
Beast you give him one chance and
there's no coming back from it he's also
so hungry for Success right now he's had
a difficult last couple of years not
being able to play tournaments uh not
being able to reach reach events on time
Visa issues it's been a difficult couple
of years so ding knows that this is such
a crucial time for him his one chance at
the world championship title happens
this year and this is the start of the
year for him with the Tata steel Masters
at why can't say and he's here to prove
a point he's world number two the only
other player at 2800 above 2800
currently and he starts with a bang with
the black pieces
yeah it certainly does and B takes C5
and I also like what he's doing right
now he's being very instructive by not
rushing his decisions he's completely
winning that eval bar what does it say
like minus nine or whatever it is and
he's probably just trying to find which
is the easiest path to Victory I could
take on F2 right away but this pin's not
going anywhere maybe I should start with
Bishop H3 just to make sure your Kink
can't even go up to G2 like these little
decisions may not appear to mean much in
this specific game uh but over time they
really make a difference and you see the
top players when they're winning they
don't just suddenly rush and spoil their
chances they are accurate to the game's
finale and the evil bar keeps going up
and up and away and that's bad news for
good cash but he knows that this game is
over he's just doing the formalities of
just trying to play a few more moves
before he inevitably throws in the towel
and that we've got speaking about
Precision ding shows Precision here
Bishop H3 not rushing in to take the F2
Pawn but making sure that White's King
has got no spot on G2 or F1 doesn't want
to be one piece up he's going to end up
being two pieces up now after taking on
F2 well Rook C2 might be the only move
here for white
yeah no if Rook C2 is the only move uh
that is not very pleasant there also
might be a back rank Checkmate like Rook
C2
oh my gosh can I take something yeah you
take Bishop F2 and after Rook F2 there's
Rook D1 the killer move oh there's a
check here Robin I'm so excited about
this line will you just uh completely
shattered my dream so Rook have to we'd
have to end up taking the Rook
unfortunately we won't be allowed to
make this move no matter how many times
you try
I'm trying to do it for you there and
the game is over uh gukesh has given up
after Bishop to H3 he's had enough and
dingley ren uh he's not gonna have
enough because that's just win number
one in this very long tournament so it's
our first winner of the round dingley
Ren the number two rated player in the
world uh the best player in Chinese
history and a Challenger for the World
Chess Championship Throne uh this coming
spring well hopefully this coming spring
we'll see if that happens but that's you
know a talk for the future right now in
the present dingley Wren leads the
Italian Masters after the first round
and what's happening in the other games
we still have two remaining as the
England's game will you know gray out
with his wind we have wow Jordan Von
Forest
against Wesley so Tanya second from the
left down there Wesley's King is on H3
I mean that's been quite a king mat and
while we were saying it's been a great
start for ding of course gokish has to
forget this loss and just move on
because uh no game gets easy as we were
talking about that you gokish is the
youngest participant of the tournament
this is his first time in at the Tata
steel Masters he needs to keep this loss
behind him but the one thing I know
about gokish is that he's super good at
that we remember that game against
nordeback at the Olympiad a huge
disappointment which not only cost a
gokish a personal game but also in many
ways uh became difficult for India to go
on and win a gold medal at the Olympiad
which eventually Uzbekistan won but
immediately after that run gokish
bounced back and went on to win uh to
win the gold medal on his individual
board so he's definitely known to make
those comebacks he has to let go of this
and I know that his mentor vishyananda
is there currently in waikansea with
themesh does attend vishes Academy
so I'm sure he's gonna get some good
words from where she to come back in
round two
absolutely a great mentor in addition to
being an amazing chess player and World
Champion and a fantastic person so
viciana live in uh Vikings really giving
his players or the three of them some
great confidence and some great pointers
as they continue to progress and right
now Wesley says King has made all the
progress in the world going down to H3
can pick up this Pawn on H2 but I feel
like time of this game is closing in
getting closer and closer to a split
point now something we mentioned a long
time ago is without the Rooks on the
board it's much easier for white to hold
because look at this King on E3 you
can't touch it with this bishop it's on
the opposite color and that means the
Knight will have to do all of the heavy
work but at some point this Pawn E4 will
just be targeted and maybe one so I just
think with the material coming off the
board that and it's already past move 40
so no time trouble that this looks like
it should just be a relatively easy draw
despite the fact that blackover made
upon ahead for the time being
but I still think there's a little bit
of precision required by white to make
sure that everything is under control
and it actually does end in a draw but
absolutely uh Robert with the opposite
color Bishop that was the chance that
Jordan was holding on to after having
that small tactical Miss which gave
Wesley the extra pawn bishop G5 white
has just collected the pawn and King H2
is the move that comes to mind to keep
uh to keep that extra Pawn but what
white wants after that is to Simply come
back with the bishop to F4 you defend
the F you defend your G3 Pawn uh you're
threatening G4 so white still has to
waste the move let's say something like
King H3 and then white jumps in with the
Knight to F6 and I'm hitting that pawn
on e4 and not very clear how black can
actually keep the material advantage in
the position
yeah it looks like it's very likely that
white is able to win this Pawn E4 and
even a black wins a queen Side Pawn
there's not enough material remaining so
let's make a move like I don't know
Knight to B4 or something that in the
event you go ahead and win this Pawn day
too
this King could actually quickly win
this Pawn or go for this pawn and
eventually the bishop will be able to
sacrifice this off for a couple pawns on
this side and that means that without
pawns on the board a lone knight and
king cannot deliver a Checkmate so it
looks very straightforward in that event
for Jordan Forest which is why Wesley is
thinking he might start with 95 and
maybe go Knight G4 check and pick up the
H2 Pawn in a different manner so he's
trying to keep his options open and I
can also jump over to C4 with check
forking the Beats upon the king so
Wesley he'll try uh for a little bit but
in all likelihood this game is level so
I think we can just hop right back to
our bird's eye view there's only one
other game remaining in the round and
it's a different story it may be an end
game but Tanya Richard Report with the
white pieces he is in trouble against no
dear Beck Abdul sitarov
he's been in trouble for the most part
of the game I mean it's amazing that
Richard is fine found the resources to
sort of not go worse on the eval bar and
keep the game going trying to find his
activity he did create the D5 passer and
I like what naughty Beck has done to
take control of that he's saying I'll
give up my B Pawn but in return I want
to get rid of what you called Robert the
quality Pawn in White's position after
King B5 Rook takes D5 and the problem is
that yes white skin can go on to try and
attack the A7 Pawn but it's going to be
so far away from the H3 pawn and the
parcel that's going to count that can
even start with Rook D7 and not even
give up the Pawn King will slowly March
up the board with King F4 still some
work to be done though with the black
here to convert this position
yeah and I think a big issue and it's
the concept of a decoy the king is
distracted by this Pawn on A7 so even
the move Rook D4 is possible because if
you take on A7 down goes the eval bar
Rook H4 you ain't doing just trading off
pieces it's an even end game right one
pawn and a king where's One Pawn a king
but the white king is very far away the
black king just goes up wins the pawn
and the H Pawn promotes and that would
be the game so you have to be very very
careful
in this end game if you are Richard
report and after B5 check it's already
past move 40. he's thinking do I take
this Pawn do I play King C5 and try to
cling onto that pawn and push up the D6
but I think there's not really much of a
choice Tonya because King C5 B4 I'm just
distracting your king as best I can and
this is an even worse version because
when you take when I take on D5 your
king is cut off on the fifth rank which
means I can push my pawn and continue to
distract your king while your plan looks
very promising
it's a it's a tough end game I mean even
with such few pawns remaining I I see a
reval bar and it makes me think that
maybe it's not so lost for white and
white should have some resources because
if black was completely winning here
Robert it would give a bigger advantage
and I'm just wondering where is White's
resource here after B5 how does white
actually hold the sand game
it might be king takes at The Rook D5
King U6 let's say Rook D4 trying this
Rook H4 idea we just saw the king takes
A7 loses maybe there's a way to win that
pawn without allowing the immediate Rook
H4 so Swinging The Rook to C6 for
example because if you play Rook H4
there's Rook to C3 defending this pawn
and the one unfortunate thing for black
is your king can't then enter along the
third rank over here so if Rook D3
instead going for the pawn in this
manner I think then The Rook goes back
to H6 and like I just kind of wait and
see that's what I'm going to do and it
might be winning for black and sometimes
the evaluation Bar Needs the depth to
consider all the options and see down
the line uh all I know is it doesn't
look very pleasant for her for white but
maybe it is Within Reach of a draw if
you had to predict your result of this
game right now do you think Richard will
save this one or is not the back taking
this home Robert
I think that no Direct's gonna win this
game I just think it's too tricky of an
end game it's not one that you would
naturally see in a divoretsky in-game
manual or just when you're practicing
for an event so I just feel like
um nobody back seems confident Richard's
calculating and trying his best to
survive I just really believe in the
young Uzbek player who has been on
absolute fire and so I'm gonna go with
him even though I acknowledge that it's
drug chances remain high but the players
they get more time they've reached move
40 so it's time for us to uh maybe say
goodbye to them for a little bit while
we take an extended break here uh Tanya
any kind of thoughts before we head on
over to uh our break yeah we've got two
exciting end games uh Robert we've had a
couple of draws but not without fighting
and uh we've still got action on so
we'll be right back we see our
tournament haul as well it's sort of uh
the amateur section has finished and
it's emptying up last bit of action
remaining we'll be right back
when I say chess what's the first word
that comes to your mind uh the musical
and of course the board game
fantastic okay it's just a sport
absolutely very competitive known
worldwide uh battle of wits to the
highest degree I imagine this is the
best interview I've ever given howdy sir
I'm doing great are you an important
phone call
okay that's not the first time I've had
people hang up for me thank you
is chess a sport intellectually yes okay
kind of like the same type of sport
physically that NASCAR is okay does that
make sense I've actually never heard
that comparison as a guy who's been in
chess my whole life that's a great
comparison hi sir do you play chess
oh speak French okay on poisson
hey that guy was walking on passant
[Applause]
chess chess yes like the gate chess I
can beat you in chess if they beat me
I'll give you ten dollars ten ten if you
beat me I
a bit
okay I love it okay I'm gonna move my
Pawn out I'm gonna let you do it I do
know what I'm doing I don't know what
I'm doing it's all right that's all
right I don't know what I'm doing in
life
hey
all right bro let's Checkmate oh
mate who's made bro I will unbelievable
you got 30 seconds for me quick
interview come on you look like a chess
player you play chess don't play chess
okay when I say chess what's the first
thing that comes to your mind winning
of these three things one of them is
real
chest dancing chess climbing chess
boxing chest climbing just climbing
chest dancing climbing chest climb chest
books chest boxing chest boxing you
nailed it okay am I right for real you
nailed it seriously yeah of of the two
of us one of us is a World Chess boxing
champion which one do you think it is
him with him the guy with the camera
yeah I'd like to say you but I'm gonna
go with Mr Man over the back okay easy
no he's not he does get he tried to hit
another guy earlier so
he looks oh my God she didn't even
hesitate from now on will you stop
making me do things in New York
and Toronto where it's cold can we do
every on the street episode from here
from now on
my Lord
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
January and Vicon say the Netherlands
for this cozy coastal town the holiday
season isn't over
in fact the most wonderful time of the
year has really just begun and look at
the intense focus on magnus's face what
a performance it has been
once again vikon Zay starts the new year
as the center of the chess Universe this
year as host of the 85th Tata steel
chess tournament
a magnet for the best players in the
game some recognize the Masters field of
2023 as its strongest in recent memory
of course it helps when eight-time Tata
steel chess champion Magnus Carlson is
back the world's number one looks to
further cement his legacy in this event
and the game's history
chasing Magnus will be amongst the best
in chess several have been crowned
championed here before some have even
shocked the world in doing so
have the winner of the tournament and it
is Jordan Fanfare winning the dramatic
Armageddon
don't leave out those poised to capture
their first Tata title
although winter Tata steel chess is also
known as the place new stars come to
bloom
Magnus one here is a teenager this
year's event has its fair share of young
players on the rise each hoping to
follow in Carlson's footsteps
the Dutch referred to Tata steel as The
Wimbledon of chess for 85 years in
running this tournament continues to be
steep in Prestige and Legacy and does so
again in this welcoming Little Dutch
town by the sea
mine Brendan it's the 85th edition of
the Tata steel chess tournament and it
starts right now
and this is the scene in Viking Zay the
playing Hall clearing out as we have
passed five hours uh four hours I should
say into the round uh many of the games
are dumb but still even in the amateur
sections we see players still fighting
tooth and nail for that last bit of Hope
in their games and well five games have
concluded in the Masters Tournament in
the first round one winner that was
dingly around with the black pieces
other games were drawn but not because
the players weren't fighting tonight we
saw some great chess in the early stages
of this event I think dingleren has got
to be the game of the day against kokesh
not just because it was the only
decisive game Robert but the quality of
play that Ding had with the black pieces
from start to finish he never really
gave gukesh any chances at all built an
initiative never an easy thing to do
with black kept going at it and found
the killer blow in the end we all
remember that brilliant sacrifice giving
up the exchange on e4 Bishop D3 so
absolute Precision there uh by ding
which is what he's known for so it's
good to see that Ding has come to this
event feeling in shape feeling good
about himself and starts well Lucas on
the other hand does need to forget this
loss with the black pieces and come back
stronger on day two I think the Anish
Fabi game was also extremely rich Anish
created his chances but ended in a draw
love on our onion definitely happy with
that result he was under pressure
against Magnus a tough one there Prague
against Arjun was a big fight there we
saw both players go for it but they had
their chances both kept their defenses
alive and that one ended evenly Vincent
another player who's probably
disappointed with the result he got that
little edge with the black pieces Robert
but Parham found a nasty trick at the
end managed to neutralize all the edge
and escaped with a draw
wow that's a great summary of the day's
action thus far and we're still created
two more games and we're deep into the
round we have some end games in store
for you right now Richard report he's
really trying his best to survive he's
down a pawn against no dierberg Abdul
sitarov the Uzbek teenager who helped
lead his country to an Olympiad gold
medal he won the world rapid
championship in 2021 and then we have
Wesley so a former winner of this event
with the black pieces taking on Jordan
Von Forest who also has previously won
this event so let's uh start with the
game between so and Von Forest just
because I feel like there's just not
quite as much life left in terms of
winning chances so I believe we should
start with Wesley
with the black pieces against Jordan
Vaughn Forest because the last couple
moves uh we saw that Knight E5 move was
played Bishop excuse the Knight went up
to F6 just going after the pawn the
Knight checked on C4 the king went up
and the Knight took on B2 so where we
currently sit black is a pawn ahead and
it's a different Pawn now black has an
extra Pawn over here on the queen side
versus the extra Pawn that was just in
the center of the board so for Jordan he
is trying to figure out can he just take
this Pawn on e4 which does leave black
upon ahead so if we just go through the
variation Knight takes Bishop takes King
takes
the pawn issue is hanging and it's not
going anywhere so you don't even have to
take it right away but after King takes
H2 then white will play the move Bishop
F4 threatening G4 check
and Tony I think there are two issues
one this Knight is a little bit
misplaced and two these pawns are on
dark squares and I guess I'll say three
this Pawn is pretty close to the white
king
and I think it's the third
problem here Robert because after you
make the move King H3 against the threat
of G4 that you pointed out white can
simply go King F5 and there's really no
way to keep the H Pawn alive you'll have
to trade it off and the problem with
that is with pawns just on one side of
the board just on the queen side the
king and Bishop can simply keep it
together and that will end in a draw I
think Knight takes E4 will actually uh
be the simplest way for white to
continue here uh King D4 played we don't
have Knight B2 yet do we
uh no we are Knight takes B2 actually
but uh one thing to note actually black
could lose right if you put H4 and white
plays G for it look at the eval bar
right it's like it is the one thing that
has to be uh looked out for because
Knights are very slow pieces they're
short range pieces so trying to get this
Knight to stop the pawn where you can't
even get the D6 the bishop cuts it off
so White's next moves are very obvious
it's just going right up the board for a
decisive game in White's favor so that'd
be crazy if Wesley who is up upon uh
then lost the game it's not gonna happen
but you just need to keep an eye on that
that's actually a really nice and an
important trick and I think it's very
important for black to not then Rush
with H4 but instead get the Knight to
the king side but again I I feel like
once the pawns are traded off it's not
going to be a problem for white to end
that in a draw Knight B2 you mentioned
has been played on the board I'm
expecting 94. and if not King H2 what is
the other way that black can actually
continue to try and create some chances
in this position
I'm just really not seeing it I think
it's
maybe I can't imagine a world where you
don't take on e4 but maybe it's King
takes H2 and Bishop F4 King H3 that way
the pollen H5 is defended and there's
none of this King going over to win it
so maybe that keeps chances alive but I
just feel like with the presence of
opposite colored Bishops you're never
gonna have serious winning chances it's
just not enough material this bishop
will always go to B8 and white can start
going after the remaining black pawns
and I I just think that in all
likelihood I mean without a tremendously
unexpected blunder it's just going to be
a draw and Wesley so I keep saying he's
won this tournament before he won it in
2017. and his style is such that he
plays a solid game he doesn't take too
many risks but he punches opponents for
their mistake so Tanya with the black
pieces in game one I think he'll be
perfectly
okay making a draw
he's not going to be superbly
disappointed he created his chances got
an edge but it was probably always under
Jordan's control with the opposite color
Bishop the extra Pawn even though a
healthy one is just not enough to
sometimes win sometimes you just do your
best and don't get enough to win and I
think this game was an example of that
but also kudos to Jordan for just
keeping it together keeping his cool and
move by move uh you know keeping things
defended and making sure that things
don't go out of control against the
player like Wesley very easy to do that
he did win the championship in 2017 as
you were mentioning a very strong player
he is the current uh Global Champion as
well that was a fantastic win by Wesley
and this year he's super motivated to
make his comeback in classical chess so
this tournament is very important for
him we see them on the screen right now
Jordan with his hands over his head he
looks like he feels that he's in trouble
but I think somewhere he knows that the
worst is behind him and there we see
Wesley just sitting looking into the
distance I think he he realizes that
this should not be too difficult for
black to hold
it should not
um you know at this point uh black is a
pawn a head but there's just not too
many pieces remaining it looks like it's
well within that drawing range so let's
take a step back let's zoom out for a
second we do have one other game
remaining it is Richard report he
started with the white pieces he played
very exciting crazy chess against his
opponent uh notibec abdusitarov but
where we sit right now is that Rook end
game it is rook and three pawns for
black rook and two pawns for white and
kingsify was played and if we bring that
board up as we dive in the last move
played was Pawn to B4 by nordierbeck
he's trying to distract the king and win
the pawn and say that if your king is
cut off on the fifth rank my a pawn is
safer now the one good thing Tony I
think we should note is that the king is
closer to the third Rank and maybe can
help defend this Pawn on H3 eventually
but the Rook on D5 even if it goes to E5
perfectly placed cutting off the white
king from the King side
it's interesting how in both these games
it's the player with the white pieces
who's trying to defend and keep it
together while the player with the black
pieces is still pushing but I think out
of nordeback and Wesley playing with
black trying to create something it's
naughty back who has more of a chance to
convert this into a win than Wesley does
against Jordan you're mentioning the
idea a B4 is on the board as you said
not abec has taken this decision to swap
off the people and to force the trade of
the b-pawn with the D5 Pawn
you know I asked you this question
Robert that uh if you had a predicted
result and you mentioned that it's
probably harder for white to actually
defend this position and you think that
nordeback will be able to take this
point home do you still feel the same
way
oh you're putting me on the spot asking
a good question
I do feel like Notre Beck has great
chances uh to win this game I just think
that
in some end games you know where the
Fortress Is you've studied it before you
see this is the setup I need in this
particular one it just doesn't seem as
clear-cut because on one hand the white
king might want to stay at the near this
Pawn A7 try to keep that in place on the
other if the king could take this B4
pawn and go to G3 you'd be feeling good
about your chances for the time being
but then I I'm just going to start
making moves and show what I mean so if
we let this King
go all the way over to F3 and G3 you
still have to contend with the fact that
if your Rook is over here and I'm just
gonna make moves that this black king is
going to come over and The Rook protects
the g-pole it's very important as you
try to push this Pawn up the board so
you see the eval going in Black's favor
here quite a bit so it's something to
note so that setup which is what I was
just talking about still has its own set
of problems and the King runs right over
it to B4 and there's no way to take this
Pawn the best you can do at some point
is trade it and this may have draw
Enchanted in some positions but clearly
not this one right so that's the tricky
part about end games is there aren't as
many pieces so on one hand it should be
easier to calculate direct sequences on
the other one mistake in the game is
completely lost
it's a very tricky end game and the good
news for the players is that because
it's a classical time format they've got
some time to try and think and figure
out and navigate their way through these
complex Rick Pawn end games uh let's get
back to our live board Robert so B4 is
the current position and white still
hasn't taken a call to take on B4 I'm
just wondering if Richard has got any
other possibility what could he be
thinking about because it's hard to
imagine allowing black to run down the
board with the beep on you just can't
allow B3
if what else is available here I think
things before it looks obvious maybe
there's some way to get the Rook behind
the pawn like a rook H7 Rook B7 or Rook
h8 Rook B8 one of these kind of moves uh
but I'm just allowing both of these
pawns to start going
to just push them and now they're
connected I feel like this can't be
right you see the eval bar going up and
up in Black's favor
yeah I'd be terrified to allow A5 and B3
come in but Richard taking his time
before he captures on B4 D6 is not
possible because black just runs down
the board and is faster with B3 Rook 87
Rook h8 ideas that you're pointing out
run into the a pawn joining in the
battle supporting uh his friend on B4
and creating a mess for black uh not
sure why Richard's taking that long King
B4 I think will be the eventual decision
here
yes and they have more time because they
reached move 40 so these zeros on
reports clock it's uh just a tech issue
at the moment we will work on getting
that fixed and we'll keep you updated
with how much time the players have
remaining uh but for now it seems to me
that a report is is working hard he
really wants to save this half point but
this can't be comfortable for him he had
the white pieces he was playing exciting
tactical chess and now he's in a
technical end game where it's as I've
been saying it's just not clear how he
makes that draw
again we've got that typical classic
chess pose of the player looking away
but the only thing on the mind is
actually calculating the position ahead
uh Richard thinking if he wants to
defend with King takes B4 or perhaps
looks for looks for a more creative way
of doing it moving The Rook away uh
Robert the kind of lines that you were
pointing out
knowing Richard I won't be surprised if
he comes up with something that
completely surprises us that's
completely out of the box in this
position
I just there aren't too many you know
pieces remaining too many options so I I
don't know what he can do and if he does
something that's maybe too outside the
box he might just lose in a few turns so
that's a that's the problem with this
position and he's he's really
calculating and
and we have zoomed in
um setting here so we can see that he
has 25 minutes and change so he does
have time to work through this position
but he's going to have to calculate
certain lines to the very end
well he's trying his best to do that and
while he does that we do have another
game going on as well Robert we've got
here Richard fighting for his life in
this Rook Pawn end game but not just
that if we bring up uh our bird's eye
view with the two games that are on
right now we also see Wesley trying to
push in this position but I think
Jordan's got this under control as well
yes two games remain we see the other
five games uh are over I would say if
we're drawn no no dingley Wren did not
draw his game he won that game against
gukash but we just have the two we're
focusing on here on the bottom row the
left one is Wesley so with that well he
had the extra Pawn currently he doesn't
he can take on H2 at any moment but just
not enough material remaining then in
the center there we have abusatara
playing that move B4 trying to distract
the white king so two end games two very
different stories and also just two very
different games so Tanya I mean that's
something that we probably need to think
about a little bit more chess players
are supposed to be objective they're
supposed to forget about the pass and
only focus on the position at hand but
it's often hard to do that when you feel
like you missed some chances or the
position just has completely changed
whereas Wesley's game was always
um pretty
um pretty much like an end game from the
start this game was tactical and he did
play we just saw Richard play the move
Rook h8 by the way oh so that is
incredible we were just talking about
how and what Richard was thinking and
what's he gonna come up with and I told
you Robert knowing this guy and just the
kind of Chess he plays he will find a
creative way to continue he plays
rokechate and we see our eval bar it
still says that white is you know
keeping well as much of a balance as he
did have let's take a look at what is
the idea behind Rook h8 because what
terrified us was the movie A5 let's
point out that B3 is a bit too rash
because I think white just slides The
Rook to the B file and then suddenly you
realize you don't really have a good way
to sort of defend uh your Pawn on B3 so
you don't want to go in for this line
you want a supporter to your Pawn push
to your army A5 is the move that comes
to mind what does Richard have in mind
for this Pawn storm on the queen side
uh maybe just Rook B8 and just go behind
this more advanced pass Pawn because you
can't play A4 you lose the pawn you
can't play B3 of course because the Rook
is behind the Pod but it's starting to
look so dicey here and my biggest
question right now is we looked at Rook
H7 and after A5 it was -3 or something
and the Evo bar is going back to that so
somehow Rook H7 is incorrect but
Rook h8 is the right choice and I really
wonder why
that's too tough a question for me to
answer to understand Rook 87 and Rook h8
the only thing that comes to my mind is
that perhaps there isn't that much of a
distance between the king and the rook
and in some lines you want to give
checks from F7 and E7 and perhaps your
Rook can come under Fire uh that could
be an explanation how it works out I'm
not sure maybe we can see it for example
let's say you go Rook B7
and okay so King E5 you're pointing out
check and maybe I can attack your Rook
get a Tempo I don't know how this helps
and I
I'm not sure what's the big difference
here
yeah I don't get it at all actually King
F4 saying is the better move so why in
the I I don't pretend to know the
difference and now I'm just very curious
so I'm really doing this for myself
trying to figure out why one Rook move
is correct and why the other is wrong
but trying to figure that out is not
easy and Richard report just figured it
out he correctly played Rook h8 rather
than Rook hm maybe it was intuition
maybe it was calculation but the
distance between the king must be a part
of it
um I'm just trying to see like let's say
we continue this line why is this
suddenly whenever King G3 looks pretty
good
I I don't fully grasp the difference I'm
not gonna pretend like I do but we just
thought about B3 played by Abdus here he
is trying to distract White's pieces as
best he can if Rook to B8 he might even
play Rook to yeah Rook either Rook B1 I
wasn't sure I feel just completely
confused by this end game
but it's really really amazing that
Richard actually found the right Square
for the rook and that's such a difficult
decision to make and just shows his
class Robert that with limited time and
of course you know we've got the eval
bar to guide us uh Richard
slowed down had a long thing and then
made the accurate Rook move and that's
really impressive what's the difference
we're still not sure uh maybe if you
take a deeper look we would understand
but B3 on the board and we thought that
Rook p8 uh seems like the ideal spot for
this Rook you put pressure on B3 let's
take a look at some of the lines what
happened after the move Rook to B8 so
you were mentioning Rook B1
yeah because Rook D3 I think that makes
perfect sense but after Rook to D3 I was
thinking that F D6 this Pawn might just
be a little bit too slow because A5 we
have D7 and now you absolutely have to
take if you're trying to win this game
and maybe it's good enough Rook takes B3
and like we were talking about earlier
uh the white pieces are gonna be
distracted by this Pawn so maybe King to
F4 and go after this one like with Rook
here and Rook to E3 something like that
very tough
yeah I'm just you know going with the
flow at this point in this end game but
it feels like this I I could see why
this is a huge advance for black because
the A5 Pawn is really just going to
distract your pieces and so I'm already
threatening to bring my rook in
easy to understand black would be
but let's back up and take a look at the
other option that we've got here so
repeat it
fours in Rook D3 was your move so what
else can be done here I'm just trying to
make use of the fact that Rook h8 was
more accurate than 8 7 and wondering
that now can you just simply go in for
checks let's say Rook B8 Rook D3
it's a rook Cafe check for example yes
King
let's go up I'm not gonna be afraid I'm
gonna go up okay let's give you another
check because I don't want to allow Rook
D5
taking a four
yeah this is this is where it gets
tricky because now if you go real Cafe
you just want to go King G3 and then
what do you want with white is not so
clear and you're hitting my Pawn on H3
and I could even go this way right I can
try to help my bee Pawn out as well
that's not out of the question
um so let's say you go
check and I I mean I I want to go this
way
how is it still only minus 1.3 like this
is clearly in that drawing balance with
proper play but
playing correctly in this position good
luck to anybody
yeah D6 you can D2
right and D6 you immediately see is a
mistake just King D2 and blacks fast
enough with the king and the pawn
I love end games but they're also very
headache inducing because there's so
many variations that look similar that
could be similar but somehow one is
drawing and one is losing so we have two
options I just want to show my point
with Rook to B1 quickly because I think
Rook D3 is better especially now that
we're just looking at some lines but the
point is if you play D6 and black plays
B2 or you play D7 you think okay I'm
gonna get a queen so Rook D1 might be
forced to take this pawn and white takes
on B2 first we just get a trade but I'm
actually not going to play Rook D1
because I have Rook C1 check and it may
look like the king escapes but if the
King goes to the B file I get a queen
with check of course I win the game then
pick up your Rook as well and check menu
and if you go this way I get my queen
and now that your king is on D6 once you
get a queen I have Rook D1 check trade
and then win with my pass Pawn so Rook
B1
is just a move to ask
White
how do you plan on dealing with this
move B2
all right and what
how far if I just keep hitting your Pawn
on B3
it's a good question I was thinking I
could put A5 because if you take on B3
we enter into a losing King and pawn end
game so winning for black because you
take on D5 quickly Rush your king over
and the white king is way way way too
far as it has to do with the a pod so I
was just trying to do something like
this where even though you get your
material back it's not going to last
very long
now after King C4 I think any King Pawn
endings are completely busted because
your king is closer to the H Pawn and
you'll sort of use the a pawn to deflect
my king decoy it and then bring your
king pick up the H3 pawn queen the
g-pawn so I can't really take on B3
we've got a move by the way so let's
take a look at what the live boat says
but one idea before we okay let's let's
go to the library but he gives a check
he gave a check and apparent bar hits it
and I think the reason why is King E4
comes the tempo against this pawn and
what actually what is the follow-up
because if you go Rook to B8 I take it
with check and then I'm just winning
and if you go something like D6 and go B
wait what are we
are we sure you just played Rook fa
check
that's what we have on our live boat
what happened
I'm just confused what he could possibly
be calculating after
King E4
double attack attacking a pawn and
trying to go B2
so after Rook B8 Rook takes the five
King C4
I think I can even throw in this check
here on a D4 because if you ever take I
just go here and take this pawn and I
think with that
uh you know we were saying one move can
just have the game slip away from you
this was not the place and time I
thought it would slip
and after the accurate to suddenly see
Rook have fade on the board because
rugby just looked like such a natural
response why push your opponent's king
forward why push your opponent's king
towards a point where not only do they
attack your own Pawn but actually come
closer to your to the Past part so
definitely a very mysterious decision by
uh by Richard here and I wonder what he
wants after King E4 because the thing is
that rookie it you've got time to go
King D3
yeah right you're actually welcoming the
king into the position and can you
forward which displayed
I'm very confused right now
and I'm looking at the Players like
trying to read body language give us
another check
okay but
he's walking this King towards C2
uh
I'm just surprised and I don't mean to
be harsh because I have so much respect
for Richard report I mean he's an
amazing player right so creative has
been one of the top players in the world
since he was a teenager himself but
right now it seems like he just kind of
handed his opponent to when I thought
I've said it all along right I thought
uh no dear Beck would win this game but
this made it very easy and that's the
surprising part is this is just very
obvious
rookie it on the board and there we have
naughty back with his classic peace
twirl there
he is so close
to converting this very difficult
Groupon ending uh he's got a choice to
make here Robert does he walk with the
King towards his own Pawn or does he
walk with the King to the H Pawn but I
don't think it's going to be hard for
noribbeck to figure this out and he's
going to go King the three King C2
yeah this feels
natural at this point and
the eval bar suggesting it's completely
over is it King D3 what happens after
King B4 because that's just one little
trick that I want to show that if you go
King seat two in that position you're
pointing out the move B2 which of course
wins but King C2 there's rookie two and
you actually end up winning the pawn
right so that we're mentioning of course
that B2 is just lost on the spot so King
B4 makes literally zero sense
and so instead we see rookie in no move
yet but King D3 seems
is very obvious
uh oh we saw ding as well right when you
know you're winning and you've got time
on the clock
you're not gonna get any extra points
for taking an extra 20 minutes home you
want to be sure that you actually find
the precise line and the clear-cut way
and quickly wrap up without giving your
opponent too many chances not a bag I
see him he's about to go and he does it
Robert he goes with the King forward and
what I could make out from the camera
it's King to D3
and it is in fact King to D3 it is a
surprising end to this game it seemed
like there's a rich end game ahead of us
you could write an entire book on the
end game we were looking at the
difference between Rook H7 and Rook h8
which we didn't even get to dive into uh
but then he just plays Rook f8 check
inviting the enemy King in and it's
simply losing there's just no way around
it and it's surprising I think that
um Richard's gonna be disappointed with
himself he's such a fantastic player and
right now he
is he kind of handed his opponent a
point in a position where again I
thought that marybeck would win but this
made it way too simple
and D6 played on the board another
question is that do you go B2
immediately B2 and then D7 and simply
move away your king
that's exactly what's gonna happen nerdy
back doesn't even give us time to show
it D7 the king will just walk out of the
rook's path so it can take this Pawn as
it promotes and then black spawn will
promote so King C2 King C1 devoid any
checks and that's just over
I'm really shocked right now
and while it looks like Richard will not
be able to hold this position we're
getting an update that in fact Georgian
has managed to defend that difficult End
Game and his game against Wesley has
ended in a draw uh we thought that would
be the most probable outcome even though
Wesley had an extra Pawn but Jordan with
the opposite color Bishop always had
enough chances to keep it even
right so Jordan fund forest and with the
white pieces you want to press for an
advantage not be the one defending but
he manages to get that drug it's Wesley
so and for Wesley with the black pieces
in round one the typical Mantra is you
hold with black and try to win with
white so a very reasonable star for him
especially because he was never in
trouble uh but in the as the players
they talk
they're just trying to figure out some
of the nuances of these the end game uh
but in all reality it was just a
naturally split point and
I still can't get this position on my
head Tanya I mean Rook f8 check inviting
the black king in like this such a
surprising mistake and I know they're
tired it's been a long game especially
with all the tactics that happened
earlier but you never expect a player of
Rich reports caliber to
play a move like that I guess it just
feels like there was some sort of a
blind spot there by Richard because Rook
B8 and if you just maybe back up to that
moment when it all turned around Robert
the moment when B3 was played and it
just looked like Rook B8 here would
perhaps be blitzed out you know it's
such a natural move to make but instead
here the Shocker rooked to f8 giving a
check a check might be a natural
movement not when you're letting your
opponent do what he wants which is to
advance the king anyway and this is
where we saw the eval bar drop down uh
you had mentioned that you expected
noribbeck to take it and that's it
Robert we do have a result Richard has
had enough he resigns after the move
King C2 we see handshakes there and I
think Richard has this feeling that he
did come close to saving this one
yes and the reason why he resigned is he
gets a queen it's immediately captured
and then the same is not happening on
the other end so it's just a win for
Notre back Abdul satara who continues
his hot streak it started at the end of
2021 by winning the world rapid
Championship that was surprising was the
youngest winner ever he wins an Olympia
gold with the Uzbek national team and
actually was in the airport with the
Uzbek team after the event and they were
all smiles and celebratory and nordbeck
is a very kind personally very grateful
for the opportunities he's had uh he
actually expressed that to me that he
loves playing online he feels it's
really helped his chest and it goes to
show that hey he's continuing he's not
stopping at 27-13 his current rating he
just wins this game with black he is
going to gain another five plus rating
points and he'll get the white pieces at
some point but Tanya it's a win for
black in round one we have two Victors
and they both had the black pieces it's
a win-win for black with Abdul satrov
and ding Lauren taking a point home the
only to decisive games all other results
all other boards ended in a draw after
fighting Fighting Chess and I have to
say that these two games were the ones
that gave us so much excitement as well
with Abdul satrov and Richard rappo you
remember the opening Robert with Richard
going for this very fascinating idea of
putting his King in the center and then
nodded back calming down taking his time
handling the opening a fantastic clip
there by nordeback very maturedly
handled opening play and then kept the
advantage going kept pushing in the end
game and finally Richard cracked right
at the end with this Rook effort we just
felt like a player crumbling under
constant pressure very often in chess
it's not one move it's these slight
advantageous position and you keep
putting pressure on your opponent you
keep putting pressure even if it's not a
winning position and eventually your
opponent makes that final mistake
because it's very difficult to keep
defending accurate directly
yeah I think you know it's worth even
instant replaying the opening because
what we had was a Vienna game we don't
see that the highest level very often
but F4 using the golden Pawn striking
and King's Gambit style at black center
and Northern back Strikes Back in the
center we saw the move F5 played to
reinforce this Knight on e4 not the most
common opening to see and after the swap
of knights we saw D4 another very good
move trying to get this queen into the
game so Tanya from the very early stages
it was just an electric position
couldn't agree more with you and we
loved calling the action on this one
just simply because take a look at this
after Bishop B4 check Richard is simply
sidestepped with the King to D1 says you
know what my King's gonna be in the
center of the game for the rest of the
game but I don't care it's absolutely
safe and not a bag decided to go for
long Castle here and I love this move B6
uh Robert because it just feels like
wait a second aren't you creating so
many weaknesses but you simply sidestep
all the ideas with the sack on B7 the
bishop and The Rook that's eyeing the B7
Pawn you free your knight you wanna jump
into B4 you want to jump into A2 you
want to come into a C3 but Richard has
his own ideas came in with the Knight
picked up that Bishop on E6 and played
the very nice Rook B5 threatening Bishop
to D5 and I love the way not a Beck
handled this position
Knight B8 we left before this move was
played but a great move you see the
evaluation bar has stayed about the same
there and the point is that the D5 score
is sure that Bishop can go in but when
the queen escapes C6 will be a fork of
Bishop and Rook so The Rook went to D5
and C6 was still playing get out of my
house said norderbeck and with the Rook
trade now we have a problem for white
the pawn E5 sticks out and that was the
pawn that black went after Bishop takes
G5 not available because Rook G8 is a
pin and a win of a bishop you play H4 to
defend I play H6 to attack thank you
very much so instead we saw that
um
H3 was played but Tanya look at this
move Queen H2 that's not the move you
want to play
definitely not but you want to try and
create chances and I'm not I'm not sure
where they are from maybe you're
dreaming of getting a G4 H4 idea in but
the biggest problem is that the E5 Pawn
is just forever a weakness and
eventually nadebeck went on to win that
pawn and that's the one that uh told the
game
yes it was even material but not an even
position the bishop was free but in came
the black king right after this Pawn now
this was a great Try by Richard I think
all other options are just losing if you
take on F6 and allow The Rook to scoop
with the pawn you're gonna lose the game
because black has a clear outside pass
Pawn so instead D4 and what he did was
cut off the black king so I thought this
was brilliant the black king is cut off
which means that defending against this
passer is not going to be easy but what
nortibeck does is he attacks A2 he drags
the king away first The Rook check then
he takes on H6 because if the king were
to be dragged this way The Rook comes
back to D1 and you should go after this
Pawn so instead of capture here
goes out for the Deep Pawn again gives a
couple checks and B5 so it was great
play the Eva bar set about minus one so
not a one position but you asked me the
question I answered it and noribeck did
the best answer of all he said he was
going to win this game no matter what
the objective evaluation was because the
players didn't know it and then it all
turned around at that moment I think
Richard still played very accurately at
least trying his best to keep things
under control it looked like potentially
he could hold this position but then
after this next move giving the very
natural check on that fit it just turned
out to be a big disaster because it
forced Black's King closer to the B Pawn
which is exactly where you want it and
with this in the last position white
Queens on the eight blacks Rook is
anticipating that picks up that Queen
black goes on to Queen uh promote his
own pawn and win the game and that was
it Richard threw in the double and with
that naughty back took the point such a
fighting game but it has to be said it
looked like nordeback was in control
from start to finish and I think that's
exactly what we can say about the
dingler and win against gokish
we can indeed we see the results here
two wins in the round by dingley Ram
with black and nerdy back Abdus Atari
with black I'm with you I like the way
you described this game it was very
controlled by abusatara when you play
Richard report he is going to bring the
heat he is going to mix things up make
it complicated for you scare you with
some tactics left and right but it
always felt like the young Uzbek player
was in his element that he wasn't
frightened for a millisecond he made
them with B6 that you singled out it was
a great choice opening up the diagonal
but closing the rook and he was able to
move his Knight back to B8 pushed his
Pawn to C6 go after that E5 Pawn which
is a long-term Target I thought that was
a real model game by abusitarov
start to finish I have to say Robert
this is the kind of chest that I love as
well it's very exciting to see you know
sacrifices and blunders and the kind of
ups and downs we see in the eval bar in
fast format play but in classical chess
you get to see this beauty this long
play where you continuously have to put
incremental pressure on your opponent
and not abec did that to Perfection
today
he did indeed and that's why he's Atop
The leaderboard there are two players
nordeback Abdus atarov and ding Lee Ren
in a tie for first place now there are
13 Rounds in this tournament we are just
getting started so when you see Magnus
Carlsen not in first place that can't
happen it has happened but also at the
end of 13 Rounds in Vikings past he has
been number one eight different times
and in round number two Tonya we have
some great matchups in store for
everybody uh because Magnus Carlsen we
keep talking about him he's pretty good
at chess he'll get the black pieces
against Vincent kymer who you were
impressed by in this first round
he played really well against Barham he
wasn't able to take the full point home
but again with the black pieces it was
Winston who was pushing throughout and
the slight inaccuracy and Parham was
tricky enough to uh to make that work
for him and he survived the game but
Vincent is feeling good about today he
will take on Magnus and we know the one
thing about these youngsters Robert
they're always excited to play against
Magnus for them it's this big
opportunity and they don't fear Him they
have a lot of respect for him but
they're hungry to play against him and
to try and beat him Winston starting
with the white pieces I'm expecting that
he's going to do his best to do the same
and dingley Wren gets the white pieces
and Parham looks shaky in this first
game yes he found a nice tactical
sequence to secure the half point but it
wasn't so easy it was not a clean game
on his part he was much worse and I
think he was in the verge of being lost
at certain points but he found the right
decisions so for Parham he gets black in
game two against dingley Wren that
doesn't look like fun and for gukash he
lost game one and now he gets blankets
Anish giri who showed some excellent
chess in game one
that's going to be a tough one for
gukesh I think I completely agree with
you that even though the Anish Fabi game
ended in a draw it looked like a niche
has come with fire to this tournament uh
he played active an active opening as
well as entertaining chess there had the
advantage against Fabi not an easy thing
to do with the black pieces didn't
manage to get the full point but was the
one in driving seat so another tough
pairing for gukkesh there and we've also
got Wesley playing against Arjun
wow Arjun gets uh black for the second
game in a row he drew against prognano
with black today now he gets black
against Wesley so Wesley played a great
game and he is a former champion of this
very event but Arjun has shown really
phenomenal preparation uh we've seen it
as you pointed out in the Tata still
India event and it was a rapid and Blitz
event but he showed like 30 plus moves
of preparation in that event here he
shook great prep in game one against
pragnanda and speaking of Prague Nanda
he gets black it's levada Ronin Lavon
played an excellent game to survive
Magnus Carlson today
he needed to really bring up all his
creativity to really save that half
point and he did it uh in good style I
really liked his play with the Rook I
think the whole game start to finish it
looked like Magnus was pressing but Leff
found his chances found his play and the
last move rookie too I absolutely loved
it eventually it was Magnus who had to
force the Perpetual down the board that
and in the draw a really exciting day of
Chess coming up and Robert I've been to
work a couple of times as have you so I
think we both know that once the games
are over it's a small place it's uh why
can't they is a small town it doesn't
have so many places to go to but there
is this one Italian restaurant that I
know was my favorite and very often you
would see all the players there after
their games were over they would be
discussing more chess uh over pizzas and
pastas and I'm guessing that's where the
players are headed right now
sounds very likely the one thing with a
small town and lots of people there is
that restaurants get full so that's a
good reason to end the games early so
you can make sure you get your bite to
eat but really the tournament is such a
great atmosphere it's so nice to see the
amateur groups back uh the players they
may not have 2700 ratings but they take
it seriously it is a great opportunity
for them to play alongside the very best
chess players in the world and just
enjoy what has been a historic event it
is the Wimbledon of Chess it is the 85th
Edition and round one is in the books it
was really a fun time Tanya so uh before
we head on out kind of what would be
your summary of this first round
it was exactly what I was expecting we
did have
a
lot of we did have a lot of Jaws but
regardless of that the two decisive
games and we had so much action on the
board as well I loved every moment of it
we saw some brilliant end game play
there's some great technique another
back who managed to convert a difficult
end game Jordan who managed to survive a
difficult end game fighting middle games
uh where players had to show
resourcefulness ding lyrin coming up
with some brilliant sacrifices in his
game we had we had positional play we
had strategic play we had tactics we had
everything that we love about Chess and
it's just getting started Robin
that's the best part it's only the first
round in the books everything that Tanya
described happened and will continue to
happen we will see the players fight
that's the beauty of Viking Zay it's a
mixed feel of the veterans the world
champions the previous winners and also
the new generation the teenagers who are
not going to back down against any
player in this field it might be Magnus
Carlson it might be Wesley so fabina
coeanna Anish giri it doesn't matter
these players they're ready they're not
the future they're the present and they
are going to Showcase their talents each
and every day in Vikings day but for now
we have to say goodbye to all of you
watching it's been a really fun first
day of Chess going back tomorrow same
time same place I will be continuing my
hosting here with International Master
Tanya sachev on behalf of this chess.com
broadcast it's been a pleasure see you
tomorrow
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]